[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this could be it's the culture it's the
music the artwork
is the people
[Music]
Deutschland
[Music]
I was just looking for myself and then
Expo came and it makes me emotional
Liz come on and join us and
right here at Expo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
one two one two
yeah yeah chess.com in the house come on
uh Harry Mack in the house come on yeah
turn your volume up right now y'all we
bout to make this happen look ah come on
my name is Harry Mack I had the hop on
camera and spit welcome to the feed day
World Championship under 35 years that's
craziness been going down since 1886
match format with 14 games many queens
will be captured the kids will be slain
check out the way I'm unraveling the
Rhymes this is sure to be a true battle
of the mind just so it don't remain a
mystery I'll take a moment to walk you
through the history I said we gotta show
love to the Masters 27 years strong
that's Emmanuel Alaska this next name
here is the honor said it's the end game
master Jose Copa Blanca can't forget
[Music]
[Music]
I'm getting loose with the style that
was the past let me take it to the now
coming off top with the clever words
time to introduce the first competitor
if you don't know this is the reminder
the end game magician Norwegian grinder
Triple Crown win to go hard for him of
course I'm talking about Magnus Carlos
sin Izzy the goat the greatest son
highest score ever 20 day 81 can anybody
test the crown well I guess so I mean if
anyone could do it then it's never cause
he's never been the one to be give it up
beyond the time to see the ill Russian
the one that's causing the concussion
peace
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
for all those of you who are not
watching this show on mute you just
passed that past that little test we
laid out for you with the hype intro but
Jokes Aside this is day eight of the
2021 v-day World Chess Championship this
is chess.com's coverage and it does
start right now and right now we're
going to welcome again the guys that
will be bringing bringing this thing
home for the next few weeks on the edge
here we have Mr Robert Hess looking
looking Dapper as ever in that sweater
that rhymed Bobby how are the cats doing
today they're doing great I'm I'm
escalating with the cats yesterday I was
gonna say there's three now right
there's three now does that mean do you
have a four do you have a four no three
is the limit it might it might be one
for each of us one for each yeah like is
this just three cats chilling we are we
are three don't get ahead of yourself
okay well uh we hope to one day be as
cool as Fabiano's cats uh you know what
is cool is our daily highlights video
where we recap the drama from the
previous battle the action is is always
heated when you when you see it in this
condensed condensed form obviously we
know that day seven didn't bring us a
ton of fireworks but still a lot of
interesting story lines were definitely
put in motion with yesterday's very
short draw following the histor the
historic longest ever World Chess
Championship Game on day six so without
any further waiting let's take a look at
what was day seven in our daily
highlights recap
history was made in game six of the 2021
feed a World Chess Championship but what
will game seven bring us we're gonna
find out
so I wonder where young will will swing
the surprise because obviously Magnus
has improved on the previous game where
where white was better so it makes sense
that Jan will have the first surprise in
this game
I do like this initial position from
Jan's point of view we see that Magnus
is the one who's going to think tank
first and Jana's not had a problem
getting nice positions out of the open
this is critical he needs to be able to
convert on his advantage that doesn't
mean just win competing in chess is
extremely difficult we heard Max's quote
has to be hard it's good to be hard it's
the World Chess Championship right but
you can't just allow Max to make an easy
Equalization of a worse position
Magnus I think played excellently to
equalize in this in this game and I we
really like this e takes D4 idea Beyond
missed a slight chance to maybe keep
pressing with Knight takes D4
if Jan wanted to
to play play on here he would have to
take risks right which I'm sure he
wasn't ready to after losing yesterday
you see the players just making moves
because they can't offer a draw yet
foreign
it was a draw as we saw but of course
there's there's so much to go here and
and there was so much to discuss after
it will yonda palmistry's strategy uh
both the one he's executing and the one
that his team is preparing him for
ultimately pay off or will he look back
at that opportunity with white with
regret we're going to be talking about
that and of course much more pretty soon
we're going to be looking ahead to game
eight and that'll be the only thing we
talk about but a reminder to watch all
of our daily highlight recap videos all
you got to do is subscribe to the main
chess Channel please also know that we
are live to the new chesscom live
YouTube channel so shout out to anyone
who might be tuning in there and we also
have highlights and clips being put on
our best of Channel
the uh the the amazing Queen trap that
you came up with the other day posted
yesterday and had like 30 000 views in a
day people loved it which was crazy
because it wasn't even a good variation
it wasn't even that impressive I mean
I'll be honest I mean it was nice but it
was funny but uh people love you man I
think they do they love Fabian what are
we going to do with our our jobs are
Jeopardy here no I feel pretty good
about it he has to play at some point
yeah I could just sit on the couch Yeah
by chance but seriously uh all of
Fabiano's uh best moments are on our
chesscom Clips Channel you should
definitely head over there and give it a
give it a sub uh if you haven't already
all right let's remind you of who's
coming up at the top of the show because
as we say every day when the game ends
our show begins today we have levonne
aronian Lubbock hammer and Ludwig aggren
again we've uh we're hoping to catch up
with Ludwig and that it doesn't become a
meme that uh that he's supposed to join
us every day and doesn't but he's busy
and these shows are are super early so
we're making sure we align our schedules
but Lavon really brought some amazing
insights yesterday with his thoughts on
yonda Palm Desi's team of course young
Ludwig Hammer bringing it daily from
Norway and as we said Ludwig will give
his first live interview since the
switch from twitch to YouTube gaming at
some point on hs.com World Chess
Championship a post game show so all
right when we come back it's time it's
time for us to look ahead guys we've got
predictions on the board we've got our
result predictions I guess in theory
that's off the board don't go anywhere
our continued coverage here of the 2021
feed a World Chess Championship brought
to you by coinbase returns
[Music]
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations
play a game start review and try it
today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
in case you didn't see our partners at
coinbase are sponsoring chess.com's
coverage of the 2021 v-day world
championship and boy are we thankful
whether you're an experienced Trader
been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
here with chess.com back in the Expo
media center after round seven and it is
still Saturday my joke before about
being Groundhog Day was sadly prescient
the players having to play two games in
the same day in a world championship
something that's normally reserved for
an American Swiss tournament uh Jan kind
of made critical about this fact but
then he said well you know if I had one
I wouldn't be complaining so much but
what about his psychology following that
really long loss in round six I asked
him immediately after his game if
anybody in his team was in charge of
psychological help and he didn't uh
really hesitate and said he didn't need
psychological help and he repeated
basically the same thing at the press
conference when he said that he thinks
of himself as being very mentally strong
but what about the Marshall is he going
to get away from it and try something
new and show a little bit of flexibility
like Magnus well as you might guess he
was very Coy about that he's not letting
us know what he's going to try as white
in the second half of the match what
about Magnus well he has this sort of
Svengali figure that's traveling around
with him Peter Heine he come each
morning and then pretty much leaves
right after the game but this other man
also named Magnus traveling in the golf
cart with him yesterday he's in charge
of music and fashion and all of the
other things that make life fun and the
two could be seen celebrating after the
game probably about as joyous as I've
ever seen Magnus I didn't get a chance
to ask Magnus what did he think about
that game yesterday in the pantheon of
Chess history and well he didn't really
want to say he's trying to be as modest
as possible now both players said
following that really long game
yesterday that they were going to set it
aside and not really analyze it much but
napometri actually basically said that
he had a couple chances to capture on B4
and didn't take advantage so we can
infer that he probably turned on his
phone or his supercomputer at least a
little bit before today but the game
today as you saw not a lot of chances
not a lot shown that's pretty normal for
a world championship match after a long
game to play something kind of placid
and that's exactly what happened today
we will see what happens in round eight
and if Magnus can get any advantages
White
you
as always we love those check-ins from
Mike Klein he's catching up with
yondapon Michigan right before the post
game press conference as well and that
interview as well as a lot of the other
stuff he's bringing us from Dubai is yet
again available at our chesscom live or
chesscom Clips YouTube channel available
on both actually all right guys it's
time it's time to look ahead time to
time to look at our beautiful board
brought To Us by our partners at House
of stunton real quick let's uh let's
play that beautiful video those
beautiful close-ups taken on a rest day
here
on site at chess.com headquarters that's
a beautiful chess set all you got to do
is go to go.chess.com Staunton use the
promo code chess.com to get 15 off your
orders during the World Chess
Championship and maybe throughout the
whole holiday season I don't know all
right guys it's first move prediction
season let's go hunting
your move
I think we're gonna get E4 I know I
predicted the last time Magnus was white
and he won by playing D4 in the last
game he has the lead he can comfortably
search for an advantage in the Petrov if
that's what Jan wants to play so I think
we'll get E4 okay Bobby I'm gonna go
with the same move and I I think that
Jan will repeat the Petrov again I don't
think even though he's he's down in the
match I don't think he's going to go for
a sharper option play the night or for
some something where he might get more
of a fight because he also knows that
another loss in this match would be
disastrous for him and I think he's
going to try to take his chances with
white later on rather than create a mess
in this game the Petrov worked out very
reliably for him in the one game that we
saw it in so I think he'll repeat that
but I also think Magnus has something up
his sleeve okay I know you guys are
nervous because the last time we did
this I was right about the first move
but you're gonna feel good because I'm
also going to predict E4 so we're all on
the same page here does that make you
feel better no okay okay I I agree with
you I'll just say can I change my
prediction I'll just say ditto to
everything Fabiano said because even
though we've been we've been talking a
lot about this just to let everyone in
on the the banter offset and we've
talked about the Sicilian because John
has played a lot of Sicilians in his
career but Fabiano's point that if you
came prepared to play the Petrov as
black you're probably gonna stick with
it despite the current match situation
so okay well we all have predicted E4
it's time for the results prediction
this is the fun stuff Robert what's
gonna happen today well as Nina Simone
saying it's a new yawn it's a new day
it's a new life and
is you know we didn't get the high level
fat head here but it's gonna be a draw
because Jan is going to come prepared
he's fresh could you put that out you go
to Walmart for that hey just because I
don't have the budget the chess.com does
for all the big fat heads all right okay
there you go Anish Gary is uh has
officially joined the sofa boys set
shout out to Anish makes him happy
because he was feeling a lot really left
out
I think we're going to see a draw as
well uh Jan's defenses have held up uh
so far well very well he he's playing
solidly in one game there was a hiccup
but he still had a good position in that
game the opinions have gone well for him
Magnus still hasn't managed to find a
dent and Jan's armor and I think that
we're going to see another solid game
from Beyond today
okay well this is this is interesting
because as much as it pains me to
predict what I'm about to because of
what it might mean for the overall
trajectory of this match I thought a lot
about it and I felt like the momentum
being so heavily weighted in the world
champions favor right now that I feel
like he's going to push that advantage
and we're gonna see the goat do
something that a lot of people don't
necessarily want to see him do and he's
going to get a dub today uh and uh that
that could spell real disaster for young
but I got to get back in this results
prediction game because if I don't start
getting if I don't start going against
you guys I'm just gonna finish in dead
last by the way at some point we got to
catch up on what exactly the total tally
is on prediction I know I'm losing
I'm sure I'm losing but all right let's
remind you that even if you're losing
you should still go to chess.com events
every day and cast your vote uh we've
seen a lot of players are actually still
perfect or maybe there's only one man
left
um I don't remember yet but there's
there's a lot of people casting their
boats daily because we have ten thousand
dollars in cash prizes up for grabs but
like I said even if you haven't been
playing along and or if you don't think
you have a chance to win you should
still head over and play cast your vote
because we are giving away Diamond
memberships daily randomly and of course
if you finish in the top 25 you get a
one month no matter what and in the top
ten you get a one year no matter what a
three thousand dollars cash would also
be fantastic so all right go over to
chess.com events and cast your vote
we're going to take a very quick break
when we come back it's time it's game
time the players will be sitting at the
board Maurice Ashley will be doing his
thing bringing on uh some some some
royalty and some feed day presidents
likely and we will be tuning in for all
that is ahead in game a date of the 2021
video World Chess Championship
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Exhibition Center as part of Expo Dubai
we've had a fantastic match so far
let's introduce the players first
from Norway the world champion Magnus
Carlson
and his opponent playing the black
pieces from Russia
today we have a special guest making the
first move a former football star for
Real Madrid Mitchell Salgado
he will be playing the first move for
Magnus
please
and with that let the game begin
we have E4 on the board and he's
sticking with it
yeah I think the time for trolling is in
the past once you take a lead if yeah
feels a little insulted yeah now it now
it's more disrespectful than just fun
banter we have e45 so so far Fabiano's
prediction that Jan will stick to his
guns so to speak the Petrov that he
prepared for this match at some point
Magnus was dabbling in The Bishop's
opening to avoid the Petrov he did it
against me
um successfully in one game
by the way Danny yeah I just want to
point out the board we'll we'll go wide
Studio came here in a second because
it's not official yet Fabi don't get too
excited Bobby Bobby gets a break threw
up a uh on the board that if we see the
move Bishop to D3
and we do Bobby Bobby the prophet Bobby
do me a favor and go like this with your
hands in front of your face and look
right at your camera you don't have to I
don't think that I should do yeah so
just to be a prophet I I will make we'll
make it an emote for everyone to spam
whenever you're right but I don't think
I'm not sure that's a great idea why not
why not
it's actually funny
anyway
Bobby actually was predicting this exact
opening and what what made you think
that he would go because it's what I
would do
okay and I I really think that he's
going to play Knight C3 now I'm pretty
sure yeah
sorry go ahead it's um it's one of the
more dangerous lines for black
wow uh well Knight C3 is not the there
are he could also maybe Castle but I
feel like Knight C3 no okay okay let's
let's set the tone and remind everybody
for what we had right in the
in game gosh I'm blanking now what was
the first pet shop game it was game four
game four so we also had
Bishop D3 right
yeah there's the other main move is um
no well um the previous game was with
Knight takes C5 instead of D4
okay
on move three
yeah main main line yeah D6 Knight to F3
Knight takes E4 D4
D5 that's right we spent a lot of time
talking about Knight to C3 yeah as the
uh potentially more challenging line but
Magnus doesn't go for either he plays D4
after Knight takes E4 D takes E5 is
another main move
um and here black has a choice between
D5 which is what
almost everyone plays but there's also
the move Bishop C5 yep which is um
which is kind of a funny one there's a
line after
um Bishop to C5 Bishop to C4
Knight takes F2 Bishop takes F7
King takes F7 Queen D5
um
King to G6
I gain this right
or am I
Queen takes C5 Knight takes H1 I haven't
haven't looked at this line in forever
so I hope I remember that correctly
but this line is considered to be a draw
with correct play
because of course right that position
you look at it you know that's so sure
that's like a real a super GM thing to
say this line is considered to be a drop
on G6 I should um I should
back that up by saying that nobody wants
to play this line with black because
although it might be a draw if you
forget a single thing you lose you lose
you get I mean and that's not very fun
you know what that line is it's
fabulously it's obviously a draw
obviously a draw obviously
um all right so Bishop to C5 is not what
we tend to see at the high levels you
see D5 and it's okay if you don't
remember your theory exactly I I clearly
forgot the exact blue border we had on
on game four I was although as soon as
we had it I'm like I was like confusing
myself because I knew D4 was on the
board but the move order was the main
line but yes today we had 3d4 94
Fabiano's prediction as we saw in studio
Bishop on D3 D5
but after 95 97 tell us about the land
9c3 you predicted Magnus would play
yeah this is considered one of the most
dangerous lines for black
um let's say you take on E5
D takes E5 and here black has a choice a
very
um
well okay I I should say Knight takes E5
is not the only move okay more commonly
now they're playing Knight takes C3
uh B Tech C3 Bishop to D6
um Castle
and black castles as well
rookie 1 and C5
this was played for example by Lavon
ronian and the grand Swiss
uh so maybe this is one of the reasons
why he didn't want to go for Knight C3
because it can be difficult to find an
advantage here
um
so in the in the last grand Swiss not
not this the one that was just finished
but the one in 2019 there was an
important game
a very important game for the Kansas
tournament where Wang Hao was playing
black and he played Knight takes E5
in this position no no not in this one
if we go back oh in the main line
instead of Knight takes E3 he took on E5
here D takes E5 Bishop to B4
castle and he was playing visionande so
it was it was a very important game for
the final standings as we know uh Wang
how uh qualified for the candidates by
winning that tournament and I take C3 B
takes C3
uh Bishop takes C3 Rook to B1
black Castle short
Bishop takes H7
King takes H7 looks like uh black was up
upon but this is how white readings upon
with Queen to D3 King to G8 Queen takes
C3 and right how won this position with
black
but it's super super double-edged
because although black has that Queen
side majority white has the potential
enormous attack on the king side with
the optical Bishops
Optical Bishops in endgame usually mean
Josh Tendencies right in a middle game
with heavy pieces they mean it could be
attacking chances super dangerous stuff
over here yeah uh well anyway Magnus
didn't go for any of
any of these potential lines we could
have seen if he had played Knight C3 he
went for a super rare line
Knight takes D7
obviously we're kind of knee-deep in
Petrov Theory here I didn't I didn't
initially see John's reaction to this
move at the board I apologize as the
resident talk about things that don't
matter expert on the couch here but I
didn't see his facial expression jokes
aside I don't know if you guys did it
was he surprised by this or well Knight
takes D7 is is probably the main move by
games but Knight to D2 as Magnus played
next
um is is a very rare move usually White
Castles uh king size so I I don't I
don't think 92 is unknown to yawn but it
it
I'm sure it came as a bit of a surprise
because it's a very rare line it's part
of the idea to maintain the flexibility
that this King could still Castle long
that's my feeling if white were given a
move here to play Queen H5 attacking D5
and Blackboard to play C6 and cast along
we're looking at a huge attack because
where does Black's King find safety yeah
it can't stay in the center and if it
goes to the king side well there's H7
potentially hanging even if H7 isn't
immediately hanging white can try to you
know bust open the king side with H4 H5
and and uh White's pieces are all aimed
there so
what we see John has played Bishop to D6
and Robert have you ever seen a position
so symmetrical in a World Chess
Championship I was actually wondering if
this is the first time a file has had a
piece on every single Square in a world
championship that would be a stat worthy
of Elias Sports Bureau I don't even know
how to look that up but I mean when I
look at this position it doesn't look
like a particularly sharp position right
because
it's a complete symmetrical but both
players have the pieces on the same
exact squares if White Castles black can
do the same the one thing that black
needs to keep an eye on is because white
moves first and let's say you Castle
here as white just to show that a queen
going to H4 H5 will be quite a nuisance
because a queen on H4 hits the pawn on
H2 and the pawn on D4 the problem is for
now that the black king is in the center
so maybe I can give a check and then
deal with the threat but if we let's say
black castles instead of playing Queen
H4 now we see quite after Castle okay
castles and queen H5 there's no check on
the e-file because the king is safely on
G1 and now you have to deal with the
Dual threats of H7 and D5 so one way to
do this playing Pawn to F5 but whenever
you push upon the squarely F5 now you're
left with these weak squares behind so
if the dark Square bishops come off the
E5 squares white for the taking if the
light squares bishops come off then E6
is whites for the taking and white saws
the pawn F2 which means that if a piece
goes to E4 you can play Pawn F3 a kick
it out of there so these are these small
advantages in some of these positions
not that it objectively is that great
for white but those are one of the
long-term edges that you can claim if
you were to get a position like this
what's funny is normally you'd be all
the things you highlight of course about
the square weaknesses White's
flexibility the black lacks Etc the pawn
can't go back but without Knights on the
board Robert how different is that
Dynamic right because you have there's a
lot less action and fireworks
potentially extremely though it's kind
of easy to see ways that you can get the
dark Square Bishops off right if your
queen comes back to F3 at some point
like Bishop F4 that's one way Pawn A3
Bishop B4 there are various ways and you
can of course put a rook on E1 black is
not just going to sit and allow all that
to happen but the point is that there
are these long term Plus in the position
for white and black while being solid
will have some weaknesses to think about
so this is interesting because black
it feels like black probably should
Castle here you don't want to allow
rookie one check I guess
it's not entirely like you could do it
but where what other sensible move do
you have like Robert mentioned Queen H4
why we'll play rookie one check black
will probably block with the E6 Bishop
uh Bishop to E6 well I can play G3 Queen
takes D4 and now Bishop C3 and white is
regaining it feels like a pawn you'd
never wanted to take yeah you you didn't
want to open the position this way
you're not even gaining material because
G7 Falls so let's say black castles
and it feels like White's ideas should
be Queen H5 because the position is
symmetrical if you don't have something
concrete you don't really have anything
many chances for an advantage yeah okay
so F5 is interesting I I don't think
that this is necessarily such a bad
thing for black because
yeah you you kind of could have the
possibility of controlling E5 in the
future or trading Bishops off putting a
rook there but for the moment it's
defended and it will take time to trade
those Bishops off let's say if you play
Queen to F3 here and maybe maybe white
wants to do that C6 Bishop
F4
and queen to F6 let's say or maybe Queen
to C7 to force those Force White's hands
to trade off the Bishops take take Rook
some Rook to E1
Rook a to E8
looks like a fine move
you don't you still don't control that
E5 square and if black plays G6 although
it looks like Black's Bishop is bad
White's Bishop is also blunted by pawns
uh and doesn't really have many targets
itself so this looks very very close to
level
um but I wonder also can black after
Queen H5 sacrifice upon yeah with G6
yeah it's a big question I was wondering
because it's similar to your idea it
doesn't win the G2 Pawn but the moment
that pawn is captured we're gonna see
the the Pieces come to life it it feels
scary I'm taking that pawn for sure yeah
why why it should take that far but
after Bishop C6 I think you have to go
Queen G5 uh for the queen trade and then
maybe black has Bishop to E7
probably white keeps the pawn in more
than one way but
it's something to consider at least so
Queen G5 in this position also looks
good but if you had Queen C4 it's so
awkward right you keep the queen away
from the King side even though you're
protecting the pawn on D4 even moves
like Bishop D5 come to mind to try to
make use of the tactics on H2 and that
feels like there's a Greek gift
sacrifice in the mix for black at some
point as well to try to it gets concrete
but it does feel like um yeah maybe
bishop D5 first and then when the queen
moves you have Queen H4 after so why
white should definitely keep the queen
on the king side
Queen to H4 and
yeah I don't know for sure if white has
black has enough compensation but it
looks scary and at least there was a
draw there right you could like Bishop
H2 check and Bishop G2 right so a second
ago it's Bishop H2
King H2 Queen H4 check
King G1 Bishop takes G2 this is a known
yeah Greek gift just sacrifice and the
double Bishop sacrifice
so we know for a fact Magnus is not just
going to allow Jan to make a draw yes
easily I I think that probably Queens
you after Queen G5 black doesn't have
enough compensation for it so we're more
likely to see F5 and I wonder
if White's Advantage here is
is purely of a visual nature or if
there's actually something to it how
does white
uh continue putting pressure here
maybe bishop to G5 is an interesting
move right just uh
if you live Bishop E7 the white achieves
what he wants he can trade bishops get
the E file if Queen E8 then
Queen to F3 now Queen F3 right Tempo
it's a better version
because after C6 now I can first play
one rookie one and then where when the
queen was I can later play Bishop's F4
and if Queen G6 instead of Queen F7
let's say you want to get active then
there's Bishop E7 is a possibility as
well oh wow that's a super
this whole concrete line you guys are
dishing out I think is actually super
instructive because
everything about this position is going
to come down to whether white can get
the e-file and get access to this
Outpost square or not because if you put
a rook on E5 before black can challenge
it then you can put a rook on E1 you
could even support it with other moves
if need be and suddenly the whole
position has uh potential also one of
White's ideas is at some points play C4
because that Bishop on D3 is not so
active yeah it doesn't really do so much
immediately
but we can see a future for that Bishop
because after black recaptures on C4 the
structure structural change isn't ideal
for white but there is that element of
initiative because yeah things on G8
it's a check the King has to move and
that Bishop becomes active uh looking at
Black's king size but as you said the
d-pawn becomes isolated in variations
where C trades for D so wow okay well
the tone is set we reminded you quickly
I'm going to do so one last time for
today if we have a decisive result chess
kid premium is unlocked for everyone
around the world old and young young and
old
old but young at heart young but
old as hard hold it hard mature don't go
see the movie Old by M Night Shyamalan
when is that guy going to get it
together like I'm serious it's like it
was one of the worst movies what is the
worst movies with a good idea yes
interesting idea they're on a beach they
get old what's going on poorly executed
I was so upset after watching that movie
because I was with a friend and we could
have been doing anything else besides
watching that movie okay well again
chess kid will be unlocked not getting
those back not getting those two hours
back not getting the back another M
Night Shyamalan disaster sorry buddy but
at one point you had it you've lost it
and this this show this show spits the
truth and that's what we're rooting for
him we hope that he gets we are we are
rooting for him we're rooting for him
you know a lot like a lot of people are
rooting for yawn we want a close World
Chess Championship Match there is the
Challenger
thinking hard about what to do in this
critical position
that is that is on the board after
castles taking a nice sippity what's he
thinking about besides gasoline what are
Black's other options we mentioned Queen
H4 that didn't look too great yep black
would love to play two moves here Queen
F6 long Castle
the king would would be perfectly safe
on the queen side for the moment well
that's what I was going to ask you is
there is there something to the idea
that the king is perfectly safe on a d8
square on an f8 Square I know that the
dysfunction there is is obvious right
you keep the Rooks disconnected but if
there weren't tactical consequences you
can play Pawn to C6 King to C7
yeah it feels a bit slow and your King
has to take a walk like you're saying
and it feels like White's going to do
the same plan anyway and now black has
to worry about his King yeah one idea I
guess that black can consider here is
maybe it shouldn't miss a pen about if
you start Bishop E6 because that also
gives black the flexibility to
potentially Castle Queen side
um and Bishop E6 is saying I know you
want to play Queen H5 so I've already
defended the pawn on D5 yeah let's look
at that real quick it does feel a little
risky especially if white puts Queen H5
yeah I'm even thinking you kind of
provoking me here to play I was just
gonna say are you are you going full
flopping is that
obviously obviously I think I'm thinking
about it F4 looks like a dangerous move
to me so I actually in a way was sort of
provoking it but I'm not sure if I
should uh it's like poking the Bear in a
way because I was thinking that
if F4 sorry Paul grew up and if I Castle
are you gonna play F5
um so let's say you Castle so I think
the idea is F5 Queen to HR and a G3
Bishop takes G3 maybe and queen takes D4
check is also and yeah also yeah here
baby Queenie too so so I didn't want to
play F5 immediately but uh I think white
can consider moves like Queen to F3
uh it's funny by the way because now the
structure is reversed if black could
ever coordinate he's the one with access
however Flex like it's way down we only
have five maybe F5 is just and then just
Queen G7 rookie eight and so actually I
was wanting to provoke F4 because it
makes White's task of trading those Dark
Sword Bishops much more difficult and
it's weird how in chess say F4 looks
such a natural move you're trying to
play F5 kick Black's pieces back but
you've taken a square away from your
Bishop right so I said Bishop E6 knowing
that I was walking into some potential
danger but also thinking that I have
this queen H4 as a saving move yeah this
is a tactically spinning yeah yeah this
starts to look
um quite fine for black after short
Castle so maybe F4 is a bit too brush
maybe Queen to H5
is the best move but Nell Roberts Queen
D7 is back on the agenda Queen to D7 and
with this coming so let's see how white
can
deal with this uh well there's two
options either white wait for long
castle and then we start a very sharp
fight where maybe white starts pushing
on the queen side and black might
actually start counter-attacking on the
queen side or
something more direct stopping long
castle for example there is the move
Bishop to G5
it does
deal with the idea of long Castle in a
very direct way we should remind some
viewers tuning in that the legal rules
of Chess state that you cannot castle if
you are passing through an attack square
that is through check so this is not a
legal move for black in this position
yep and Nora's F6 which would be a way
to try to Castle way to walk into a
check so you can't do that and H6
doesn't actually carry a thread it
doesn't do anything because the Rook on
h8 is loose so that gives white time to
make music rookie one maybe the F4 idea
that Bobby mentioned earlier so let's
point out a tactic there in the movie
you mentioned H6 work 80 E1 now the
question is well black is saying okay I
can't cast along but I can Castle short
uh but now we see Bishop takes H6
if G takes H6 Queen takes H6 maybe black
is still hanging in there with Bishop to
F5
it looks scary but
um
it is scary it is scary the question is
does white play Rook to E3 here because
Queen to G5 Bishop G6 maybe black
there's even F4 Queen G5 Bishop G6 F4
potentially yeah
uh this is this might not be losing but
it's not the kind of line you want to go
for with the longer the computer thinks
the more it thinks white is winning
in variations where you're down a piece
but a lot to play for and you're at
minimum three pawns minimum three pawns
so we'll just say you can check take on
G6 and win three pawns for you you also
take the D5 Pawn there as well like you
your choice of which Pawn you want to
get so but I'm wondering if concretely
here Queen G5 Bishop G6 F4
uh
that looks pretty pretty strong right if
if F5 happens black will probably either
lose that bishop or force and be forced
to H7 with the bishop which looks
terrible so
so this might be close to winning for
white and then there's a rook lifts
everywhere come to E3 guys guys John
knows we're talking about him he's
looking at us
um he was looking right at us in studio
he's thinking it was here
no I think magnus's choice is really
smart
uh this is a very safe line for white
this but he can he can put pressure and
this is what we saw in in the game which
Magnus won
um it wasn't he didn't win quickly in a
blistering attack it was slowly pressing
through the advantage once he got it so
here he's just trying to get that tiny
Edge and and make the most of it like I
said now he's looking right at us again
hi buddy
this is actually one of those
frustrating positions to be in because
not much has happened to start this game
very natural development some trades and
we're in a position where everything is
the same except White had the first move
and this is actually a good illustration
of why copycat chess typically doesn't
work out right we're saying if black
castles we've done the same thing thus
far maybe in a different move order but
then because white gets Queen H5 first
black obviously can't play Queen H4 you
lose your queen so uh in general some
newer players think let's just do the
same thing as our opponents it doesn't
work out and here's a great example and
I actually think that this F5 position
it's 100 up magnus's alley right that's
the type position he loves he's created
one very clear weakness that he can
exploit as the game continues and his
opponent doesn't have anything to go for
in his position so
um yeah it's a really good opening
preparation I'd say for Magnus no risk
whatsoever it's not a tactical Affair
and he gets to push forward with his
ideas and Jan is in the think tank
trying to figure out what to do and
these 15 minutes may not seem
particularly consequential but it's more
about how this game is continuing versus
the time situation at the moment I was
just going to say we've been we've been
really focused on the X's and O's here
of of this Petrov because it's kind of a
fascinating
position but we haven't talked about the
Practical the obvious thing staring at
us in the face which is John is clearly
on his own here guys so that doesn't
mean that he does I mean obviously
strong chess players recognize that okay
with some accurate moves here black
should be fine I mean you look at the
position optically it's completely
symmetrical you feel like with the right
approach there's no way white should
have something super concrete that said
we've been pointing out a bunch of
variations one after the other where
actually the fact that it's totally
symmetrical and it's been a copycat game
can be very dangerous with one with one
wrong slip up right so I mean I just
feel like we haven't actually pointed
out the obvious factor which is hey Jan
is clearly out of opening preparation
here he seems to be thinking I actually
want to say the move uh that Magnus
played on move seven Knight D2 which
surprised us a bit yeah
um is very clever so if we go back to
that moment and to explain why Knight to
D2
is more clever than castling first yep
if I were to Castle First bishop D6 is
the move and now Knight to D2
here I believe that black can Castle
and if white takes on e4 in any way
black has Bishop takes H2
I wanted to play I just want to point
out for everyone the reason Queen H4
first doesn't work is because of f4
blocking the bishop and the queen so you
have to play it maybe that's also okay
for black but yeah this is
thank you
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
no
no no no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
everybody
[Music]
hi pop hi Danny hi Robert hello Daniel
H5 was played on move nine
while we were at the break
that is a shocking move
um okay but I I have a feeling that it's
like you don't play this without
preparation
uh so I I
mean I would be amazed and Incredibly
impressed if
Jan just played this movie over the
board because it looks so weird you
allow rookie one and uh you're going to
play King f8
um but I just want to say H5 that can
only mean one thing
yeah
that's a happy Hikaru yeah
oh gosh they're lifting closely you can
hear the sound of a million chest
pundits on Twitter saying Danny broke
Fabi yes I was about to say it myself
broken Bobby by the way explain the
happy Hikaru reference
um
well
[Laughter]
it made more sense in my head
okay
um but we're all happy to see age we're
all happy no I I will I will translate
the happy Hikaru that's what I've been
doing for years which is that this is
suggestive of a couple things one
regardless of the final result we're
gonna have a fight today something
Dynamic on the board is coming and I
assume that's why Hikaru is happy
yeah yeah this is this is a huge fight
already yeah we were looking at Short
Castle Queen H5 F5 yep it looked like
Magnus would have a bit of a pull there
but we weren't getting super excited
over the position because right it's his
advantages of a static nature yeah
um and you know we we can get excited
over long grinds if that happens but
after H5 we're not looking at that
possibility yeah now we're looking at a
fight between
um why keeping Black's King in the
center because I think after rookie when
he's going to play King FH it's the only
move really right let's explain why
Bishop B6 is no bueno
um I think that you can play Bishop F5
here yeah you're just gonna pile and pin
piece and for the same reason Bishop E7
uh would
would be a problem as well because
you're putting your Bishop into a pin
you can win Bishop G5 Bishop B4
depending on the circumstance and yeah
this is no fun for black so king of f8
will be the move on rookie one let's
analyze that and the point for black the
point of H5 is we saw lines before where
black plays Queen to H4 uh at some point
white plays G3 black takes that pawn and
white plays Bishop C3 and now that H
Pawn if black plays Queen to G4 after
that supports the queen and um we can
see that for example a line like Queen
to F3 here
black also has a move Bishop to G4
potentially maybe that's but the queen
to H4 uh makes a lot of sense G3
Queen takes D4
Bishop to C3 Queen to G4 now we see that
H Pawn becomes uh a useful thing not
only in supporting the queen potentially
on G4 but also as a battery in Ram
if white takes on D5 suddenly we have
Bishop C6 and uh and potentially H4
coming down the board wow and what game
this could be right and we might in this
case see you know a trade of Queens at
some point because white is is worried
that well if there's not a trade of
Queens then there's potentially a mating
attack on the king side yep so how does
white deal with this
um
this idea of H5 I think Magnus is
churning through very precise variations
now because this is all about
calculation yep
yeah and they move H5 to begin with
while it did catch us off guard there
are positions in the French defense and
the caracon where you do make this move
H5 but it's not standard to have the
King sitting on E8 because our first
instinct is give it a check and then
either you have to retreat or block it
in a way that you don't want and the
alternative is go king of fate and you
lose your right to Castle but as we're
seeing perhaps the king can sit
comfortably on f8 even if white can
initiate uh some sort of direct threats
that black
fends off one by one and then as five
and I was saying maybe a queen trade
could happen if black organizes is peace
in the way we bring the queen to G4 and
if white can't avoid the queen trade
then black has no actual weaknesses in
the position and I was going to
highlight another point which is that
the king gonna fade and a lot of those
lines also guards the G7 Pawn so you're
a little more I guess willing to grab D4
that might be an argument for why y
doesn't play rookie one right uh yeah so
in a lot of lines the king is actually
you could argue
better on f8 right and so despite the
fact that you lose the right to Castle
maybe moves like Queen F3 first or what
Magnus is actually thinking about you
can't Castle anyway for black because if
you castle Yeah you drop the H5 Pawn
right well you could guess along if you
give me a move but yeah absolutely but
the thing is you typically give a check
right if black is about to escape with
the King otherwise you can keep it under
your reserve so I think that in the
initial position with the queen on D1
what Max is thinking about is like well
do I want to throw in the check do I
want to move Pawn to C3 potentially to
defend the D4 pawn and then also you can
play Queen B3 so your queen can come
from different angles depending on how
black reacts because one of the ideas
we've been talking about is for black
putting that Bishop on E6 but if you
bring your Bishop away from the queen
side maybe White's Queen is better
suited on the queen side so it's just
keeping your options open and
black at some point will threaten or in
fact play Queen to H4 and so we have to
be ready for that at all times and we
know the D4 Pawn is hanging is it really
a threat for black to capture that pawn
D4 that opens up the position when you
have a king in the center you typically
don't want to open the position up
unless you can con excuse me
concretely that's all and concretely
yeah can concretely figure out a way to
escape and Salvage the remaining
position well you make a good point with
C3 which is that you you don't have to
check this King to take away the right
to Castle black took away his own right
to castle with the move H5 right so a
move like C3 overprotecting D4 keeping
your options open
black black is not castling short here
anytime soon it would it would lose on
the spot so I like C3 a lot the more we
talk about it I think you can also start
with rookie one and then C3 I think
black is probably not castling in this
game and if he does so it's to Castle
long and that actually wouldn't be a
good sign for white because H5 clearly
um signifies that that black is going
for an attack if the king is not in the
center so if black is allowed to cast
along that's been a huge success for him
so you're still advocating for the check
despite the fact that the king might
actually be useful on a face I am
wondering about the move C4 here uh you
mentioned it earlier and now we're
looking at the center I was wondering
the same uh because as you mentioned
with the King on E8 G7 is potentially
hanging so an average or queen to H4 if
black were to play that G3 Queen takes
D4 white has this bishop C3 move and G7
false this does not look fun for black
and we'll just show even in lines where
the Queens come off the board this is
still not good lines like this you take
on G7 with a Tempo on The Rook you
thread and check next yeah probably why
I would have some edge here yeah it
might not be very much of an edge but it
looks like something
I'm wondering after C4
if black can play D takes E4 first
Bishop takes C4 now Queen H4
uh maybe
yeah G3 Queen takes D4
and it gets very sharp I can throw in
the rookie one check or maybe Queen to
each yeah 22 check allows you to play
Bishop C3 next
and then we have this queen to G4 it's
it's difficult to evaluate because white
has some temporary temporary initiative
but black is a pawn and if the Queens
get traded black is simply better
so it it gets rather concrete Maybe
after Queen 64 White had something more
promising than this it's funny because
this was such a I don't want to call it
a tame looking position but if you're
just tuning in many are as this Sunday
is getting started welcome to game 8 in
the 2021 vide World Chess Championship
this position here was completely
symmetrical
not to say that there weren't a lot of
really accurate details that we were
diving into but suddenly with H5 the the
game takes on a whole new life where
despite the Symmetry on the D file
what do they say these days find the
beauty and repetition find the beauty
and symmetry
I'm making that up yeah you didn't need
to preface it with the beauty and
repetition if you're just gonna make one
for yourself
that yeah that is well timed for sure
uh we need a niche to say as much but
yeah this position right now there are
not many pieces even staring at each
other right we have the interesting note
of the D file being completely filled up
but other than that there's no tension
in the position so the move C4 is one
that could give you an isolated pawn and
likely will but because Black's King is
in the center it makes perfect sense you
want to sort of pounce in this moment
and say your King's not getting the
queen side because the worst thing you
could do as white is allow the black
king to escape the queen side and then
also isolate your own Pawn that feels
like it does open the C file which is
good for a rook but Black's King will be
safe and now you have a weakness in your
position they need to deal with in
addition to these Queen H4 threats so
yeah I think that if white can get
Rookie one check or a check of e-file
and break open the position for the
Bishops that would be an ideal scenario
for Magnus but now I have to ask and
Bobby you ask you in particular
at what point does Magnus have to like
sort of show some restraint because if
he wants to just nurse his lead and win
the World Championship
in a quiet fashion versus taking any
risks like what would you do as you know
if you were in Max's corner like would
you recommend going for C4 or something
a little more calm
um I wouldn't think about the match
situation I would just think about what
the best move is because that's the move
which will give you the best chances for
victory without putting you under risk I
don't feel like white
um if white is taking risk in this
position it probably means that
something bad has happened because that
means that white has abandoned the king
side to allow let's say like if we go
into a particular line to to demonstrate
this if white plays Rook T1 King to f8
C3
Queen which looks very natural Queen to
H4 G3 Queen to G4 and if white were to
make a move like a queen to B3 here
now why it's taking risk I think
significantly because of H4
and and it's a very serious attack
um so I think that if white take takes
risk it's because he made a bad move
everybody makes good moves he can keep a
slight Advantage without
um Queen to E1 was good I imagine I
moved to you before I was I was waiting
for you to finish and then of all the
moves predicted we predicted how many
like five or six in this position nobody
said Queen no no but what's funny about
this is I was mentioning Queenie one
checked him during what when we were on
break and I was like half joking about
it but not in this exact position Queen
he won but at some point you might play
Queen E1 because then you can meet Queen
H4 like F4 and try to trade the Queens
but Queenie one has an added benefit
that if you play King of f8 yeah there's
Bishop B4 so that is clearly one of
Max's ideas but when I see Queen E1 I'm
probably less likely to play King f8
because your Queen's blocking your Rooks
from getting the same square
yeah you know so uh the reason uh why
white wants to trade those dark Square
Bishops uh as Robert mentioned is
because the Bishops on D3 and D6 are the
good Bishops even though it looks like
well all aren't all the Bishops pretty
much the same in this position the ones
on D3 and D6 are the ones that aim at
the king side the ones on D2 and D7
don't really have many targets so if
white were to trade those Bishops and
let's say uh black makes a move like
Queen F6 white takes takes and
um makes move let's say queen to D2
which doesn't look like anything super
special but now white has that E5 square
and the better bishop and if white is
able when I say E5 Square let's say
white plays Rook a e one next and plants
to Rook on E5
no Bishop can kick that Rook Off The
Square black would have to either trade
it off with another Rook changing the
pawn structure or kick it off with F6
weakening the king side and F6 is not a
move that you necessarily want to play
especially in this position so the
reason the bishop D3 is so good compared
to the bishop D7 is that Bishop is
really aiming at Black's King side the
king can't go to H7 for example because
of that if black plays G6 he's putting
pawns on light squares where the bishop
is aiming at and why it might even
consider you know F4 F5 at some point
using the fact that that white has more
of an aggressive position uh so I feel
like King to f8 allowing the trainer
Bishops is not what black wants to do I
think
a more natural way of playing is to try
to trade the Queens off
um and so there's a very natural move
Queen to E7
that suggests the trade of Queens in in
the near future because well I I don't
see how white wants to avoid this you
can play Bishop to E3 but then you you
allow black to develop very comfortably
maybe long Castle maybe even short
Castle I know we said this wouldn't
happen but why is short castling so bad
now it's not anymore when the queen
isn't hitting H5 so I I've rescind my
statements the black will never Castle
short I did not anticipate the queen
moving to E1 so I think that White's
idea after Queen D7 although maybe it's
uh not necessarily necessarily his idea
but one which makes a lot of sense is
Bishop Bishop to G5
um where's the queen tree with Tempo
because if F6 that allows Bishop G6
probably not what you want
yeah if and you could play like this but
maybe Magnus feels there's some slight
edge here although if black plays F6
king of seven next trades with all the
works on the D file I feel like the edge
is extremely minimal so I wonder what
Magnus is planning after Queen to E7
well is it possible that even though
your answer to hess's question at what
point are you showing a little bit of uh
you know reservation is actually a
little bit of what Magnus was thinking
here I mean obviously he spent a lot of
time digesting Jan's H5 before
committing Queen E1 which as you said
probably is going to lead us to the
offer of an end game maybe Magnus is
like look
I'd rather go for that two result
position however minimal my winning
chances are then play this sharp
attacking game where we might actually
see yawn attack the king side with Pawn
H5 yeah but there are some end games
this is very far down the line we're
having the pawn H5 is a bad thing
because if we can see some trades happen
yeah like let's and it's hard to
visualize but if we get all the Rooks
and the Bishops off like we'll go
somewhere closer but the white king can
start snaking up the king side and
having your Pawn being Advanced makes it
easier to approach so that's just one of
those things that I mean this actually
is not going to be a good illustration
but it's hard to make it happen but I'm
just trying to
suggest that having ponds that are more
advanced they stick out and are closer
to enemy pieces which can come under
Fire so actually we go to Queen E1 check
Queen E7 one idea that is none of the
questions of A3 because the point of A3
is to go Bishop B4 you can't play A5 is
black because I can take your Pawn A5 so
you can't stop me from doing that my
queen is still on the board and
protecting the square and if you Castle
Queen side let's say I can play this
move Bishop B4 and what I'm trying to
accomplish as white is if we trade
Queens on E1 I'll take with the aphro if
you trade Bishops on B4 I'll take with
the a pawn now I have a clear Target on
A7 now I have the E file and this is the
type position I was trying to mention
that your Pawn H5 it sticks out so even
if white you know puts H3 King H2 King
G3 this is more with the Rooks off the
board I can actually approach your pawn
and in some end games that pawn being
Advanced is a really really bad thing
for black
or in this specific position white may
even try to fix that Upon A Tribe we
spoke about the Bishops already
uh more of Black's pawns are on light
squares than
um than White's Pawn so that those pawns
on light squares are a target for white
slide squared Bishop the H5 pawn and D5
Pawn in particular D5 is pretty hard to
Target but in the long term if all the
Rooks are traded off why is King might
go H2 G3 F4 a bishop on E2 attacks H5
and maybe the king will go to G5 to to
keep attacking black king side so uh
White would have some advantage in this
position maybe not enough to win but
certainly enough to put significant
pressure on yawn and with this exact
Pawn structure actually when I with the
King coming F4 white plus F3 G4 and you
try to create an outside pass pawn and
this is very long term so I'm thinking
down the line what might Magnus be
hoping for and I think it's this that
actually if Black's King castles the
queen side in many of these end games
white can go for the king side and it
doesn't look like much with even
material same number of Pawns nothing is
under Fire here but these are these
long-term ideas that you get very
uncomfortable when You Face them and
I've seen Magnus win so many positions
like this because he sees the future in
a way and Bobby Fischer was renowned for
this what pieces do I want to trade
where do I want to take this game and
where will I still have chances
remaining even if most of the
liquidation occurs and this end game
despite you see the evaluation off the
side it says about level slightly better
for white no it's slightly better for
white in a way that black has to be very
careful because if I can break free an
outside pass Pawn or take over an open
file that's where black gets in trouble
and Fabiano made the point Bishop on D3
far better than the bishop on D7 Bishop
on D7 a defensive piece the bishop on D3
will start attacking pawns and force
some concessions out of black
it's actually a really instructive line
you just gave again just to back it up
Queen E7 not not Bishop B3 was that even
a move we mentioned no it was A3
and again this this whole idea of
heading into an end game where you can
visualize the change in structure the
future of the a file the future of the
e-file belonging to White fascinating
stuff but that's what it takes to win
World Chess Championship Games as Magnus
said in his uh game five uh or game six
interview right you got to be willing to
squeeze out the smallest of advantages
why young hasn't moved yet yeah because
Queen E7 stops Bishop before right now
but he's trying to think down the line
like if these trades happen if that
position occurs what am I to do and it's
not that the position is overwhelming
Jan knows he should be fine at the
moment but that's what happens in chess
you have to think how am I going to feel
15 moves from now as you start
visualizing the future prospects yeah
I'm actually wondering after Queen E7
um
A3 seems like a good positional idea to
to play Bishop before uh but we can also
implement it in a slightly different
version I'm wondering about the move
Queen takes E7 here instead of A3 which
looks like the most you know by the way
we do have king of Fate on the board so
Jan committing to the middle game which
perhaps given all the lines we're
looking at makes the most sense that
that end game would really offer a
squeezable position for Magnus at least
here the Dynamics of the Queens being on
the board and the potential tactics we
consistently looked at at least stay but
let's go back to your line Fabi just to
show again Queen E7
uh yeah well I think King fa is more
interesting now okay let's go for that
all right because I I mean queen E7 we
can discuss different end games all day
and the slight uh pull my white white
might may have but uh king of Fate is
very interesting it shows Jan's
intention to keep the game double edged
yeah to keep three results potentially
on the board but I don't
I I don't really like it because after
Bishop to B4
uh it feels like white is the one having
all the fun here and I think black
should play Queen to F6
black and maybe also Play Bishop E6 but
in fact I think the bishop is better on
D7 than E6 because after Bishop B6 maybe
y just plays F4 immediately and like
Bishop will get kicked again and white
keeps getting space on the king side so
so I think he probably wants to play
Queen to F6 is there any merits of Rook
H6 as well
Rook H6 yeah that that makes sense
um
it raises a typical question where is
The Rook better because on on the H file
it wasn't doing much but it was kind of
a defensive piece on the D file it's
also a bit weirdly placed but I guess
it's more active
um but also it it uh might run into
Bishop D6 Rook D6 Queen E5 you can't
play G6 I'm yeah you don't you certainly
uh wouldn't want to play G6 here it's
not Checkmate immediately but your king
gets forced out into the open yeah this
is this is I I just don't this is
probably winning for white or close to
it so
so not G6 but after Queen to H4 maybe
black White's Queen on E5 becomes too
much of a liability and will get kicked
around and probably forced to retreat to
G3 and trade Queens probably not what
white wants
um because we'll have just too many
simplifications wow but now Queen so why
king of fade first
I I don't know
I assume let's go back to Queen Seven
immediately so at least now we do go
back to it let's at least understand his
intentions
um I think that he was worried about
Queen takes E7 because it's concretely
potentially a bit dangerous if King King
takes these out king takes E7 Rook a to
E1 King F6 yeah I think he was probably
worried about this but I was wondering
how does white continue because H4
threatens mate
in in Checkmate in one almost Checkmate
but after Bishop F5 black is actually
happy to trade those Bishops off even
though the king looks a little bit
vulnerable I don't see a way for white
to take advantage of it
um there is potentially Bishop G5 King
to G6 trade on F5 King F5 Bishop to E7
maybe Black's structure gets damaged but
after Rook H to E8
um Bishop takes D6 he takes D6 although
we have these Double D pawns okay I
don't think it matters much if Black's
King is actually pretty good pretty
active what's kind of funny though
before the bishop trade the dark sir
Bishop trade this is what we're talking
about what Magnus wants but now would be
good for young right because it would be
a dark Square Bishop against a D4 and H4
Pawn so the these principles are very
important for both sides in a position
where you have uh the bishop pair it
looks better for young when you take a
king from f8 and put it on F5 or V8 and
put it on F5 so yeah the king position
is all the difference so maybe he saw
something here which concerns him but I
don't really see what it is because
besides H4 running checkmate
well white doesn't really have any
Targets and black is one move away from
playing Bishop five trading Bishops or
even starting to gain space H4 and that
King on F6 is potentially very well
placed so I'm a bit surprised by his
choice
yeah they don't really seem to work in
combination with one another I mean
Queenie one check we understood the plan
either trade Queens try to trade darks
for Bishops but he allowed the tread
Dark Soul bishop and then plays Queen E7
so to me that's just kind of strange but
I think white wants to keep the Queens
on the board right I would I would take
on D6 for sure I know that we were
talking about end games where one might
have a pull but I think a middle game is
a more promising thing for white and we
mentioned Queen to D2 here I'm not white
white is a of course not forced in his
choice to put the queen on any Square uh
White has
so many countless moves even F4 makes
sense to me
although I would I would wait with this
move in general I think F4 and F5 is an
idea because once white gained space
we've seen this in other games
it might not seem like you know uh this
space gaming gaining
um
maneuver
really does anything
just the fact that white has more space
is an advantage in and of itself yeah
but I would still wait and play Move
Like Queens D2 here stay a bit more
flexible
it's just sort of strange because we
were trading Queens because Black forced
White's hand to trade Queens after Queen
E7 initially but as you're saying here
you could take on D6 move your queen out
the way and connect your Rooks and black
Brooks are not connected and playing F6
is going to be difficult for black and
playing G6 ever runs right into your F4
F5 idea so I am confused by the decision
making here by Yan it's not that his
position is that terrible but the
combination of the last couple moves he
could have started with Queen E7 but
he's giving white more options and I
think those options are favorable for
Magnus yeah
Magnus is about to make his move it
would seem
he doesn't look entirely pleased but I I
do think that after Queen E1 was he
really hoping for more than this I
I think that this is uh
pretty much the maximum Advantage he
could get after playing the move Queen
to E1 so let's look a bit deeper in this
position because I'm wondering how black
approaches it not necessarily concretely
but
strategically after Bishop D6 Queen D6
Queen D2 okay
um because does he play F6 did she oh I
was about to make the move and it
snapped out of my hand and played Bishop
takes T6 that's because the dgt
feed came in and that revealed magnus's
move which was Bishop takes D6 so it's
on the board yeah I think Magnus is
correct to keep the Queens on Queen D6
and let's say queen to D2 because that
feels like the most natural move to me
and
not getting into exactly Black's most
precise way of approaching the position
here how does he play it strategically
does he go for G6 King G7 or does he go
for F6 King F7 because he needs to get
the king out of the center one way or
another or actually does he go for
Robert's sort of idea to play Rook H6
and try to get the Rook to the e-file
and put the 1980 thing on G8 I'm gonna
work it it develops itself a little bit
artificially but
maybe that's actually the right approach
for black to develop to work like that
normally the risk of that is obviously a
rook on H6 and a rook on the back rank
are disconnected from challenging the
only open file but I guess if the E6
squares is so strong for black
you can play it yeah I'm starting to
wonder though with that King sitting on
f8 if black is in time to do things like
that because we're like let's say you
play Rook H6 and white plays Rook to E1
let's go over the a-rook and you'll Rook
E6
so one thing I'm thinking about do I go
Queen G5 to induce G6 another thing at
some point is can I play Rook to E5
because uh sorry after even after Rook
E6 just to keep our tactics alert rookie
5 takes Pawn takes Queen takes is Queen
B4 check and then you have to judge how
is this change in Pawn structure uh how
is it working for the players is it good
for white is it good for black because
white will have an additional Pawn on
the flank where that could be good for
some end game so not that any of this is
forced but the queen on D6 is a very
important piece because Queen before
check would threaten to win a pawn in
many of these positions and I think that
Rook h60 E6 is a good idea but you can't
rush it because the H5 pawn it sticks
out like a sore thumb
well Queen to D6 Queen D2 is on the
board ironically you not ironically
Bobby the prophet predicted this quite a
bit ago uh remind the chat that uh now
is now that you've already voted at
chess.com you can vote directly wherever
you are watching this spam the emotes of
yawn and Magnus let us know who you're
rooting for who you predict if you're on
Twitch you can use your channel points
to take a stab at what the result will
be today it's time to vote so that we
can reveal what everyone's thinking at
some point later on here
we are uh
getting ready for our trivia question
coming up remind everybody that you
quote tweet the answer I saw today's
question guys and I knew the answer I'm
just going to ask it because it's kind
of fun it was which two world champions
were also renowned mathematicians don't
answer
because we need people to answer yeah
coach read the answer well you made it
like you were asking us the question I
thought we had a perk up he's like oh I
know and I was like don't do it don't do
it quote tweet the answer the first ones
to do so get a one-year Diamond
membership and play along with us every
day uh let's remember that our trivia
questions are brought to you by Jonathan
corbla who is the voice of our
documentary episodes from your daily
chess a reflection of us shout out to
Jonathan bringing us those trivia
questions daily from Dubai all right
we're going to take a very quick break
on the other side we have hoefan
four-time women's world champion our
first guest as always our only guest
that really joins the show uh not as
part of the post show so when we return
Fabi and I are joined by ifan our
subscribers get to ask questions you did
such a great job with that yesterday and
I hope that hope that you play along
with us again give Fabi any Fawn some
great questions and obviously plenty
chess ahead to today game eight of the
fide World Chess Championship and
chess.com's coverage brought to you by
coinbase continues in element
[Music]
hello again from Expo 2020 in Dubai at
the World Chess Championship my name is
Jonathan corblock bringing to you
another trivia question about the World
Chess championships this one about
prodigies prodigies exist in many fields
not only chess but art mathematics and
music for instance Mark time enough
World chess champion candidate was also
a classical pianist
which two World Chess Champions were
also gifted mathematicians
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
New Zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has Alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep and
do all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
New Zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has Alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
try to coordinate a challenge on the
e-file yeah I mean Rook H6 trying to
bring the Rook towards the center and
develop towards E6 trading on pieces
doesn't really work out here because the
pawn H5 is loose and one other thing
that is happening is with the queen on
G5 it sort of provokes black to make
this move Pawn to F6 but that's not a
movie you want to make when your Rook is
on H6 because that Rook will no longer
be able to get towards the center and
that means that you're stranded over
there on the king side and white will
focus his attention to the center so
that's the problem that Jan is currently
facing is he can kick the queen out but
that makes his Rook offside or if he
brings his Rook into the middle then his
Pawn on H5 is in trouble
yeah thanks go ahead Bobby no I think
black is in trouble here really it's
fascinating for such a symmetrical the
structural symmetry here is really
interesting when you you feel like wise
chances are actually only getting better
and better
I've played positions
far better than this with black and felt
under pressure because when you have
initiative that just it doesn't let up
this this is an internal initiative I
mean if black can't trade Rooks is the
main problem he can trade one pair of
Rooks but let's say white makes a move
here he might for example create lift
for his King H3
um or he might secure the center with B2
D4 C3 I don't think it makes a huge
difference for the moment uh but the
problem is that at some point black will
trade Rooks on E1
or maybe white will on E8 but he won't
be able to play Rook E6 because H5 is
always hanging and you just have no way
of dealing with that issue if you play
F6 with black at any moment the queen
will drop back maybe it's a D2 or maybe
to another square and black can still
never trade Rooks because of well
because the work is blocked off on that
file by the pawn
that means that white has the e-file in
this position why is control over it and
black has no way to regain control over
that e-file white has the better Bishop
the bishop on D3 versus D7 this makes
end games potentially better because
Black's Pawns in the Central and light
squares and games are what white black
wants to go for so uh that's not the
main reason that the bishop on D3 is
better than D7 the main issue is for
example
um I mentioned the move H3
and black plays Bishop takes H3 and G
takes H3 why does that tactic knob work
for black because the bishop on D3
defends G6 that Bishop on D3 is far more
active than the bishop on D7 it controls
the G6 Square it stops black from
playing King G8 H7 because it controls
H7 it stops black from potentially
playing Bishop to F5 because that F5
square is under control so Bishop 1 D7
is a passive defensive piece one D3 is
an attacking aggressive piece
this the more you describe it the more
it's hard for me to see anyway for black
to improve his position and his white at
some point bringing the Rook to E5 in
some positions and similar to what we
talked about you can definitely consider
it and one idea like if black had a free
turn here Queen F6 would be high on my
to-do list because that Queen on G5 is
really annoying but the issue is if you
bring a Queen to F6 maybe the queen for
white will try to occupy the diagonal
that the black queen just left so you
solve one problem but you open up
another Avenue for white and it's a
frustrating position to be in for black
because some of White's ideas are
natural but you do need to be precise
because if you make a lazy move and move
C3 here for white comes to mind just
creating a pawn chain protecting your
opponent D4 maybe at that moment black
is suddenly able to bring that Rook from
H6 into the center so you have to be
careful here if you're white not just
give away your entire Advantage but you
have no risk whatsoever and there's so
many problems that black needs to solve
whether it's the pure end game with just
the Bishops and the Kings and the pawns
then the pawns and light squares are an
issue or with more pieces on the board
is white going to be able to take over
and Barrel down the e-file so no matter
how you look at it no matter what trades
you foresee it's white who's going to be
in the driver's seat and I think that's
what Fabiano was suggesting before that
he's had much better positions you know
from his games where you still feel
uncomfortable because you know that
you're going to be on the defense for
the next 40 moves and that's never fun
and you want to say oh let me find some
way to purely equalize transition to an
end game where I know I'm not going to
lose you can't find that right now so
you have no liquidation that solves all
your problems dare I say as well it's a
Magnus carlson-esque type of Advantage
right just to add not necessarily insult
to injury but all the things that make
this position difficult no matter which
Super Grand Masters are playing it's
exactly the type of nagging advantage
that Magnus is so dangerous with because
of his ability
to just just keep it alive keep the
position going and you mentioned Robert
and an accuracy from White could allow
black an idea like Queen F6 to trade
Queens
but probably Magnus is not going to make
that an accuracy
um this is a really bad outcome Freon
um let's point out for example if why
were to play H4 at some point that the
weakness of the H5 Pawn is
um will last deep into the end game
potentially even if everything is traded
off the White's King comes to F4 we
already pointed this out in similar
variations the H5 Pawn is a big weakness
uh so I think that Robert's idea of
Queen 06 is really Black's Only Way
Forward he doesn't want to wait forever
he doesn't want to wait for white to
play c3h4 trade Rooks on the e-file
regain the e-file you know and start
maybe thinking about rookie five and and
not just keeping H5 under lock and key
but also attacking it with multiple
pieces so Queen sticks this idea you
mentioned rookie five I think rookie
five here is an idea yeah immediately
because if black plays F6 white is
actually happy for that provocation
because white just takes on E8 puts the
queen back and says now your H6 Rook is
locked out of the game indefinitely I'll
just show that super quickly on the
board just to show that again because
you guys have highlighted so many times
that if F6 occurs this becomes the
problem you've now cut off communication
from The Rook for the rest of the board
so that's a many many times why as much
as you would love to play F6 to not just
hit the queen but guard E5 it's a palm
move that as we keep saying it's not a
that's not a patch that chess has
received yet there's no there's no bug
or patch fix for Paula's not being able
to move backwards although there is
something to note that if the Rook E5
for white and then black was Queen F6
right these type of positions are really
interesting because at that moment like
if we actually include those moves yep
then white can take on F6 because the
Rook can take on f6. dropping H5 you
don't want to be down a pawn yeah and
you take with the pawn F6 all the things
we've been talking about where the pure
end games are gonna be really bad for
black if not just outright losing
because one of the ideas I mentioned
even with the pawn on G7 was bringing
the king to F4 F3 G4 spring free and
outside pass Pawn that's much easier to
do when you have double pawns like this
so
um rookie E5 can't be met by Queen F6
which is important and you can take the
Rook on E5 and that's actually where I
wanted to head to is let's say black
takes white takes back and then plays
the move Queen seven this transition
where instead of having pawns on the
same files we have a situation where
white has a four on three majority on
the king side and black has a four on
three majority of you cut the board at
the D file right there's that extra Pawn
so this is a dynamic that black might
need to explore in order to actually
gain some activity for the pieces but it
still looks questionable having the
extra Pawn where the kings are means
that white can actually launch forward
for an attack and that black Rook on H6
still doesn't have great footing to work
with so to continue that line a bit
because I think that Robert was on point
with what black has to do after rookie
five is probably take on E5 and play
Queen E7 and at first I was thinking
Queen E3 is Supernatural and then you
play F4 but
I don't think this is necessary for
white but let's look at it because it's
a fun variation anyway I want to look at
F4
I knew you would I just knew you would
take Rook E6 and now it gets interesting
because white has more than one way of
pursuing this I think G6 is a very
dangerous one
yeah Rook E7 uh and now
how does y proceed here why can go for
Bishop endings like Rook G takes up
seven Rook F7 Bishop G6
but it might be close to a draw so maybe
um maybe this is a bit too Josh white
White's tastes and queen E3 is a
it's just you know you want to keep the
Queens on the board because Black's King
on f8 although material has been more
limited now and we can't really say that
King is in the center
uh it's still a bit disconnected like
The Rook on E8 and King on G7 upon G6
would be very harmonious for black then
we would say probably black is okay here
blacks work on H6 where does it go
Black's killing f8 it doesn't really
want you got to deal with the a pawn and
there there are some direct ideas of
just doing nasty things if you're not
careful the reason I don't think this is
so bad for black is because after B6 if
y plays F4 black has Queen C5 and a
trade of Queens would ease Black's task
a bit maybe it would still be a
dangerous end game yeah it definitely
does not solve all of Black's problems
but you're right that those kind of
Trades can help black at least gain some
active play so yeah this position is is
really tricky Rook E5 you know Magnus is
thinking about it but he's not just
thinking about that singular move he's
thinking about exactly what we'll be
talking about does the trade help Yan's
defense defensive task or does it keep
posing problems that young want to solve
move after move because even if the
Rooks come one pair of Rooks come off
even the Queens come off we keep
highlighting this certain end games can
be very difficult to defend and this
Rook on age six I you know I mentioned
the Rook lift I was hoping to get it to
E6 the move Queen G5 that was played
just stopped that rook in its tracks and
is giving Magnus some very good play
here
such a thorn the queen on G5 holding the
Rook down to the H Pawn
reinforcing the threats of rookie five
trying to trying to induce this horrible
move
I also think that a move simple move
like C3 might be perfectly a perfectly
good option for white you just want to
secure the pawns because there is a
possibility that wide will black will
trade on E1 play rookie six sack the H5
pawn and it's good to have your punch
secure in that case because you win H5
but you want to make sure you don't lose
some of those Queen side pawns right so
C3 makes a lot of sense to me yeah there
are weird tactics where Queen B4 can be
played not like that Queens don't move
that way but like that yeah the queen on
B4 might attack two pawns and be
difficult to deal with right uh so C3 is
just a generally useful move and what
does black do after that he he doesn't
want to wait around because white will
find ways to improve the position we
mentioned H4 I think that's a good one
so let's see C3 Queen to F6 as Robert
said this is Black's most obvious maybe
only only maybe his only idea
um but white can react to this with
Queen to G3
you don't want to trade queens and
Island trading Rook taxi and queen to B8
Invasion so black should probably play
Queen disease D6 back and then now
rookie five and now now rookie five may
be a better version I'm wondering if
we're worried about H4 but I don't think
white is really worried about H4 because
that pawn advances against space but it
could also become a weakness so H4 Queen
to E3
and uh and if white is allowed one more
move either maybe F4 and then Rook to E1
like if F4 black can no longer take 25
because fe5 would open the file so then
we're already talking about an outposted
Rook on E5 and for example if F6 here
even now F4 maybe I don't think it works
there but sometimes that's an idea I
just love you for suggesting that yeah
it doesn't work it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter forget the email part
uh what wait what is King James I forgot
the purpose pit yeah LOL
so but but I can just trade on E8 and we
mentioned the F6 is almost never a good
outcome for black because the Rook on H6
gets cut off so C3 also a very good
looking move to me
um Magnus might be low on time but I
think he's very happy about the position
it's such a comfortable position for him
Robert highlighted it's not just a
Magnus s position it's a position with
no risk
and um
so many subtle problems for black
yeah I'm trying to figure out a way that
black can solve these problems with
these Rook takes E5 and I'm trying to
better understand when the pawn
structure changes what happens and
Magnus takes on E8
which is a bit surprising just given
what we were analyzing so I was thinking
about this so black will be Bishop B8
that's forced and I think his idea is to
play rookie one okay uh he he wants to
gain the e-file in the most direct way
uh and if you play rookie sixth you can
see yeah you can win the pawn this is
the reason why I suggested C3 because I
was a bit unsure about rookie one rookie
six
uh Rook takes E6
let's look at that okay
uh Rook E6 Rook takes E6 so black and
white fp6 but that's pretty ugly yeah he
traded off a lot of pieces but white
will simply play c3h4 and uh Black's
pawns are all weak and he cannot get rid
of the weaknesses and you can never play
E5 and what that means that in the end
games that we keep talking about if the
Queens come off and the white king gets
that four White's gonna do guess what F3
G4 and there's some really big problems
for black in those end games yeah I
think I think black has no problems in
that end game because he can resign
comfortably and go on to the next game
so you don't want to play ep6 but you
might play Queen takes E6 this gets a
bit sharp and it's one of the lines they
have to consider but after Queen H5
Queen to E1 Bishop to F1
um black May collect some of those Queen
side pawns but white has Queen H let's
say queen yeah D B1 for example collect
some pawns but after Queen to h8 King E7
Queen G7 the most important Pawn is the
H Pawn Queen to C2 white doesn't even
have to save the rest of his pawns just
H4 yeah that pawn just starts to run
really good example not how many pawns
you have but who gets a queen first in
the end game and that H Pawn would be a
serious problem
John continues to respond quickly to
Magnus and and
you know it's a pretty big Point here
Black's move before The Rook trip was C6
if that pawn were not on C6
black would have this rookie six move so
if we just actually go for like rookie
six again just right here
trade
right Queen takes H5 Queen E1 check
Bishop F1 if the pawn were back on C7
you'd have Bishop to B5
and that would mean that white couldn't
go for this variation so it was very
good recognition by Magnus to note that
while black protected the D5 pawn and
that's why C6 was played that because
the bishop can't get to B5 that is the
essential difference in the position
that allows him to play this line
yeah so um yeah that's that's important
I was even going to mention black can
maybe play C5 there well can try at C5
but uh but it doesn't work out because
white has time to deal with the bishop
B5 thread but Queen takes D5 collecting
even more problems so young has already
played Queen F6 and he just continues to
not only play quickly but spent little a
little to no time at the board calmly uh
calmly saying that no I got nothing to
worry about here
he has something to worry about sure
this is not an easy position uh White
although D4 is hanging white can
consider but I don't think it works
Queen to G3 I think black can take that
part on D4
um
because after Queen to B8
Rook to E6
Rook takes E6 fp6
white might collect B7 but uh but black
got the activity and it might be enough
activity to
to hold the balance wait a second though
in the before Queen to B8 right this
just feels like black is super loose
here that there must be and now it's the
evil bar shooting up take and check and
take oh I see the move here
Bishop to F5
oh wow you stop Rook E6 and you also
have all kinds of mating that's coming
now on Queen B8 Queen B8 is a huge Queen
I3 is also maybe an idea and if Queen to
B4 to attack that Rook
um then we have I think Queen to E5
there's no way to deal with the threat
on the bishop is actually trapped which
is a kind of you don't usually see a
piece trapped in the middle of the board
but uh but here's trapped
anytime we're befuddled by the eval bar
we have a obviously obviously the answer
was Bishop F5
so
Queen to G3 might Force black to play
Queen to D6 because you can't allow
Queen B8 that's that's game over
if you play some other move like I don't
know Queen to G3 H4 Queen to B8 resign
it instantly so
so Queen to D6 he can keep chasing that
Queen but how long can he Chase it for
well I guess the question is you know
white might try rookie five which we
were talking about before but there's a
big difference here that now after Rook
E6
um if you take on H5 then black happily
trades Queens at least relatively
happily does so so Rook H5 rookie one
check the bishop drops uh back to F1 we
trade on G3 and now the extra amazing is
that every time the extra Pawn isn't
that big of a deal and so the reason why
is when white plays Brook ah check
you're not winning the g-pawn right so
black is able to keep the rest of the
king side pawns and the extra Pawn is a
double Pawn so while you don't want to
be down material Black's Rook is very
active and gonna hunt down White's Pawn
well there might even be something
concretely like C5 with threats of
Bishop B5 in some weird positions for
sure that's not going to be nice either
black may just be winning in that final
position well okay but why not be a bit
careful yeah um maybe maybe for that
reason Rook to E5 is not working out so
well
uh so Queen G3 in that in that case
maybe Queen to E3
is a better one
because if Queen to E6 then white
happily trades Queens we already
mentioned the structural change of F7
Pawn to E6 is bad even if there's no
pieces on the board rookie six white
takes takes maybe Black's King gets her
in time but white can play F4 here bring
the king to H4 uh I don't know is can
black hold this or not it's it's very
very hard to say but not not a decision
you want to make with black because you
have no chance of winning you have every
chance of potentially losing this uh but
maybe with the kick on F6 and G6 black
can passively hold this even though all
those pawns are on light squares I agree
and I think that in that line Queen E3
dragging the queen to E6 is helpful for
white because Queens lose stare Downs
with Rook so Queen E3 if you play Queen
E6 then Queen D2 comes with Tempo and it
also threatens Queen B4 check the Rook
can come to E5 now like if Queen D6 or
maybe rookie five you don't have rookie
six anymore you drop the pawn H5 if you
play F6 same problem as earlier you're
shutting your Rook out of the game and
white control is the only open file now
controlling an open file looks great
sounds great is great but the question
becomes then what so you're going to
have to find a way to make inroads I
think it is possible for white in that
position because there's play in the
center and on the queen side but as I
look at the position it does feel like
you know black is just like one move
away every single idea we come up with
if you can bring that Rook into the
center and initiate the trade then
you'll be able to minimize the damage
that's already been created here but I
don't think that John's getting out of
this so easily yeah I think after Queen
E3 though the the move which I see as a
problem is Bishop to D7
because what white wants is a rook in
front of a queen not a queen in front of
the Rook if white could teleport I wrote
to E5 now we're talking about about a
very serious Advantage but like this how
does white continue because you your
goal is to get the Rook to E5 but it
takes time you have to secure D4 first
and to play C3 then maybe black is in
time to play Queen to D6 and
um
and eventually Rook to E6 to trade Rooks
which is his ultimate goal so this is a
tough moment for Magnus because he has
many roughly equivalent moves it's all
about calculation you know Queen to G3
is the most immediately obvious one
um maybe Queen to G3 Queen td6 and it
looks a bit funny
but do we have another a better Square
for the queen besides G5
like I was thinking F3 makes sense but
then maybe Queen to B4 suddenly becomes
an issue
Queen before is always looming if you
haven't played C3 especially if the Rook
on E1 is undefended but maybe you still
have ideas with C3 because after Queen
takes B2 at some point Bishop F5 like
the idf5 was mentioning earlier can
still yeah this is something where you
give up some material over there on the
queen side to go for an attack now it
appears that black is
probably able to hold there but it looks
very dangerous white has actually played
the move Queen E3 as we see yawn Nippon
nashiba returning to the board we are uh
now looking at a position where he's
just literally forcing Bishop D7 right I
mean there's I think so no other move
here well yeah if Queen to E6 we
mentioned this queen to D2
um Queen to D6 Rook to E5 I don't think
that will appeal to yawn because then
his Rook on H6 will never be able to go
to E6 to trade Rooks he might be forced
to play a move he doesn't like at some
point F6 yep doesn't want to do so he
quickly plays Bishop D7
uh
and I'm sure Magnus has a very specific
idea after Bishop D7
but I don't really see it for the moment
I'm thinking C4 is an idea it's it's of
course not really what you want to do
structurally but maybe
yeah you could go for it but that's
what I was asking you earlier a long
time ago right C4
it's not really risking that much at the
moment but is it worth
make a move like that that causes an
isolated Pawn to try and win yeah I
think again it comes to concrete details
because the point of C4 is if black
ignores it Queen to D6 then white
happily plays C5 both to gain space and
to kick the queen away from a D6 Square
to keep troubling black
and
um maybe black should take on C4 yeah
yeah but after Bishop takes E4 suddenly
there is a threat of Queen to A3 oh yeah
so black has to deal with that probably
with Queen to D6 but now there's no Rook
E6 idea anymore because the bishop on C4
covers that square
on the other hand end games are no
longer very promising for white right so
now we're just white is saying I'm going
to prove my advantage in the middle game
which may prove to be true
I would really hesitate to play C4
though
yeah it does seem like it could cause
white some difficulties even though I
see the point where you're trying to
crash through but one idea that's this
doesn't work because the pawns on H5 and
on H7 is like Bishop F5 would be a
really cool tactic trying to distract
the Bishop from the E8 Square because if
I could Land Queen e that'd be Checkmate
but of course you have the queen I'll
just show it real quick Queen takes F5
Queen E7 check this is why I need the
pawn back on H7 because then I could
back rank Checkmate you yeah but it's
just an idea I know it doesn't work I
led with that but the point is that the
point is that you need to think about
these kind of tactics because if that
Queen were not on F6 then Bishop F5
again it becomes a very useful tactic to
include and I like what you said
probably about the A3 Square
um not something that I initially was
thinking about but if that Bishop could
move with purpose then there could be a
queen A3 check
in timely fashion so I don't think it's
going to happen but I'm just now keeping
that in the back of my mind are we are
we not giving young enough credit here I
mean he obviously seems relaxed he's
suggesting that black should have a way
to coordinate a defense obviously by how
quickly he's playing yeah maybe Rook
texia was not the most accurate is my
feeling now because I don't see why it's
clear follow-through in this position
and we were looking at other moves which
seemed difficult to deal with like C3
right
um
again it's possible black has some
accurate way to to equalize a position
there or even mentioned H4 at some point
yeah
um
here I'm not not quite seeing a direct
fall through of course white will remain
with a slight Edge even if
pieces get traded off even if Rooks get
traded off but I I think that the worst
would be over for black them so how does
white
keep the Rooks on
um Queen to G3 black will meet with
Queen to D6 again
H3 is played
so if Queen to D60 just wants to play
Queen G5 back
that's what he's saying what's the
difference
um between between this and before
you create love for your king that's one
good thing but maybe
so where do you want to put the queen is
white that's the question yeah I don't
know where I want to put the queen I
want to put my Rook on E5
that's that's what I want or or again to
to remind everybody of the great
prophecies that have been laid by Hess
and Fabi if all these pieces come off
the board and the white king does have
quick access to F4 don't mistake that
there are very decent winning chances in
an end game like that uh especially with
with the opportunity to have a good
Bishop versus a not so good bishop and
the idea of things like F3 and G4 with
H4 creating an outside pass Pawn
potentially so
so I guess maybe
yeah Queen D6 maybe he wants to
like I know it's just to illustrate the
point even if it's not the best if
something like this happened and maybe
it is okay this is exactly the type of
end game he might be aiming for because
the Rook is dominant even if you could
trade it which you may not be able to
because of H5 but even if you could
White's winning chances are actually or
at least we'll say this White's ability
to improve the position is very clear
well I think specifically here black can
comfortably play H4
Ah that's huge
um also we're thinking about like let's
say a pure Bishop bending let's say Rook
to E6 here
um because I don't know black well maybe
here white wants to take the pawn
because after rookie won the bishop was
not forced back to F1 but just for
argument's sake let's let's check a pure
uh King H2 probably this is not very
good for black
um but just just to see the position
generally let's assume black why just
takes on E6 and let's see a pure Bishop
ending
because it it could be a possibility at
some point why you should play H4 here
yeah just stop stop page four black
plays F6
and G5
King to F7
yeah here black was in time feels like
feels like a draw
of course white is on the better side of
the draw here but it draws a draw
whether you're more comfortable or not
yeah so Magnus doesn't want to go for
this note the difference if this poem is
on G7 and the white king is on F4 we've
there were there it looks dangerous
because white plays F3 G4 right and then
maybe not even creating a password maybe
G5 because you wanted to like bust open
those dark squares for the king to
invade it's hypothetical but I think
it's instructive because even if we
can't properly calculate the concrete
line that forces such an ending it's
quite possible something like that
occurs and to really visualize what
Magnus is trying to create whether he
can get it or not yeah you can't just
force a win against yonda palmishi he's
putting up stubborn defense he's playing
extremely well in this game but the
point is that in those positions you can
play on more or less forever and black
needs to show tremendous accuracy to
survive and I don't think it's clear
that black can force the Queens off and
there are many possibilities for white
to keep the Queens on the board and as
Bobby keeps trying to make work Rook to
E5 and if you ever capture on E5 then
the new pawn structure is something that
really needs to be evaluated because
assessing it isn't easy for either side
it could be a good transition for white
it could also give black some play to
make his life easier but that's I think
where we're headed I I so I saw magnus's
idea and why young played H4 okay
um if we go back one move before you on
play day four because we were wondering
what happens after Queen D6 threading
rookie six the difference is Queen to G5
here Queen to F6 is back now Queen to G3
Queen to D6 black keeps teasing this
exchange now Rook just pointing out why
you have to go Queen D6 and not H4 yeah
Queens is E6 now if Rook to E5
with the pawn H2 we were mentioning Rook
to E6 and white can't take that pawn
because the Rook comes to E1 forcing the
bishop to F1 where it's very passive but
now Rook E6 Rook takes H5
rookie won King H2 very comfortably
meets rookie one and White's Queen side
cannot be attacked by The Rook The Rook
actually covers all uh like Rook to P1
B3 at some point like first black trades
right and then Rook to be one is met by
B3 so this is his point he created that
lift sort of what it's like gain of
tempo that's uh that's why Beyond played
H4 that's a huge variation there
for those who may be just tuning in we
had this exact type of line before but
with the pawn on H2 that Bishop F1 was
not only not good for white after the
Queen's trade because you really don't
even have an extra Pawn there because
it's doubled but perhaps tactically a
serious problem for white on the first
rank with things like C5 and Bishop B5
coming so that's a that's why we have
Fabiano here sitting here trying to
figure out what was magnus's idea we
solved it the threat of Queen G5 induces
H4 from yawn so that now in those types
of variations the White Queen no longer
has this valuable G3 square but okay
here we go
here we go C4 is on the board
I think C4 makes a lot of sense we've
been highlighting many of the reasons
why it's trying to make the bishop on D3
even better than where it currently sits
and also now the Pawns in H4 yeah many
of these variations the pawn while it's
good in the in some of the end games it
also has gone very far so with the
Queens on the board in particular to
protect it with move G5 could be very
risky but I do like the way Yan is
playing I think he's holding on very
nicely and Magnus is trying everything
he can but there's some problems with
the move C4 as well if you've been stuck
with an isolated Pawn that won't be good
news in some end games
all right well C4 played on the board a
critical moment we expect yon as fast as
he is to at least take
at least take a few seconds to think
about it so on that note we're going to
take a very very quick break promise it
will be short and we will be right back
with chess.com's continued coverage of
the 2021 feet a World Chess Championship
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we are back as predicted Yawn is
thinking I knew he'd pause at least at
least for a few seconds guys on C4 even
for him it's worthy of a thing because
this might be one of the biggest
critical moments left in the game right
how to deal with this with this offer of
an exchange Bobby I think he should
capture because
um if he allows C5
after Queen to D6
then it gets very awkward
to find places for his pieces because
that D6 square is so essential for the
Queen the queen wants to go to D6
without the rook and come to E6 it can't
go to C7 because then you will have
Queen D7 check
and actually this one is a funny
Checkmate to show yeah Robert kind of
alluded to it in a different position
here the bishop covers H7 so this is
this is Checkmate of course
um that would never happen Queen to F6
Heroes it's it's not like this is losing
or anything but now he can't comfortably
play rookie six so I can actually start
playing B4 right and uh
the C5 point is an advantage for what
it's extra space it creates it creates a
possibility of now A4 B5 and and space
gaining um
uh stuff on the queen side so I think he
should take I'm pretty sure he will take
he's just figuring out his next move
after after capturing Bishop C4 because
now Queen to D6 is very natural
um I might be Queen G Queen G5 might be
the Tactical issue with this this is
Queen C5 chat yeah yeah the fifth rank
has
the floodgates have opened I still feel
like it's probably okay because black is
so solid and even like here no not here
no not not here but after Queen's G5 I
still feel like black should be okay
even like Bishop T8 to E8 is super solid
for black but you might not want to get
Bishop E6 actually feels so scary
um
can you play Bishop to E6 if Bishop
takes E6
wait wait actually can we just go back a
half step sorry I know we're jumping
around Bishop takes H3 available now oh
Bishop H3 there we go finally finally
the tactic we've been calling for which
remember consistently did not work
because the bishop was guarding the G6
square is suddenly a possibility
sorry go ahead
um yeah so Queen Z6 wouldn't be good uh
would be fun after Queen G5 but you know
white actually has other ways to attack
black there's Queen to B3 yeah
uh that attacks two Pawns
and B7 maybe even be more important than
F7 because that would let white get
access to Queen to A8 and and Invasion
all the back Rank and if Bishop to E6
white actually still has Queen takes B7
Bishop to E6 here if black were to play
that yeah all the checkmates still Queen
takes B7 is a possibility
uh the bishop on C4 is immune because it
was a back rank checkmate
and white wins upon black can take D4
but you don't want to you don't want to
trade D4 for B7 because now you're left
with the wrecked Pawn structure
everywhere yeah there has to be
I think simply uh well you might
actually just win a problem with Queen
A8 King E7 Queen check yeah so
so this is a disaster
um
so why black has to be careful after DC4
Bishop C4
Queen D6 seems to be a bit dangerous
maybe there's another move I'm just
gonna say maybe there's another move
because you don't actually need to put
your queen on D6 here I mean queen A3
check Queen A3 is the threat but you you
could guard the pawn in another way
A6 makes sense in theory Queen A3 Queen
B3 like we still have that as an option
Queen D6 Queen B3 it's a better version
for black A6 is slightly more defended
but then that doesn't mean that it's
still not a problem for him yeah
difficult to deal with this yeah five
Bishop takes F7 that pawn is also
hanging
the bishop is a bit loose and kind of
weird on F7 but how do you exploit it
the structure is very bad for black here
maybe black has Rook to F6 then Bishop
H5 right Bishop H5 Queen takes D4
oh I don't know about that with your
King on f8 yeah there's counter play on
F2 but the problem is if white simply
plays Bishop to F3 here for example the
long-term structural advantages is in
White's favor because black has this
King on a f8 that's not covered by many
pawns so so scary I mean not only is
Queen A3 maybe an immediate threat but
this is like this is this is where
blunders happen Rook to D1 is also
threat and long-term black isn't in
danger as well so A6 doesn't seem to be
a solution either What's
um
let's go back to Bishop takes C4
I also want to make one very quick
comment after C4 that if white you
mentioned C5 is an idea right after
Queen D6 but there's something else to
look at as well because after Queen D6
C takes D5 I just want to show the
difference in uh structure here C takes
D5 in many of these positions that pawn
being loose on D5 not having a connected
Pawn to it that could leave black in
some big trouble in the event of the
immediate Queen G5 as you just showed
and also even in some end games because
that Pawns in a light Square which means
white can attack it black is stuck
defending it so C takes D5 is not out of
the question right even though fabi's
idea with C5 also looks really strong I
think this is even better because after
Queen G5 you can't play Queen F6 so what
do you do you can't play rookie 6
because H4 is hanging right after Queen
F6 D5 is hanging so you have to make a
move like Bishop E6 Maybe
but then your Rook is is cut out of the
game this was White's goal was to make
sure that black can't trade Rooks and
one can even use that C file as well and
note that Queen d8 is a threat Queen d8
is a media threat that's why black
should move the bishop somewhere to
protect that square either C6 or E6 but
in both cases black can't trade works
next move so he's left with a statically
bad position
I really like your point Robert about C
takes D5 for all the reasons you said
and now if we get those similar types of
Bishop endings with a pawn that's
isolated you have those long-term
chances where a bishop kind of Maneuvers
behind the structure right and suddenly
you have a new way to create threats
that you previously wouldn't have in a
closed position so all kinds of as we
call them magnus-esque weaknesses that
he just he's like a gatherer right just
sees little weaknesses right gathers
them up and you're like this doesn't
matter and all of a sudden he's got like
five of them and you can't solve all
your problems he's also very good at
recognizing when the position needs to
change yeah because if he had not gone
C4 and you've gone C3 we were talking
about many of these variations where
black is able to actually keep
everything together and maybe initiate
some trades so he recognizes if he does
nothing or he makes some as I said
earlier you make a kind of lazy move
right then black just says all right
I'll go make the draw right when you
play C4 now the onus is back on yawn to
find do I take on C4 improve that Bishop
allow Queen to come to A3 with check if
I'm not looking out for it so now we see
yon he's you know he's twirling a pawn
but it's because he really has a lot to
calculate here and Magnus
isn't putting himself at risk by playing
so yes structurally you don't want to
have an isolated Pawn especially if the
Queens come off the board but we're very
far away from the Queens coming off the
board right and black has all of these
pawns to worry about A7 B7 F7 where
sorry the H Pawn still needs to have an
eye kept on it so I like to move C4 a
lot and I'm guessing Jan doesn't really
love that C4 was just played
yeah I was considering
um after DC4 Bishop C4 what black can do
because we already eliminated a number
of moves and let's say we're looking at
this from a point of view of candidate
moves and and from Black's point of view
he looks at Queen E6 first doesn't look
too great he looks at A6 doesn't look
too great uh not left with any many
moves because Queen A3 is a threat so I
thought maybe King to G8 to deal with
green day three wait there's an idea you
thought it was an idea but can I get
away Queen E7 now yeah that's that's the
only question is Queen to E7 a dangerous
move and it's not immediately obvious
because black has Bishop to E6 here
maybe
but after Queen to E8 King to H7 Bishop
takes E6 fp6 I feel like black does have
a position which I I literally thought
you were kidding
no no I I I feel like it's one of
Black's
um Canada moves so one of the moves that
he should be considering wow that he
will be considering it looks funny
or maybe funny is the wrong word it
looks dangerous to allow the queen to E7
a potential Invasion if black were to
take on E7
then we're already talking white wins
right rookie seven Bishop to E6
um
white winds V7 Pawn maybe black still
has Rook D6 here funnily enough actually
maybe this is not so bad it's funny
because if you take with the bishop you
actually lose to King f8
yeah and Rook takes F7
um if Rook D4 there's Rook F4 that wins
the The Rook that's an important
variation we we have D takes C4 on the
board and Bishop takes C4 is an
immediate response by Magnus if we
continue to analyze here but as you can
see the predicted lines are happening
and so the question becomes what does
Jan have planned here in the live
position
um yeah I'm
well we will quickly see his plan
because he's moving rather fast in this
game overall yep you see King G8 one
other idea that white has and we
actually haven't even mentioned this
move as a positive it's D5 that the move
D5 it threatens the A7 Pawn if you ever
take on D5 the bishop on D5 now hits B7
eight A7 of course under attack and now
the queen doesn't have to stay
protecting the D4 pawn it also opens up
the D file so maybe it'll swing your
pieces there and black still has all
these problems to solve and queen E7
remains an option for White Queen A3
Queen B3 like black is really Holding On
by a thread because at any moment you
can drop a pawn and once one Pawn falls
off
you're in big trouble yeah that's an
interesting line maybe we should look at
it a bit further because after King GA
D5 is certainly one of uh White's main
choices maybe cd55 B6 it looks a bit
slow but I just want to make sure I
don't lose uh either of those Queen side
pawns and if Queen D7 now white hap uh
black hapley takes Rook takes and Rook
to D6 right right now the bishop on D5
is attacked if Bishop takes F7 huge
mistake King's f8 wide loses an exchange
with a losing position and if white
Retreats Bishop to B3
Bishop to E6
Bishop takes E6 fp6 I feel like this is
moving towards a draw because Rook A7
black has the intermediate Rook D1 uh
yeah you need a check first
to to lure that King away from defensive
F2 now Rook D2
if white loses the B2 Pawn then we're
already talking about Mass
simplifications maybe white has B3 here
Rook F2 and trying to attack B6 but it
feels very drawish anyway yeah because
white also has to worry about those
Queen side pawns so white may take B6
but lose A2
uh
so this would likely be a drawish
territory
John still hasn't moved yet so normally
when we see him make a move after a
thought he already has his next response
prepared but uh not this time it seems
he's double checking what he wants to do
yeah now I'm so can we actually go back
to that position very quickly so King
James of course is by no means forced
but after King G8 D5 we trade on um D5
B6 so
black defends all the pawns but similar
to five between Bishop F5 earlier when
we're looking some tactical positions
maybe white can sort of improve here and
say that black doesn't have an easy
response so even with like Queen to B3
comes to mind just freezing the queen on
F6 and then Bishop E6 is a pretty ugly
move to play for black maybe it works
out but you're going to make that move
and hope and calculate deeply that it
works out for you because it's not a
movie I don't even want to play it
okay I'm going to argue the point that
black doesn't have other useful moves
here because if black plays Rook to H5
here for example
it looks a bit slow but black is
actually potentially creating counter
play either Rook G5 or Rook F5 also
attacks some of whites
uh stuff maybe Rook G5 with idea of
Bishop H3 at some point or Rook to F5
actually secures F7 and black if given
time we'll play G6 King G7 and really
get that King to a safe spot so I think
white has to be concrete here yeah maybe
there's a play D5 unless you're sure you
have something because it simplifies
things too quickly you know G5 maybe
maybe the right move it's it's certainly
one of the first moves that uh that
magnets would be calculating oh okay
whoa so wait Queen A3
that is that's what they call Active
defense yeah but examples five isn't
Queen A3 check
also Magnus is sort of like playing with
his pen like
like he was writing down to move but
thinking like wait what's going on after
like wait did you really just play B5
that's usually a move in an end game
like this extending your pawns too
aggressively simply creates more targets
long term for your opponent whether
there's something concrete or not I mean
B5 is a very committal decision Queen I
don't get a queen to A3 checkmate
we mentioned this back rank uh tactic
before here why wins upon it's not as
important upon as the B7 Pawn but still
a pawn C4 is
um invulnerable for the moment cannot be
captured because of Queen to A8 with
checkmate
uh is there something like
I mean I have no idea it tries to free
this side of the board so that he can
coordinate quickly like yeah you can do
that but it's still a pawn like yeah I
don't know you can play G5 if you want
Bishop to B3
um well I can trade yeah Rook yeah if
you want to Rook F6 I guess Rook to E5
or something
uh Queen C5 coming I mean trade of
Queens this is a healthy Pawn
uh don't look at me like that it's not
my fault that he I'm just trying to
figure out what he's seeing here because
Queen A3 check is the move that we're
gonna have our laser focus on because
he's checking and wins the pawn so Queen
A3
King if you go King G8
you still just take on A7 right because
after Queen A7
if they're if you could make bishop
takes H3 and white had to take back on
H3 then that could be something right
because if you take on H3 then you get
the bishop back on Z4 White's King is in
some danger but you don't have to take
on H3 there in fact you could think
about the move you know rookie eight
check and take on F7 you could take on
F7 right away and enter a rook end game
up a pawn or or queen takes F7 is even
I'll clean up yeah Queen F7 is one and
rookie a check after that is yeah King
H7 Bishop F7 that's funny it's still up
a pawn
um I mean we can discuss if this is
winning or not but uh but why would
black enter this whether or not it's
winning Even If you defend it somehow I
don't understand how you enter this
willingly and in fact I don't think
white wants to trade Queens because if
we go back just two moves Rook to E8
King H7 Bishop takes F7
um I'm interested in a mating attack as
well I was looking at Queen G5 Bishop G8
and if King G6 is Queen F7 mate but
Queens G5 is of course not forced maybe
black has something
better there I actually see now the move
Rook to G6 yeah yeah Rook G6 oh wow what
a move yeah and if Bishop G6 Queen G6
we're looking at a double attack maybe
The Rook isn't even important because
it's more that G2 is indefensible
um so okay we're getting a little we're
getting a little wild here but back to
the moment let's feel the drama yawned
upon as she just played B5 and again
he has a lot of time on the clock more
time than his opponent
he must sense that the position has
danger because magnus's Magnus is
playing it and you and we know what he's
capable of in these small Advantage
positions so it makes me say that he
must have calculated something concrete
on B5 but the eval bar don't lie they
say ball Don't Lie the eval bar don't
lie and when you've got
a king
in a position like this with diagonals
and files open on all sides of the board
that's that's how blunders are made they
want to know how babies are made this is
how blenders are made Robert
now you know how both now you know how
both are made I wish you didn't throw
over to me after saying that
here we are I've been putting up with
you for years but
oh no the kids are wondering and now
they know this is how blunders are made
the birds and the bees okay where's the
stork anyway queen queen A3 check seems
uh just obvious and
I'm trying to figure this out because if
there's some end game so this is the
thing that high level players do is even
if it costs them a pawn if they see a
rook end game let's say we trade the
queens and white is up a pawn but you
know theoretically that position is a
draw then that's a good reason to answer
this because you make sure that you
won't blunder given the pressure of the
position
but you know that at the end of the day
you have a rook in three versus rook and
two of these kind of theoretically drawn
end games but I don't see a path towards
that and that just makes this even
riskier than you can imagine and as
we're looking at these positions maybe
there's some kind of Bishop takes H3
tactic we were just looking at that
position but yeah we were we were
discussing it but those are not simple
end games no no like like let's this is
the only idea I see for black is Bishop
takes H3 here and and you try to trade
off a few pieces you weaken white king
side let's assume there's nothing
immediately decisive for white involving
an attack that might be a big assumption
but well I also like going to Rook
ending just Queen F7 Queen F7 Bishop F7
King F7 GH3 now uh even before rookie
just just take on F7 first because I'd
rather
just take off seven no no queen of seven
Bishop takes F7 check Queen takes oh
you're just going yeah go for The Rook
end game
uh because
yeah maybe it's dry I don't know but uh
black also has weaknesses H4 is weak of
course white has a lot of weak pawns and
they do say all working games are drawn
um I didn't say that first I
yeah yeah I have said it but
um
but not not all of them are really
strong well of course and Magnus by the
way has played Queen A3 check but I
think you're on the right track anyway
because there must be something like
that that y'all was trying to go for
because Robert made a good point that a
resourceful Defender will be willing to
sacrifice material to go to an egg and
they know as a theoretical draw right
and they don't care about the eval bar
if they know hey that's a drawn Rook
ending I don't care that I'm down upon
but there's no clear path here right it
looks like it's just a pawn and all the
compensation remains as our buddy yes or
ceremon would say white has the pawn and
the attack
yes and there maybe we aren't diving as
deeply as young did he was spending you
know time even whether he's sitting at
the board or calculating while he's
walking around but this doesn't look
good this is a situation where he
decided to lash out rather than sit
passively and that makes perfect sense
in fact that's often our instincts as
chess players we don't want to sit and
defend for hours and hours the last time
that happened maggots ended up winning
in the eighth hour and so Jan says let
me try to solve my problems very
concretely
but it's not concrete it I mean we're
gonna have to keep diving into these
positions with King G8 and queen takes
A7 but I I would be really worried and
it's not like Queen 687 is force by the
way after King G8 Rook E7 is another
possibility so if we just play that line
right here just to show that after
uh King G8
Rook E7 I'm giving up my Bishop on C4 to
get your Bishop on D7 and then you have
this A7 Pawn I am sort of leaving my
king on a G1 so that could be quite
risky but the pawn structure is worse
for black white is very active so unless
black sees a way for it here then that
also is something that you have to
consider Robert so I I like your idea of
not taking E7 so I was looking at rookie
seven but then after bc4 work t7 Queen
F4 I feel like this idea of Queen C1 H
F4 with the Perpetual will probably lead
to to a draw but actually I noticed a
move which is a very unusual one after
King G8 Queen de7 ah I want the same
thing if bc4 Queen D7 I I'm attacking a
lot of your Pawns
but uh but a lot of them are weak ah but
black can simply take on on and Rook D6
right okay yeah that's
that's leading to which line here
instead of a b takes C4 just Queen takes
E7 and Rook D6 the lines we've been yeah
we looked at that line yeah Rook D6 now
this is this doesn't work out for white
um so forget Queen E7 probably Queen
takes A7 is the right move right
but the thing is right
freeze at this point here there's so
many different options Queen A7 we've
been looking at Rook E7 Queen E7 and a
question that sort of I'm wondering like
if you put Bishop B3 which is kind of
risky because you're losing sight of the
third Rank and Bishop takes H3 might
already be a problem but sometimes you
can play a calm move like this and say
you've helped me out because you're A7
Pawn can't be defended except by Queen
6d4 but then Rook D1 happens and now
you're Bishop on D7 is loose or my queen
or Rook comes in E7 anyway so you can't
just get greedy as black because your
king is the one in danger so Bishop B3
is a reasonable idea probably not the
most precise choice at the moment but
white has a number of options here and
all of them leave black with some
difficult choices well it continues to
prove that it's as we said it's a
blunderable position right these
positions are just
full of opportunities to go wrong land
mines
uh real quick results of today's votes
again for all those of you playing along
with us thanks for doing so the chat
boats had 47 for Magnus to win 16 were a
draw votes at chess.com events Magnus
had 35 percent victories 54 of you voted
for a draw
um after the next rest day on Tuesday
we're getting down to it of course we'll
have a rest day on on Monday uh that is
tomorrow we'll really start keeping you
updated in regards to who is in the
running to win the cash prize because
it's a lot of cash up for grabs so uh
continue to play along with us to win
Diamond memberships and there's the
schedule before you twitch chat doesn't
like draws they don't like every time we
show the percentages it's the chess.com
events has a higher percentage of
drawing and then to which I just they're
picking their favorite emote yeah yeah
because a draw and yeah whatever the
most not as good but if you're playing
for cash at just.com they tend to be a
little more cautious uh with their with
their votes here Magnus being cautious
and just look at how hard he's working
it's for the record
it's not his move yet he's at the board
and sometimes when people see that as a
from a body language perspective you
assume that he must have problems to
solve no this is Magnus as I've said
before when he's ready to pounce I've
seen I've seen this uh this Rodeo before
for the last decade plus watching Magnus
Carlson dominate The Chess World and
that is a focused Magnus Carlson who
understands that this might be an
opportunity to put away the entire world
championship and do a rare thing which
is prove Danny Wright who called a
Magnus Victory today yeah his focus is
um is perfectly timed uh the main thing
is that this is calculatable territory
we're already in very concrete
variations where black has limited
options here black has only two moves
which don't lose on the spot Queen D6
King G8 white has an obvious response to
both of them Queen takes A7 and then
black has very limited options there yep
so we get already narrow blacks options
down which means that he is calculating
his possibilities in for example King G8
Queen A7 Bishop H3 or queen D6 Queen A7
G5 one of some of those possibilities
that we were looking at and he also
knows that
you know he has time he has plenty of
time for now but time easily goes down
and it's still 18 moves for him until he
reaches a Time control so he has to be
extremely
um
he has to be extremely accurate with his
uh with his time usage and it makes you
wonder I mean
where where is John I mean as he might
be he might be throwing water on his
face right now and regretting B5 at this
point
well I think he had a plan and probably
it's King G8 Queen A7 Bishop H3 I don't
see
another way I think it's kind of bizarre
to go for the some of the end games that
we were considering
but maybe it's not so bad
um like to me the most promising ending
we looked at was Queen takes F7 here
Queen takes F7 rookie eight King H7
Bishop takes F7 Bishop to F5 most likely
and white has a variety of choices you
can even maybe play Bishop to G8 check
because I want that King to G6 to kind
of get in the way of The Rook right yeah
if I get Rook D6 just for the record
this is this is probably much much more
holdable if that Brooks on D6 different
game yeah if if it were black smooth
Rook D6 I don't think black is any worse
yeah the good thing for black is that H4
Pawn is a tremendously good Pawn Yeah we
were talking about the weakness of the
potential H5 Pawn before yeah but now
that White's H3 Pawn is gone and that
black pawn is advanced IT exerts a
cramping influence on White's King
kingside and that King on G1 is actually
a little bit weak
it doesn't look weak it's not coming
under attack but it doesn't really have
much freedom to maneuver like H2 G3 it
can go to G3 so it's a bit restricted in
this movement maybe that's the basis for
black having
decent drawing chances here I still feel
like it's a pawn so white also has
decent winning chances but it might not
objectively be a winning position
Robert Hugo we were both about to speak
but you're the Grand Master I defer no I
was I think we were also very surprised
by B5 because Queen A3 check was
telegraph but it's kind of what I was
highlighting before the if Yan has
really dug deep and he sees this
position and says I am going to make a
draw in this position then he might
prove himself just to be brilliant
because otherwise he's suffering from
many moves and if he thinks or another
things but he knows that he can hold
this but as Fabiano was saying earlier
and I completely agree with there's no
clear path to a draw because white can
play this on in many different ways so
it's not like you can know with any
degree of certainty that the game should
conclude with the point being split and
look at the pawn structure here white
has an A and B Pawn black is a B Pawn so
there's so many positions where even if
it costs you a pawn you give up your
extra Pawn is white and you push an
outside pass Pawn that can be very
dangerous for black to deal with
yeah on that note I was gonna
add maybe a concrete line to what all
the things probably said about the
advantages for black here of course the
Palm being on H4 the bishop working
together to keep the king entry but if
you throw in that check and the King
awkwardly Cuts The Rook off and what if
what if I quickly just try to create an
outside passed apod if you played B4 now
Rook B8 is a problem where I could
capture it and defend D4 and if I just
go all in on the idea of using an extra
Pawn
yeah that's a good question I think we
would get into very uh concrete lines
now because black would play King to G5
possibly and after A4 take take Rook to
D6 the question is is your a pawn fast
enough uh it's not clear to me that it
is because after A5 Rook D4 A6 like it's
just in time A7 would win but Rook to A4
whites uh y would be tied down to the
defense of his pawn and even though the
pawn looks super dangerous and white has
ideas like Bishop C4 here maybe because
that Bishop is immune
um it's still tough to push that pawn
farther so so we might be in very
drawish territory in this case
but team G8 has been played by the way
yeah he was obviously going for this and
I mean I understand he probably thinks
there's good drawing chances here but
like how how do you go for this anyway
it's it's nuts as the Ebel bar going
crazy or is there something more
concrete than the lines we've been
looking at
I think I think
the email bar is struggling a little bit
with the long-term chances but it
certainly seems to love white here I
wonder if Magnus is about to reveal
well the
I mean we were talking about taking on
A7 versus you know not doing so
there it just takes a nice he does it he
takes I mean yeah we didn't see a more
logical move maybe after Bishop H3
there's something
better than going for an end game yeah
maybe that's the move the computer was
struggling to consider but once played
it sees the black strong chances are
slightly improved yeah I didn't see
anything because the problem for white
is that if white at any point plays
Bishop D3 for example Queen ba King H7
Bishop D3 the bishop comfortably drops
back to F5
right so Queen ba checked is in the king
escapes and you block the check on D3
and well then the H4 Pawn is great yeah
then we're already black is already
fully equal not worse than the slightest
maybe even
well okay black can never be better but
certainly not not any worse
so so that's the reason why this is
tactically possible why why can never
play Bishop D3
um including in the current position
Bishop D3 Bishops F5
a is a similar story
we see Magnus standing at the board
Yon
still still not back
and uh kind of an ominous sort of take
Magnus alone in the glass room
lost at his thoughts about to write that
hit song shut up Dan I'm walking away
there's some positions actually I've
been trying to calculate Bishop takes H3
like I almost want to make rookie three
work at some point but I don't think I
can get like Rook E8 check
King H7 and I was like wondering can I
get away with like a rookie three move
but I'm not sure uh it
suffices for a huge advantage and I know
that my king on G1 is a bit risky and if
you take on C4 then I go Rook takes H3
and I'm trying to get my outside pass
Pawn so I'm just trying to shake up the
game a little bit and clarify some of
White's edges we should remind everybody
why Bishop takes F7 doesn't work because
if you've just tuned in it would it's a
shocking response with this crazy Rook
G6 move and suddenly the script is
flipped Black's attack is real and if
you take it you might actually even lose
because of the double attack actually
can we continue the line a bit afterward
G6 I want to try and move okay I don't
think it works but let's give it a shot
Queen to B8
and I think very importantly Rook to G1
uh and then Queen G5 and queen G5 and G2
okay and I think that's otherwise I
think white wins yeah so I thought about
that before which is why I have or no
there's also Queen takes F7 which is
kind of disappointing oh but yeah
you're getting fancy
okay so anyway we're reminding everybody
that's why Bishop takes F7 is not on the
agenda we already established that
Bishop D3 allows Bishop F5 and probably
black isn't losing so Jan's
really sort of shocking and forceful
approach to try to defend this position
let's go to Robert's rookie three give
it a try
ah
you didn't like it I I didn't like it I
still I don't like it for many reasons
yeah I guess white Black's not down
material so even like
even bc4 work H3 doesn't feel like
anything to me
um but black might have something even
even better than that like Bishop takes
G2 and if Bishop D3 works at G6
and and Black's attack is super super
strong I couldn't even hold back but
yeah that's an awesome life this is one
of these moments where having the
evaluation are so distracting because 53
is not a move that I would have
suggested if not for trying to find the
best move as I see the yeah exact bar go
crazy
yeah so so wait after Bishop takes H3
I had a
a line which is certainly incorrect but
anyway it's kind of fun Rook to E8 King
to H7 Bishop takes F7 Rook to G6
Bishop G8 King to H6 and Bishop to D5
oh C takes D5 Rook to h8 King G5 and I
was wondering about this because okay if
G takes H3 maybe black starts his attack
with some king move and maybe Queen F3
first and then King King to F4 and check
that okay yeah this is um so much fun
but white doesn't have to take on H3 for
the moment black king in a rook position
is kind of funny
um I don't know which movie White makes
but
um but maybe there's something if the
queen could come back I'm thinking like
some wild re-maneuvering of the queen
here
yeah
it doesn't I mean white would never go
for this because you're opening up the
possibility how do you lose yeah which
you don't want to you have safe and good
alternatives
um but it is funny to look at
well again we uh we have a Magnus
Carlson sighting at the board and yet no
yonda Palm Nashi
um
yeah it's it's a bit funny Jan is
playing extremely
committal chess sacrificing material and
and then he leaves the board
and he's he's obviously thinking about
the position
away from the board but but it's kind of
funny because he just blitzes out his
move
um and he's he's playing so quickly
overall yep like when he's actually at
the board he moves pretty much instantly
and then he goes away
just trying to figure out this position
here because there's so many tactics
right with the F7 square and Bishop
takes H3 I think we're all in agreement
that's yeah it's only move it's only
move
um like if black plays Queen to D6
well what is at least a clear pun up and
probably just Queen to A8 right might
even pick up more material it's going to
be fun when Bishop takes h3s on the
board because at least those tuning in
will be like wow fireworks
a couple of Bishops hanging
a couple of Kings Under Fire
there's a couple of guys in Dubai
playing some chess
that is true
[Laughter]
um
so where is The Knockout that's that's
the question Magnus is really
calculating because the reason we think
there's a knockout is because we see an
evolve bar which is almost almost to the
top yeah but uh
but it's difficult to see what White's
response is to eight Bishop takes H3
besides the lines we looked at where
white has some Advantage but not one
which is completely winning
um
and it could also be
an eval bar uh Gone Wild
[Laughter]
Edition you know honestly the first the
instincts we had with Queen takes F7
checked it could be a depth thing like
yep maybe initially it says one thing
and it goes up but this is live with
Queen F7 I I want to get back to that
because we didn't find a clear path to
equalize for black and if the rookie a
check King H7 Bishop takes
I'm seven here I mean this seems like
serious chances for one yeah and we were
talking about the outside pass Pawn we
rushed the decision with b3a4 which you
can hold off on for the time being but
this position does look amazing for
white yes black is one move away from
playing Rook to D6 but
they're often a rookie five can be
played yeah that was the main move I was
considering here because after Rook to
E5
black probably wants to play Rooks F6
because if you move that Bishop it's
going to get kicked around more and more
and you don't want that and after Rooks
have six black plays Bishop sorry white
plays Bishops B3 oh I love it I thought
maybe bishop da is is also good but
after Bishop B3 the treasure takes F5 so
that's why this looks sort of attractive
to me but maybe you remove Bishop to E8
which threatens Bishop takes C6 is an
even better one
um the advantage to that is also
if C6 over Falls then the bishop will be
I in B5 plus I kept thinking about it in
my mind would in order to to improve my
winning chances and solve the one issue
I have I want to make D5 work if I can
in a lot of positions right that was my
plan is to trade drastically improves
White's winning chances in theory and
it's a two on one the outside it's not
going anywhere and if we can remove C6
then B5 is in trouble so that's the type
of position that I'm looking for and I
think that instead of all these tactics
where I've gone wrong enough times to
say let me just get here because now I
know I can play for a win without any
risk and I actually think that it's much
more likely that white wins a position
like this than black ever holds even no
matter what the evaluation Bar says we
have a Yellen apologies citing returns
from the wild
sits at the board
and plays Bishop takes H3 quickly I
assume
um because this must have been seen in
advance by him he like Queen I3 Queen's
xa7 is yeah literally the first thing
that you look at we're gonna we're gonna
have to see Bishop takes H3
here in just a moment wait what what
wait wait what I literally thought it
was a dg2 I was refreshing the board
Queen to D A to D and he leaves again
he's doing down a pawn
okay this this is just tilt
um because black plays Bishop B3 it's
one of those where I mean you just
it's impossible not to talk about I'm
sorry but I mean you just this is this
is reckless and especially given you
know the demeanor you saw from yonda
Palm Nashi after his chances with white
almost and we we all said it it felt
almost like he was convincing himself
that everything was fine in the post
game conference yesterday because now
we're in a situation where
he's this this game is falling apart by
his own doing and in a fashion that
unfortunately like it or not has to has
to call for public criticism just
watching what's he's never at the board
he's playing quickly and what's
Happening Here is world championship
chances are are falling by the wayside
yeah I mean I don't this is a bit
disappointing to see because
um
it seems like he thinks that he can just
Blitz Magnus and uh and it works out but
uh the clock really doesn't matter here
his position is losing after Bishop to
B3 there's nothing to calculate you you
just move your Bishop Black's only
source of counter plays maybe Rook G6
um but that doesn't even threaten Bishop
takes H3 so I can simply play like
rookie five to stop Queen G5 yeah and
then any move here and there's okay
maybe not but
I guess I don't think you can move the
bishop because F7 is hanging so I think
that was just an email bar being a
little nutty I think Bishop B3 is
totally fine I mean it to me it looks
winning after Bishop to B3 maybe there's
something better
um
I mean because it might just be
tactically winning in some some way but
uh
maybe you mean something even better
than Bishop B3 here well I was wondering
if Bishop to D no Bishop D3 doesn't look
right because I need allow Bishop to E6
but we see Magnus here with us in the
studio about to move
um Bishop to B3 feels like
like a good move yeah let's let's go
back to full Magnus and uh let him let
him take us take us into his into his
world and Robert I feel you over there I
feel you over there you stay tight I'll
give you a chance here hold on Buddy
uh I don't know if Bishop D3 is is worth
trying because Bishop D3 Bishop E6 why I
can play Bishop to E4
and attack that C6 Pawn
um
and the advantage of Bishop D3 is that
the king can't escape by uh H7 so if
let's say queen to D6 there's background
problems
okay but
you want Bishop B3 yep yeah that that
feels like the right move seems like the
most concrete
thing to go for yeah I'm just gonna
ignore the evaluation bar because it's
clearly a great position for white it
goes back up every time so I yeah
there's something about and I just want
to elaborate because again more
important things to discuss but I do
believe it's a depth issue what you said
Robert because there are certain things
we see rare Horizon effects on occasions
still I think there's just certain
things about the position the computer
is like consistently going down the same
line and missing something but white is
clearly winning here don't let it pull
you go ahead Robert I mean it's just
completely surprising because yeah Jan
was playing well to actually hold the
position for a while yep and then he
plays B5 and I was the most critical
yesterday and actually as we were
discussing afterwards I almost felt a
little bad because I was I'm not gonna
retract my sentiment but maybe some of
the decisions weren't that bad when you
look them individually but the way he
was playing it didn't feel like he was
competing to win that game and I think
that was such an important moment and we
had Lavon on afterwards and he was
talking with Fabiano about he said I
would have tried to strike immediately I
wouldn't just sit in the hope that I can
maintain the one point deficit until I
have a chance you need to create your
own chances at some point and Magnus is
great at doing that he's a maestro but
this game he didn't have to create he
was playing well he was causing some
concern for Jan and then B5 happens and
the game kind of falls apart from here
and maybe Jan will miraculously hold but
now he doesn't have that much more time
than Magnus does he's down upon his
King's the one under pressure there's
still going to be an outside pass Pawn
on the a file the queen on A7 is very
active the queen on d8 is defensive
everything you could ask for and more is
what Magnus was just handed it's not
just B5 like okay B5 was
was a bizarre move but bizarre's
decision but if it's in conjunction
Bishop takes H3 and there's some
calculation behind it yeah uh and he's
evaluated some end games I would still
say it's a bad decision
but at least you can understand people
understand why he did it yeah you're
about to say but Queen d8 there's no
there's nothing here like first of all
it doesn't even challenge magnets
because Magnus just plays Bishop B3
instantly it was the first move that all
of us thought you just well The Bishop's
attacked you move it back and uh Black's
Bishop can't move whites up a pawn
yeah
I mean now
like I I think any move
um Rook to E4 for example comes to mind
you defend D4 and attack H4
um enter and Rook F4
you even directly thread Rook takes H4
yeah yeah uh because there's Queen takes
H4 Queen to B8
um yeah Rook to E4 comes to mind as as
winning move uh
and any move Queen to C5 I feel like
what is is there something even more
concrete okay white is objectively up a
pawn but a single Pawn is not worth plus
5.6
well it's not just the pawn it's also
let's say Rook to E4 and black plays
Bishop to E6 yeah and white plays Bishop
takes E6 yeah Rook takes E6 Rook takes
E6 F takes E6 this is not just a pawn
this is also the the weakened structure
means that white has a winning Queen end
game right after let's say queen to C5
um
yeah
it's funny because if this when you're
when you're up this much the evaluation
is swinging from five to even three or
two may not even matter as long as the
position continues to get easier to win
right it simplifies as as you would say
it's the opposite of what I was saying
earlier that if yawn maybe the advantage
for Magnus was growing but he felt that
he'd get to a theoretical draw right
same thing when you're winning as long
as you win the game you're happy and if
it goes from plus six immediately but
with some complicated moves defined
versus plus three where all you have to
do is push your pawns forward and you
know eventually you'll win then that
makes sense to go for uh right now if
Magnus can find a game-ending idea of
course I'll go for that and queen C5
also comes to mind here rookie four as
we've been talking about many options
here for white all of which look good
but I think mags is smart to spend a
little bit of time here so he can put
the game away now versus having to win
it a second time if that's what it comes
down to yeah Magnus is taking it I
actually like Queens of C5 yeah of
course the more we looked at I was going
to suggest Queen C5 it just seems like
the Queen's centralized it looks and now
after let's say Bishop T
it doesn't matter Bishop to E6 forget
what it says Bishop takes E6 Rook takes
E6 is no longer a move because C6 Falls
as well so black has to play fe6
uh and then Rook to E4 and the position
is just Frozen and you you can't play
Rook D5 because Queen C6 so you're down
a pawn with it's not yeah it's not just
the pawn also H4 is weak E6 is weak G7
is weak uh this is this is game over and
I mean like especially in magnus's hands
he
of course he's he's good at
many and most things but in the
technical phase and accuracy in in
technique is uh definitely one of his
strongest points
wow wow wow wow okay well
um
the
the critical moment in this 2021 theater
World Chess Championship Match might be
happening before your very eyes so we're
going to take a super short break but
when we come back
hopefully this game is still going I
think it will be but uh if it is won by
the world champion uh it may be the game
that ultimately proves to be the nail in
the coffin will Yonder Palm Nashi the
Challenger hold me miraculously I can't
even say the word because it's probably
uh not gonna happen uh but uh don't go
anywhere just.com's coverage brought to
you by coinbase will return in a few
in addition to the chess let's compare
something else that matters at Expo 2020
the battle of the country Pavilions
foreign
and now it's time to tally the scores
when it comes to outside architecture we
have to go with the Norway Pavilion and
the Viking ship what about the inside
the light show of Russia wins that
category and food well the Norwegian
waffle was mighty tasty but technically
the kiosk was outside the Pavilion
Russia didn't have any food either
that's its eye uh-oh it appears it's one
and a half to one and a half
foreign
well there you have it it seems to be a
tie but just like in the world
championship we need a tiebreaker and I
think that adorable kids playing chess
means that Russia wins
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
and uh
the whole world is wondering
what's going on Jan we were correct I
mean he went B5 and they followed Queen
d8 he's not even posing a challenge to
Magnus Carlson and as we look at the
position he knows he's lost yeah he
dropped a pawn and it's not just the
First Pawn H4 is hanging F7 is under
attack thanks to the bishop on B3 so
yeah B5 uh it already was a questionable
decision as he was lashing out but then
after that to not play
King and Bishop takes H3 here just to
complicate the position and make Magnus
work for the win I mean that's at this
world champion level you can't do that
and and queen D.A was played in a minute
maybe or a minute of actual thinking at
the board right consistently giving
y'all the benefit of the doubt as a guy
who we know walks around a lot a lot of
players have different styles in terms
of what makes them confident but it
doesn't matter I mean Fabiano's here and
as a guy who's played it literally for
the highest title in the game
you can't replicate hard work hands on
head pushing yourself at the board no
matter where you're looking at a chess
position on a monitor in the restroom we
see Magnus with just a completely
different approach right now he's poised
he wants to put this match away and if
he takes a two-game lead head into the
next rest day
uh for La for lack of you know it's my
job to uh believe in dramatic storylines
and and uh as they say content is King
Magnus will not be throwing for content
if he takes a two-game lead I'll say
that no and I do think that John has
some chances as a chess player he had a
winning record against maggots heading
into this match many of those games are
from years ago it's a whole lifetime ago
in in chess speak but if he plays
aggressively at certain point you just
have to win games you're running out of
draws so this game is not going his way
but in the future if he plays some sort
of sharper variation and we talked about
this position where you can just take on
E6 white is up one Pawn to begin with
but the rest of Black's pawns are in
terrible shape and it looks like Magnus
I mean he knows Jan also knows look at
the him holding his it's funny how all
of us notice the things about the pen
and the body language because we've all
played over the board there's something
about a player in the way they carry
themselves there's there's body language
you just you can't hide and
any chess player knows how someone
really feels when they're
because how can we really talk about a
comeback in the match before Eon
stabilizes right I think that's the
first thing we have to do and we
suspected that was what he was trying to
do in the previous game
but this game shows that he hadn't
stabilized mentally because his mistakes
are
not ones that a player of his level
makes he's capable of playing at the
exact same level of Magnus yep at his
best
he is capable of that and we saw that at
the start they were playing on more or
less equal terms and even in that game
he lost
for most of it we can say that they were
playing on more or less equal terms most
of it you could say he was the one
pushing I mean as black we were
applauding everything about that game
from G takes F6
you know to the way he was transitioning
in the queen versus two Rooks until
until you know maybe the moves Queen D5
missing Bishop takes B4 but yeah it was
a game which was a bit back and forth
but we can't uh we can't say it was you
know I I really uh single on one one
terrible decision that game which was to
play Queen E4 to allow takes A3 even
though it wasn't the move which
objectively is the worst in that game
from either player right they both made
mistakes with bigger evaluation swings
that's still the move which I single out
as a strange decision
but we could still find we can still say
that was a high level game overall right
this is this is not this is a game
between Magnus and
it could be between you know a 2300 I
know that sounds super harsh
um but not a player who's 2800 like
you're about to look at me
I can't remember but the way you looked
at me but thank you for saying 2300
because that means I would have played
better than this well the thing about it
is we're harsh because we know what Jan
is capable of you just said so that at
John's best he can fight Toe to Toe on
even terms with Magnus Carlson and
yesterday I predicted yawn apology to
bounce back and win and yet I was the
one who was being really hard on him and
it's not because you know he's a bad of
course he is playing the highest stage
of Chess there's so much pressure on him
and we have to contextualize that that
said Lavon jumped on the preparation
what is this you didn't even try to win
with the white pieces it seemed like
we're looking at some of his decision
making he's sloppy at moments where you
cannot afford it and you really can't
afford it any moment when you face
Magnus Carlson no matter the event but
the magnitude that he is having his one
shot of the world champion title he may
never get that opportunity again just
because there's so many great players
Fabiano included it's unlikely that
anyone necessarily gets that shot
because you're competing with seven
other players in the Kansas tournament
who all have the same same chance that
you do so when it's your moment and
you're down a point you need to go for
it now he's down to point about to be
down two because of just a decision that
B5 goes away from the board comes back
because Queen d8 I wonder if we
calculated how much time he spent away
from the board and we tried to look at
that does does that impact players and
some players are always away from the
board they still play the best chess
that they're capable of but it just
seems like he's not present in the
moment and it's gonna cost him cool
I'm sure if we did the math I'm sure he
spent more time away from the board than
at the board this game regardless of you
know whether that's a rightful criticism
or storyline for us to make or not it's
it's one that we see before our very
eyes and really hard not to draw
attention to when when what's actually
happening on the board is happening
normally if I feel like a storyline or
narrative is BS I would call it out I I
think kind of like the uh
the Hess merch
yeah let's let's not talk about the head
Sports anymore
but in this case I think it is actually
a bad sign when you're playing a world
championship match yeah and you are
barely seen at the chessboard
um yeah I think the main thing I I said
this before the match uh when you when
you asked me about this
uh I I said that
the main thing in this match is that you
have to be able to stand the tension
and the difficulty of it and if you're
never at the board it feels like you
don't want to be there that's that's my
general feeling uh I understand in this
position you really don't want to to be
looking at it especially against Magnus
um I think this game at least is a
foregone conclusion
um
any any Grand Master would be expected
to convert this with ease
but yeah like he had plenty of time and
I I don't know what he's going to what
he's doing with that extra time I mean
you can't take it into the next game
so when you rush with B5 and with queen
d8 and I think we see that both of those
moves were played relatively quickly
right compared to like I can show the
timeline of them
B5 was played
after four and a half minutes of thought
but also how long was he at the board
for
and then Queen to d8 was played
after nine minutes of thought but also
how long was he at the point yeah he was
not on the board for most of that and I
also feel like if we're going to single
out okay those are the moves you single
out as the ones which lost in the game
and
but also King to f8 fell weird to me
early on we were thinking about Queen E7
and we didn't even consider King f8
because it really runs into magnus's
playing a bishop B4 why are you giving
your opponent what he wants queen to E7
just felt like a more principled move
because you don't want to trade Bishops
your Bishop on D6 is better than the
bishop on D2 I know that
in hindsight this seems like a minor
detail to focus on but still strange
decisions
um should be singled out
and okay now Magnus has won another Pawn
after Queen takes F2 Queen takes E6 he
puts the queen on E5 he can he can even
probably actually he doesn't even need
to do that what he can do is after let's
say King to H7
Queen to E4 King goes um back somewhere
he can just play D5 because Queen to G3
King to H1 the king hides itself
perfectly that deepaw is running out of
Queen B2 Queen takes H4 wins yeah I was
gonna say the queen he's another Pawn H4
makes it impossible for this queen here
two pawns up this this is a
dead lost position they're blitzing up
moves so that yon yon is blitzing out
moves now so that he can get
get to a position that is reasonable to
resign obviously we know he's you know
regardless of all the things we say no
one is going to be feeling worse about
the situation than Jan himself and I'm
sure he doesn't want to be at the board
any more than any of us want to see this
world championship match get away from
him just because we uh
you know we admire both these guys for
the Chester cable of and everyone wants
a close match but the reality is
unfortunately
for uh for those who were looking for
those storylines what would Yan do when
things started to not go his way Magnus
Carlson himself said on a podcast before
the world championship match
that John has been known to tilt and
that he anticipated that if he could put
yon in a tough spot that he might just
do that and
you know it's it's not something you
wanted to draw attention to but at this
point we don't have a choice yeah and
you feel for you on the palmistry yeah I
know some of the criticism may seem
sharp it may seem like he's not getting
the respect that he definitely deserves
because he is a phenomenal chess player
he's nearly 2 800. he won a candidates
tournament that was really challenging
with all other super Grand Masters
high-level players but now we have to
talk about the moment the stage he's on
and the way he played today that's just
frankly not World Championship caliber
game because he handed it to magazine we
also have to give the proper credit to
Magnus he put the pressure on now it's
easy but he was making Jan's life
difficult he played C4 and all of a
sudden that's when Jan collapsed so
credit to Magnus Carlson for being
ceaseless in his path to Victory and
just trying to make his opponent's life
difficult but yonda palmchi he gave a
helping hand
Relentless would be another another word
and uh
after after Queenie for check and and
King I like the move B4 the most
because after B4 Queen G3 doesn't lead
anywhere and if Queen takes A2 Queen
takes H4 white keeps the two Pawn
advantage and then can secure the Pawns
with uh let's say queen to D6 that
covers the diagonal but White's king is
not in danger of getting into a
Perpetual check at any moment the queen
only four stops that possibility
completely
so
so black doesn't really have any sort of
compensation any drawing chances for
this two-pawn deficit uh
I mean the only question is
is
the queen 94 is so well yeah after Queen
E4 King G8 24 is actually on the board
unfortunately unable to get it on the
board
uh yeah he played Queen to E4 King G8
was played and the only question to me
is B4 or D5 both of those moves look
really good
um
I'm sure there's also I mean of course
all moves are winning even Queen to D3 I
just real but yeah Queen to D3 is a bit
strange no I think B4 is a very good way
of doing it
uh so you're saying that just putting
the queen behind the past pawn and just
trying to push the pawn up the board but
that could give black some checks right
and I think that's what you're trying to
do is limit yeah any risk that black
suddenly gets a bunch of checks and uh
can get behind your pawns yeah I I'd
look for the most clinical way to do
this and V4 seems to fit the bill uh in
my mind because Queen's G3 is simply met
by either King's H1 or G1 maybe King H1
is the the safest
and black has no real way of attacking
the pawns without also losing H4 and
white simply plays D5 and pushes that
pawn off the board if given time and if
Queen takes A2
instead of Queen to G3
then Queen takes H4
and let's say black tries to attack the
pawns with Queen to C4 for example white
can play Queen to d8
King moves somewhere doesn't really
matter where
let's say H7
Queen to D6 and now I've defended both
pawns and now that I start after I start
pushing my D Pawn there's no checks
along that diagonal because the queen it
not only defends pawns also defends the
king and this is resignable uh so yeah
of course
Magnus is not forced to play B4 I think
D5 also
also
it's a slightly sharper way of doing it
because after Queen V2 maybe you just
want to play D6 and you say I don't care
about winning pawns I want to promote my
Pawn maybe that works just as well
but usually you look for ways to just
limit counter play and B4 is a good way
of doing that yeah I mean it's a good
example of how Pond quality is always
more important than upon quantity of
these kind of endings so to five minutes
point they're playing D5 and just trying
to rush that upon the queen takes B2 D6
full steam ahead you can't stop me the
one concern you would have is if the
queen for black can simultaneously
attack the pawn from behind the d-pawn
and threaten some kind of repetition so
uh the queen on e4 are just on the
e-file in general you can give the G3
square but then black can't follow up
with E1 but as you're highlighting the
F4 squared is C1 that's something that
you have to keep an eye on but it does
seem like white can handle both well the
obvious way that that would blunder is
to show everybody would be something
like this just allow although funnily
enough even in this line maybe there's a
way for the king out but okay yeah the
king escapes and that's why I think
white can play Queen to E8 King to H7
and D7
and after black gives checks let's say
F4 King to G1
D4 yeah King to F1 Queen to D1 King to
F2 the king is escaping by going up
Queen to D2 King to F3
Queen to D3 King to F4
um
and I I
um Magnus plays
even more surprising
he plays B3 just a simple move
yeah so here after Queen takes A2 he's
going to go for the beep on Queen D5
King somewhere again King H7 let's say
queen takes B5
and coupons two pawns yeah and you can
always just bring that Queen right back
to E4 yeah take care of the chair you
could also if they go for the d-pawn you
could again go pick up the H Pawn if you
wanted to
yeah and you'll bring your queen to E5
you centralize the queen and then you
can keep your king shielded and then
push your pass Pawn this is for Magus
Carlson this is Elementary
yeah this is um already a simple
technical task
for white
B3
I think the question now is what will
Yan do to recover from this
at least to stop the bleeding because
well you have to do two things one is
you have to stop
losing but the matches
you know there won't be so many games
left soon that you already you have to
start getting on the scoreboard as well
that's why I was very critical yesterday
is because I felt like time was starting
to run out that even though it's
understandable after a nearly eight hour
game finishing past midnight losing
sleep you only have so many games
remaining and half of the match was over
before today and Magnus had an extra
white and he's making good use of it in
today's game so that's why I was saying
that you know in Lavon and Fabi and
everybody was kind of saying like the
preparation it felt like it needed to be
sharper it needed to be giving Beyond
more chances because the way that game
went was too simple for Magnus and
Magnus is well prepared he's playing
lines that Jan can't break and look at
Jan right now I mean I feel for him like
he is undoubtedly devastated and that is
hard to watch yep
yeah he uh well he understands of course
where this position is going
um he can already consider resignation
soon in this in this game he's probably
reflecting on
what went wrong because after Bishop
takes C4
we we understand that black is under
pressure but also that black must have
some way of equalizing this position
yeah
well we were looking at all kinds of
lines that included Queen D6 we also
looked at A6
yeah we we thought maybe King to G8 we I
don't think yeah we looked at those
critical positions where even if Queen
E7 happened it wasn't it wasn't so clear
especially because of the tactics
including yeah Bishop takes F7 king of
fate and black actually wins so like I I
think if we continue this line that yeah
I think black was equalizing here and as
a pawn sacrifice I like this one a lot
more Rook takes F7 yep and we kind of
stopped here but after King to H7 this
looks like a way better Pawn sacrifice
rook's F4 G5 yep it's very awkward to
keep defending that pawn on D4 it was
this type of line we were anticipating
because we know Yawn is a resourceful
Defender especially when he can find
those tricky we we compare them to a car
Nakamura a lot of the time right he'll
defend a position by finding a forcing
way to give you something but he knows
it's not enough to actually win that was
what we were first trying to do when we
saw B5 give it the benefit of the doubt
okay is this some forcing draw but the
eval bar unfortunately as we say ball
don't lie ebelbar don't lie it instantly
said no B5 is no good
and everything from here on out was a
uh a train wreck
well especially this move yep because
this is the objective moment when it
went from possibly bad to dead loss
Bishop takes H3 we were still struggling
to find yep a clear way for of course
white is much better and we thought
Queen takes F7 and white would have good
chances to win but black also has good
chances to draw and maybe objectively
it's even more on the drawing side right
than on the winning for white side
so that's that's the real moment Queen
to d8 is when it all fell apart for him
yep and that was it was the moment that
had us all really
really just
befuddled uh yawn
now down two Pawns in the live position
a clean two Pawns
because the queen is centralized
defending everything
this is a a really unfortunate moment
for yonda Palm Desi fans
who now now see their man with uh his
literal literally with his back against
the wall going forward although on the
flip side of things people have been
criticizing Magnus Carlson for so many
years now he can't win a match against
these top level players in classical
chess
he goes up five to three with this win
he's going to silence some of those
people and people keep asking him in the
press conference about his legacy I
don't think it's the right time to ask
him about that because it's unfair to
him to make him think about things
besides the chess but when we start
talking about Legacy and Matt is winning
Another World Championship it's not a
foregone conclusion but he's really
headed towards that this is probably
good for his confidence which is bad
news for the rest of the Chess World who
wants to beat him yep
I I think the Magnus in general has or
let's say other players have a top level
which is very close to magnus's level
but Magnus has that consistency and we
see it here like on on a best day Jan
and Magnus will be
uh we'll have a similar level but Magnus
has bad days less often than other
players in his match he hasn't really
you know he doesn't have those blackout
moments right uh like we saw here he
might at some have shaky games but he
always keeps that consistency pretty
high that that uh mean level relatively
uh High yep and that makes a difference
at least in this first half of the match
that that has made the difference
well and one other thing to add to that
is you know it took Magnus
many games to get opportunities but when
he has here in game six and game eight
the there is no doubt about his ability
to convert and one thing he does also
better than everybody else is he you
know he when his opportunities are there
he takes them right unfortunately for
Jan the biggest opportunity
opportunities he may have gotten in this
match could be behind him games two
games five
game two yeah he had an objectively
tremendous Advantage he knew it Magnus
knew it and then he expressed in the
press conference some fear and right now
Magnus is just trying to convert this
Advantage he he can take all the time he
wants there's a rest day tomorrow and
really it doesn't even there weren't it
doesn't matter he just wants to win the
game and of course he's clearly winning
this but for Jana Palmer she his best
chances are behind him and I still
believe he can strike back but he needs
to change his repertoire he can't keep
going to these anti-martial lines where
he's trying to get the slimmest of
advantages because he's also not
pressing them in a way that comes close
to allowing him to convert but yonda
palmishi he needs to rest up he needs to
look at some sharp lines going into the
next game he gets the white pieces and
if he can win that game we're talking
about a new match right if he doesn't
win that game
well that's the world champion for you
yeah
for sure and maybe even the next time he
gets black despite Fabiano's prediction
proving to be accurate big surprise that
the Petrov would be played today maybe
again with the black pieces Robert your
your suggestion over breakfast yesterday
will we will we see a sicilian at some
point so I also believe that Jana Palmer
she has the style and and at his highest
level is capable of beating Magnus
Carlson unfortunately though when you
hand someone a two-game lead it's uh
you have new Dynamics to consider right
similar to what we would say in in a
basketball game right being up by 20 the
team now has control of possession right
you have other weapons you can use
against someone when you're leading a
match when you're leading a game when
someone is up two games the amount of
openings available to Magnus the
decisions he can make because a peaceful
result is never a bad result anymore the
whole dynamic changes so the gloves have
to come off and Max's Juggernaut we've
seen this in tournament play as well
there was a year in Vikings a where I
think he started with four or five draws
and then he just are winning all of his
games so when he gets that first taste
of Victory uh no good and he can be
stressed he can be frustrated when he
doesn't win and he is an objective
player but as the number one rated
player in the world and everyone expects
you at all times to win and of course he
expects great things out of himself that
can weigh on you now he has two wins in
this Championship he has nothing else to
prove he just needs to keep on going and
not lose any games well one of the
important things is that Magnus doesn't
have to change strategies right he he
his strategy was to play solid but
flexible openings with black and try to
put pressure with white and he took some
risks early on with white
with black he doesn't have to change
strategy at all he can continue to play
his openings and Jan is the one who has
to either continue trying to hit his
head against the wall in the
anti-martial maybe finding some ideas
there or maybe in the previous like in
the previous games find more or less
nothing
and Beyond will maybe have to consider
playing for women with black at some
point like if he doesn't win the next
game he might have to start playing per
win with black that's a total strategy
change and I don't think that most
people come into a world championship
match
um with being able to easily switch
modes from I'm trying to play a Petro up
and solid game with black 2. I'm doing
something because I need to win at all
costs with black because you know I'm
I'm down two two games with with four
games to go and every game becomes
critical so that also eases the
psychological pressure on Magnus and
puts more pressure on Young
and again we we discussed all of this
yesterday in our in our in our fear or
the comment I made when when we had
Lebanon it wasn't even so much that Jan
didn't get anything as white as that I
was sure Magnus would not do him the
same favor of having such a short game
with a lead and here Magnus had no
intention of doing that very clearly
of course John helped him with some
mistakes here but right now this is uh
showing the difference in terms of match
experience I think as well for Magnus
and his uh
his Focus to put this thing away
yeah and he's remaining focused he's
remaining alert he's just making sure
that he doesn't make some kind of
careless Pawn push gives up one Pawn of
his two Pawn advantage and then has to
watch out for these checks so the game
we're very well aware that this is a win
for Magnus it's not even much of a
question at this point but Magnus is
being cautious because the one thing you
can't afford to do is just take things
for granted and Magnus is really look at
it look at him he's fully focused
because if and when he converts this
he's feeling great about retaining his
world championship title well he's
considering two options one is to play
Queen takes H4 here after Queen B3 you
put the queen on E5
or wants to play Queen D3 which he did
um I was thinking the the safer Choice
was to play Queen H4 put the queen 95
and start pushing the d-pawn because
that is certainly winning
um what he did is also certainly winning
it's
it's trying to end the game a bit faster
yeah because he's saying okay you have
some check on F4 but I'll just play King
G1 King F2 my king can go to the center
safely and I'll push the D5 pawn and
that B3 Pawn as an outside pass Pawn is
more important than the H4 Pawn right
um you know it's like Queen D1 right and
just cover the first rank so you get one
check on a diagonal and then just push
the d-pawn yeah I was thinking why uh
black I was thinking black would play
Queen C1 but then Queen C4 trades Queens
so Queen F2 maybe he just wants to play
Queen D1 here uh I think that's a great
idea he's got the king hides on H1 the
d-pawn pushes and actually that d-pawn
can push and even sacrifice itself
because a trade of Queens would mean
white has an extra outside pass B Pawn
Black's king would get super distracted
trying to get that pawn white would
collect the king side and two on one and
promote a pawn
so Queen D1
yeah I think that both D5 here and queen
D1 are
are absolutely clinically winning
um
but Queen D1 is even more depressing for
black because you don't allow any checks
yeah Queen D1 we might actually see it
resigns I doubt it but it's possible
because Queen D1 is that
that's uh really takes the air out of
out of your sales
no more Perpetual check with the queen
on D1 hide the king and uh push him baby
black will have to put the queen
oh okay I think he's going to uh a
similar Square not exactly the same as
D1 but from here everyone the idea is
the queen guards both C3 G3 and E1 so
this check here is met even by something
like King to G1 and the point is the
queen guard's everything I like this
most of all because the queen also
supports a b-pawn push right so maybe
it's not even the d-pawn which is the
most dangerous but the B Pawn will push
will go ahead and black has no checks he
can try to create checks but it's only
for one move right create one check and
then wise King will hide again
so he'll probably play Queen to E4 after
King G1 white will start pushing the B
Pawn and queen B1 is met by the king
hiding on H2 again yeah and to your
point that even if the queen for black
attacks the D5 Square well I could still
play D5 yep because if the black queen
takes it then Queen C4 forces the queen
trade white easily wins with the extra
Pawn in the king and pawn ending because
black will be distracted the pawn will
be a decoy on the queen side and White's
King will mop up on the king side so
yeah there's no way to stop all of
White's plans and it seems that queen of
four is one check you're not even
getting another the only thing is don't
play Queen C4 first
yeah don't play Queen C4 because that
would actually allow the dark Square
perpetuals back in the game well I would
have to play Queen F1 and lose one of
those pawns and potentially well King H7
was actually played by Yan to avoid
those types of lines where Magnus just
sacrifices either Pawn but heading into
any King upon ending if you imagine the
Queen's off the board easily winning
because this King has to come over and
white mops up everything here so but the
B Pawn is the one that runs now B4 and
B5 and X if black does nothing yep and
if black plays Queen E4
uh to play B5 Queen to B1 check
well white has various ways of course of
slowly pushing those pawns up because
let's say queen to E4 I can play Queen
to D2 now
now I want to push the d-pod up both
those pawns are going up the board
Queen's 25 but then I give 93 and now B5
yeah and slowly but surely once it gets
surgical from this point marches up the
board kind of like the queen on D1
better I did like the queen on D1 better
I I just felt like this would have been
the ultimate
the ultimate uh deflating move Queen D1
it just removes all of the worry that
you have but your king falling victim to
a check and you just start pushing your
pawns but okay
Magnus will uh
we'll do do what he does anyway and
convert this one we have actually just
reached move 40 as you saw there which
means at time control both players get
an hour added back onto their clock that
was not magic that was by Design so
Magnus is three minutes turns to an hour
and three minutes and yawn with an hour
and 17 once again
but at this point not not really
irrelevant a relevant talking point I
think even without a D4 Pawn white winds
very sexually yeah yeah just by playing
B4 and the King will run to the center
so usually Queen undeen's with an out
with with a pass Pawn an outside pass
Pawn
um and nothing special happening on the
other side of the board and here the
pawns are kind of fixed there's nothing
really to speak of in terms of Black's
counterplay usually an outside passport
wins the game so even if Magnus
somehow lost that part which is hard to
imagine
I don't think that it would change the
valuation it would just change the
amount of time that this game would take
yeah
well again we are back to a similar
situation we've been in many times
Magnus Carlson thinking at the board in
a winning position yonda Palm Desi
not at the board
understandably at this point doesn't
want to sit there and look at his lost
position but unfortunately
unfortunately it may not matter
yeah no Magnus I think he's doing the
right thing here though and it's a great
lesson for chess players of all levels
in particular for newer chess players if
the world champion has a completely
winning position and he's sitting and
thinking trying to find the objective
best move let's make sure nobody else
should do that too yeah
it's hard work to win chess games right
and uh people obviously you know some
people have talked about Magnus being a
genius but also I think he is the
hardest working chess player in the
world and you see that in moments like
this and it's why he wins more chess
games than than everyone else in the
world so
um there is a saying in chess the
hardest thing in chess is to win a one
position yeah and I'm not sure if that's
the hardest thing in chess but it's hard
in the sense that that's when people
feel like their job is done right and it
very often isn't
um a lot of one positions maybe even
most one positions are at some point
spoiled right even positions where
someone's up four pawns right yep even
even those positions and I wonder who uh
who spoiled such a position um I don't
know
maybe this guy
oh who could who could spoil four puns
up and then tweet about it
um
yeah
no but you make a good point Bobby
because even if the game is still won
when we when we review it afterwards you
look at it with the computer it's
amazing how often chess games that you
were winning at some point
you gave your opponent a chance right
whether they always took it or not is
another question and it shows how hard
it is to win you you realize that was
experience very often positions winning
positions that are actually one in the
game there's usually one moment when the
opponent has a defensive chance right
and that goes from both sides like when
when you've played
um for many years you you realize I'm
more and more analyzing your games even
at the top level
uh you see that there's maybe there's
only one moment but there is that
defensive chance for the opponent and
that also helps you uh mentally realize
that
if you keep resisting if you don't give
up at some point you will probably have
that chance if you take it then you
might save a position that would have
been lost right and I if that applies to
the top level I'm sure it applies to
every level in chess right uh the
question is of course it's difficult to
know when that moment is it defending it
is still a super difficult skill to to
build up and to develop
but if you do it you you realize I'm
starting to save so many positions that
I would have lost and it's really
changing my results
that's that's uh one of the things I
think people could improve on the most
to at every level to improve their
results is never giving up
shows the discipline the Magnus has to
no matter what he's not thinking about
anything else that's going on clearly
not he didn't put his jacket on the back
of the chair in a nice way yeah he
didn't even he he taking his time took
the jacket off took 40 moves for him to
take his jacket off but he ultimately
does so here in game eight and uh again
just showing an example that uh he's not
going to even let his opponent have a
have a single sliver of a thought that
he might hold this game and also you
know there's a psychological Edge we
keep talking about the fact that the
match might be over on some practical
levels the truth is it's not over until
it's over and Magnus I think doesn't
mind sitting at the board in a winning
position
and and I there is something to that I
think that's part of it that maybe you
want to just prolong the suffering of
your opponent but I really do think that
he is just double triple quadruple
checking that he does not allow some
sudden checks some repetition some
Perpetual check possibilities and it's
just why waste this moment where if you
know objectively you're winning you just
gained an hour on the clock so why win
in five minutes and potentially spoil
the victory versus spend an hour and
make sure that you win the game so I
think he's doing the absolute right
thing I think he's probably even a
little jittery and and nervous right
because this is a critical moment if he
somehow does not win this game now Jan
is the one who's like wait a second I
have chances still Magnus makes mistakes
I handed him such a great opportunity
and he didn't make the most of it so I
think that Magnus Carlson he's way too
experienced he's way too strong and he
is just a great head on his shoulders
both in terms of Chess generally
speaking and in A Moment Like This to
rush because there is no need to yeah
yeah I think nerves is important
um word that that Robert used because
even though we think of uh Magnus and I
think strong players in general as uh
being super cool and calm under pressure
even Magnus especially at these Stakes
gets nervous and uh he understands that
this game might be the match yeah it's
not over yet of course but a two-game
lead he's probably thinking already that
this is his match
um so he doesn't want to spoil his
moment I'm sure that he is he's nervous
despite the fact that he has complete
control in a totally winning position
and he just wants to clean this game up
with no counter play without letting
anything get out of control so he's just
looking for the most accurate way he has
plenty of time which means that he can
he can basically calculate this to the
end because Black's counter play if
there is any
um
is easy to spot right like after B4 or
whatever move he's looking at
there's only a few moves that black has
that stops V5 and so he can he can go
through the moves to make sure that he
uh calculates this out as accurately as
possible
uh also when you're playing at that
stage and it's already been a tough
match they've played a number of long
games including the longest game in
world world championship history
um your head starts to spin like I'm
sure this happens to everyone where
um just the pressure of the moment and
the tiredness gets to you and uh and
you're not feeling physically like you
normally do so in those moments it's
good to calm down and remind yourself
that you have complete control
and for the moment you haven't made a
mistake so make sure that you don't get
careless and make a mistake right uh
sometimes it's important to calm down
and
uh and not rush with decisions we
already saw in this match how important
uh rushing or not rushing can be
and I think he's doing exactly what
you're saying Fabi he's trying to
conclude this game in his head right now
he's trying to map out a road to Victory
on the spot where there's no chance for
Yan and he made his little facial
expression that led me to believe that
he didn't quite find it he's going
probably 25 moves deep and people often
ask this question oh how much can you
calculate right and positions like this
end games you often calculate 20 25
moves at the Grand Master Level so he
went Queen D3 check he brings his Queen
behind the pawn and he is either getting
ready to push the pawn immediately or
cover the first Rank and then push the
pawn but he spent quite a lot of time
because he wants to perfect this end
game
good stuff and uh on that on that note
Robert you asked that question how how
deep is Magnus thinking people often ask
that question we actually had that
question coming from Chad earlier which
uh reminds me I want to remind everybody
while we have all of you here before
this game ends that uh 10 lucky fans
will actually get an opportunity to have
a private lesson with Fabiano carwana
it's private in a group setting as we
debut our new feature classroom a tool
that's rolling out to connect coaches
and students around the world forever
more on the interwebs it's going to be
amazing and Fabiano caruana debuts it on
December 13th 10 of you will get at
least one question answered I will be
the Maestro on that day I'll make sure
everyone gets at least one question
answered so all you have to do is take
at least one video Lesson in Fabiano's
new series that he did on his road to
the world championship in 2018 which was
an amazing video series regardless you
should go check it out and then tweet or
insta a screenshot as proof that you did
so
uh and uh on that note I want to remind
everybody too before we take a very
short break and then probably bring this
thing to a close that when this game
ends our post show begins we have
several guests coming up let's remind
everybody who they are we have Lavon
aronian once again we'll let Levin Fabi
discuss what they think about team yawn
at this point and the state of the World
Chess Championship Match we'll have John
Ludwig Hammer as usual and then we will
have Ludwig today double question mark
for the memes because Ludwig is doing
everything he can to evade the question
who is his favorite person in chess
Magnus Carlson or Robert Hess we're
going to leave you on that Cliffhanger
because it might lead to some fun talk
and chat uh maybe there's a twist ending
a third person that's becoming his new
favorite person in chess I don't know
is it you Denny we'll be right back
[Music]
you ready yeah your Knights on F7 where
can it go F7 D6 e87h5 G3 E2 C1 B3 white
King on A3 white Pawn on B3 black king
on E7 who wins it's a draw Lexington
gets to Aid before what's King gets to
B7 name the fastest Checkmate for White
e45 Queen H5 King 7 Queen Tech C5
recount your opening versus Alexa Yenko
from the first half of the 2020
candidates tournament T4 Knight of six
c46 Knight C3 Bishop B4 F3 D5 A3 Bishop
E7
e4d for fe4 stop tell us about a chess
game that made an impression on you
karpov kaspar from the world
championship match 1985 kaspora's
octopus Knight on D3 controlled eight
squares in the enemy camp and allowed
him to become the world champion there's
an identity five what squares does it
attack F7 D7 C6 C4 D3 F3 G4 G6 stop how
do you do this
visualization and chess isn't difficult
for me it just comes naturally
where does crypto come from
honestly I don't know
can you tell me
learn more at coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free crypto when you
sign up and verify your account
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we may be moments away
from the final move of game eight
guess where that Queen is back on D1
it's where she should have gone from the
beginning when we saw that idea finally
Magnus you're finally doing it right
Magnus well I just think that it makes
his life as easy as possible because
there's no more checks he can just push
his pawns at the board and Jan's doing
the only thing he possibly can is
throwing his pawns forward hoping that
Magus makes a mistake the game of course
is in Max's hands D5 and so on the pawn
goes up but that's the thing let's say
you play D5
and then black plays G4 all of a sudden
you have a few decisions you have to
make because if your queen ever leaves
D1 then there's Queen E1 check Queen E5
check and yeah that's how you go from a
win to a draw his idea must be G4
because otherwise White's Pawn just
pushes down the board on G5 broadcasts
that he wants to play G4 but after H
takes G4
his only idea is H3 and well I mean
white has so many moves
maybe the easiest actually I I don't
think black threads anything so also
like D6 comes to mind as a very
uh easy way to win because white is
after all of three pawns King to H2 kind
of forces I was worried about Queen G3
to like force the the issue I think that
um I mean to to start with G takes H3 is
probably uh completely winning you
actually just get out I I think the king
escapes
um
as well as
well that might that might be the
easiest way
in fact because take King G1 Queen G3
King F1 the king just goes up the board
uh
black would need to be able to play
Queen F3 here to continue the checks in
a way that can allow the king out but
the queen covers that and if Queen H3
King dev2 what does doesn't matter yeah
it doesn't really matter but King death
two I like the most because it
immediately escapes from any yeah useful
checks Queen H2 King F3 Queens three
King anywhere F4 just go it keeps going
up and it will hide behind its pawns at
some point yep King to F5 it's already
nearly hidden it'll go to E6 uh D7 and
Etc
um so so yeah this is just the last
desperate countermeasure G5 G4 it
doesn't it doesn't work out for black
for uh numerous reasons but it would
work out every let's see D5 G4 just to
show what the big idea is if Queen takes
G4
Queen E1 check King H2 Queen E5 check
and you've gone a little wrong here
because the queen can go back and forth
white would have to interpose with the
pawn going to G3 but it opens up more
checks along the second rank as well and
yeah that's how you don't win positions
and even I think this one is already
possibly a draw yes because White's
Queen is really misplaced and queen B2
then the queen gives check on C1 and
then to D2 white King has to go up to
hide but now going up isn't so easy
because D5 is hanging and B3 is hanging
and G3 is potentially hanging so
um yeah I would just go D5
because G4 doesn't seem to be much of a
worry
I was also thinking D5 G4 white has
another very simple way after hd4
H3 I like to move King H2
because it forces hg2 I like that and
then King G2 and black has one check
Queen E4 and white can put the queen on
F3 Queen goes to C2 and whites King
hides either on G3 or H3
all pawns are defended by the queen and
the king is also defended by the queen
so this is three points yes yeah and
even if you lose one of the pawns as
long as you can get a check that trades
the Queens off you have too much extra
minutes although shout out to yon for
even going for this idea because at
least it creates the appearance of chaos
right something that's all you can do is
create the appearance of Chaos
but I just really think that Magnus is
being a role model right now by
continuing to think he knows he's
winning he knows that D5 will end up in
a win but he continues to calculate
rather than just make moves with his
hand he continues to use his brain he's
focused he's locked in here and I mean
this is really great stuff from the
world champion
this is why I said when you look at
magnus's body language don't read too
much into it because he actually looks a
little bit
he of course understands fully how
winning it is uh he's just looking for
the way which allows the least amount of
counter play which
which I'm sure he'll find shortly but
yeah not rushing he's demonstrating that
if you look at the time he's
significantly lower on time but time
doesn't matter when you have a winning
position
sums it up nicely
[Laughter]
yeah I wonder if I I mean
there may be something more accurate
than the lines we looked at but I think
I think what we saw was good enough
yeah it's as we said it G4 looks
trickier than it actually is and again
it's important whatever your whatever
you're losing to create chances like
that by as we said creating
chaos or at least the appearance of
chaos a lesser a lesser man might
actually mess up and allow some sort of
Perpetual as you guys have demonstrated
a couple times right if G4 is met by
Queen takes well now we actually have
that problem
if you're afraid of opening your king
and if you take here allow H3 it
optically looks a little bit scary for a
moment but concrete calculation I think
King H2 might be your nicest nicest way
to just make it look easy Bobby and
there he goes you pushed D5 and he has
indeed pushed the Deep on so Jan's last
chances are uh are going to be put to
the test here as soon as neponishi is
back at the board we expect him to
quickly to quickly shove forward with G4
in fact
he does it instantly
right on cue
yeah well CH takes G4 for sure
um H3 and
Queen F3 King H2 D6 all these moves look
good I don't think D6 will happen
because it gives black some extra checks
I suspect actually we might see Queen to
F3 because the queen is really great
there it stops not only does it defend
uh all the pawns it also stops all the
checks so
maybe I mean King H2 also looks
pretty clean
but Queen F3 even seems to be a shortcut
to uh yeah that position that we were
looking at HD2 now played that on the
board
yeah
and there it is resignation
Magnus Carlson takes game eight
I mean I thought instead of B5
Queen D6 Queen D3 and so on yeah it's
gonna be free if someone is
A6 or something this
is
not too many words
when you lose your second game in a
world championship match understandably
so
yawn
has exited the glass box
that's uh that's going to be a really
tough one to come back from we already
suspected the any loss might be tough to
come back from yep but especially this
because it wasn't just the loss yeah
although the loss is huge right it was
also the manner in which it happened yep
it wasn't
it doesn't look like Jan is is the same
player that he was in the first uh few
games in the match right he no longer
looks like he's willing to put in that
effort and defense
um even in the game he lost he was
defending very tenaciously for a very
long time and we understand you know you
make a mistake on move 130 in a in a
terribly difficult maybe even
practically lost position
but this there was no fight here there
was no once he got a worse position it
it just went downhill instantly yep
which on the flip side makes it a great
opening choice for Magnus Carlson yeah
he had the one point lead he made sure
that he was never in any danger
whatsoever and he said work for it if
you're gonna draw this game and only
have a one-game deficit you're gonna
have to work until the very end of this
game and well as five of them just said
he made this move B5 and then queen of
d8 to follow that did not help his cause
and it caused him to lose
and ultimately it lands us where we are
looking back instead of talking about a
game in progress it's now time for our
coinbase rapid recap this is game eight
of the 2021 fide World Chess
Championship and as Robert just said
this was another Petrov a uh a choice
from the world champion predicted on the
board by Fabiano caruana here in the
studio as not just a pet shop but the
exact line with Bishop E3 and D5 and
Knight takes E5 now here when young
played Knight D7 this is when we had our
first not necessarily surprise right you
highlighted the main line including the
uh the game between bishidon and Wang
Hao from the 2019 fide Grand Swiss uh
that occurs with Knight to C3 but
instead fobby we had Knight takes D7 and
then the actual first surprise this
interesting move Knight D2 yeah this is
a rare move and we pointed out the
reason for it is because if White
Castles first and after Bishop D6 Knight
to D2 uh if Magnus were to try the same
approach
black is not forced to take on D2
transposing into the game but can castle
using the tactic available to him which
is Bishop takes H2 if white captures on
e4
and here black would equalize very
easily yep because regaining the piece
and and uh staying equal material with
the with an equal position so Magnus had
a tricky little idea of his sleeve it's
again typical Magnus to have some small
try which uh you know on paper it looks
like black equalizes comfortably but he
understands that there's some small
problems to solve and as Robert
mentioned
he's in a good position he was in a good
position in the match up uh one game so
he could afford to play a slightly more
quiet and solid line taking no risks
because we understood white risks
nothing in this type of position but
still keeping some slight pressure on
young and in this position here after
castles we he mentioned no real risk but
some slight pressure there were so many
lines we were looking at that really
showed how how tricky this position is
for black ultimately yawn actually took
a lot of time here before the movie on
cork but remind us Robert of just the
critical reasons why simple moves like
castles could have been hard for black
yeah this game is a great demonstration
of first move Advantage yeah because
after castling we have the same exact
position for both sides but white gets
to strike first with Queen to H5
threatening Queen takes H7 Checkmate
threatening Queen takes D5 and if black
is forced to play F5 you have made a
huge concession the E5 Square
potentially the E6 square and the e-file
white is first to to that because the
Rooks are connected so that's why Young
don't decide not to play Castle's
kingside played The Adventurous H5 but
it was the follow-up after this that
really caught us off guard yet Magnus in
turn spent a lot of time digging here
which was interesting right because
Magnuson courts Knight D2 yon takes a
whole lot of time to play H5 Magnus
really stops to think I think in
hindsight we can say it was because he
might have already been sensing okay
this is an opportunity here right I'm
gonna get something Dynamic enough to
push for and he plays not the obvious
rookie one check which may have maybe
has a little something not even a more
logical move like Queen F3 that we were
looking at but a move we hadn't really
talked about except for really briefly
this move Queen E1 check was played
to ask the question to the king but also
to create this interesting threat of
transitioning into a position where the
dark Square bishops come off the board
in a huge way for white
yeah H5 was a fascinating move I I feel
like it was the result of knowledge of
the position I think that Jan knew
something about this line yeah and
because
in hindsight we know that H5 would have
worked out quite fine for black but
after Queen to E1 which uh I'm sure was
a surprise for yawn and a surprise for
all of us
Queen to E7 I think would have been a
fairly equal past fairly easy pass path
to equality and we were looking at the
line where Black's King runs up to F6
Queen takes E7 King takes E7 Rook ate
one king to F6
the king is momentarily in some danger
after H4 but then black would play
Bishop to F5 trading off more pieces
including the bishop which is slightly
worse than whites and leading to I think
a pretty much dead equal position yeah
if yarn had played Queen E7 I don't
think he would have encountered very
serious problems
um that's not to say that he would have
necessarily held the game
after that
he might still have been put under
pressure later
but I don't think that he would have
faced opening problems well perhaps even
more illogical though was that not just
that he played King f8 that that move
may be okay but after Bishop before he
then played Queen E7 right so if you
were going to do it why not do it before
it's the question that I think everyone
wants the answer to it didn't really
make sense and his position wasn't that
bad even after this point we saw the
bishops get traded but the issue is that
Rook on h8 you can lift up to H6 an idea
that we're talking about during the game
and eventually happen but the problem is
you he could never quite bring his Rook
to E6 so that H5 Pawn once pawns
Advanced they can't move back and when
your king is on that side of the board
if you lose that kind of Pawn your kings
in really big danger so the move H5 had
its purposes but now that Rook couldn't
quite get into the game yeah and queen
G5 was the move that really highlights
what you said that the Rook would love
to come over here and challenge the
e-file but not so fast because of the
pawn the queen would love to come over
and get this thorn out of his shoes so
to speak but you got to worry about D5
and because of that Jon play hc6 but now
Robert you highlighted a really critical
point which is that because this Pawn
comes to C6 to defend D5 the bishop
actually suddenly has less scope and
that led to some forcing lines for
Magnus he played Rook takes E8 maybe
there were other options but immediately
grabbing the e-file and trying to get
aggressive over here because of the the
lack of activity that that Bishop now
had right because rookie 6 would be
available and if we just go through that
line once more Rook takes E6 you can't
take with the pawn but then you have a
terrible structure the queen on G5 is
great black spawns can't move so if you
take with the queen you lose H5 you get
a single check on E1 and unfortunately
in chess you can't play Bishop to B5 you
can't jump over your own Pawn here
otherwise black would be winning but
because that pawn went to C6 Magnus
reels he could capitalize on the moment
and take over the e-file yeah and that's
exactly the kind of moment that just is
whatever you want to call it Magnus
Carlson's calling card the little things
right that become big things he's king
of making the mountains out of mohills
if you will Pawn on C6 led to this
forcing line where black problems were
becoming even more clear Queen F6 is now
played because the pawn does defend D5
but after Queen to E3 and Bishop D7 you
said again Magnus knows when to change
the position and he did so here and yawn
in hindsight
we know the next move was a big mistake
should he have also tried to maintain
this tension you feel like that was
right on cue in terms of what black has
to play I think that uh the move H3 is a
bit underappreciated because this was
actually one of the most impressive
moves in the game I thought yeah it
looks like white needs to do something
very direct but in fact I liked uh H3
just giving White's King some Luft and
we saw a line after H3 black plays Queen
to D6 trying to trade Rooks via E6 Queen
to G5 Queen to F6 trying to trade Queens
again
Queen to G3 Queen D6 trying to trade
Queens for the third time now if white
plays rookie five
black no longer has rookie 6 as an
option if the pawn were on H2 black
would have Rook E6 with a good position
but here Rook takes H5 this would be met
by this with a Pawn on H2 yeah now white
King has that square on H2 to go to
White's Bishop is not forced into
passivity so it stays on D3 and white
has a healthy extra Pawn so this was the
point of H3 the reason why
yon couldn't immediately solve his
issues and why he played a waiting move
in return H4 which is a perfectly good
move
but now Magnus could say well my H3 Pawn
is more useful than your H4 Pawn because
I never have to worry about the back
rank again and then he hit in the center
with C4 he sensed this was the moment to
try to play concretely although this
move likely doesn't lead to an advantage
uh it still gives black concrete
problems to solve and for some reason
Jan wasn't ready to start calculating
lives yep he directly took maybe maybe
uh taking wasn't necessary but we felt
like taking on C4 was the correct
decision for black and he was at this
moment
that Jan chose a shocking move
B5
the move that will be talked a lot about
again because it
what are all the reasons well obviously
objectively it's not a good move right
he lost the pawn but it also arguably
was not necessary yet you had been
holding well Robert for some time right
and because of the nature in which it
leads to forcing lines you have to
assume okay if you're if you're forcing
something you better have calculated but
when you when you clearly didn't it can
only be described as a reckless move
something that Sergey karyakin did so
well in his world championship match
against Magnus is he didn't force the
issue he was okay to be the one reacting
to Max's plans even though it meant he
would not get activity of his own he
said I'm solid enough I'll be able to
hold B5 is going full steam ahead and
the position doesn't call for it now
your Pawn on A7 was directly lost and
what my coach said growing up his
mistakes often come in pairs in chess
and it was first B5 then after Queen A3
check King the G8 queen queen d8 doesn't
even put up a fight because the only
resistance that could be had in the
position was Bishop takes H3 it's going
to be a bad end game you're going to
grovel for a draw all and maybe you
won't make it but Queen d8 is just
saying I have no fight left in me this
is your game and for those who may be
just tuning in perhaps the line there
were many that might have might have
been on the board in the game could have
been something like this where black
does have Bishop F5 and while again
objectively white is up a pawn and we
did display in real time probably
probably some of the better plans for
white perhaps starting with moves like
rookie 5 to try to convert at the very
least this needs to be converted this is
going to take some work and black
showing chances are are clear only being
down a pawn
but in the game as Robert said perhaps
even more perplexing than B5 was the
follow-up Queen d8
and now you're just you're just sitting
in a position down a pawn right here
white has the pawn and the compensation
so to speak Bishop B3
Rook up to E4
and I'm gonna I'm gonna go forward I
don't know that there was anything
better for Yan at this point the
pressure on F7 via the x-ray vision that
the queen displays on the seventh rank
forces a move like Bishop E6 well let's
just show why why young didn't make make
a waiting move like G6 okay in fact
there's probably more than one reason
Rook to F4 is probably winning on the
spot there's also Rook takes H4 if we
like a cute little tactics uh we we love
cute little tactics around here Queen
takes H4 Queen to B8 wise picked up
another pawn and The Rook is coming with
it yep uh so Jan was obligated to trade
Bishops and although he wants to trade
Bishops he doesn't want to trade Bishops
in this way where he further damages his
structure right and after in this
position we already saw the writing on
the wall it's not only that white is up
a pawn it's that black has too many
weaknesses to hold if he could try to
defend everything while creating counter
play against White's King maybe there
would be some drone chances but he tried
to create counter play with Queen A5 but
he wasn't able to hold all his
weaknesses yeah
goes for some checks but Magnus now at
this point was in he was in uh whatever
you want to call it
conversion mode right he had the focus
of uh of a predator and he never let up
from here on out and uh I can go through
these games the centralized Queen is
obviously super instructive as a very
important thing for everyone to take
away that's how you convert these end
games the queen does the job of
protecting against perpetuals as well as
helping the pawns go forward
um and really Robert you were just you
were just applauding magnus's just
discipline here rights leading by
example if you will is what the world
champion did he'd never he made this
look so easy yeah and he actually also
changed his plans because sometimes
we're stubborn as human beings but also
as chess players where we come up with a
plan in the next few moves he brought
his Queen to C3 when I was saying he
could go Queen D1 he goes Queen C3
and then we see a couple moves played
with check the king comes back he goes
back to D3 and guess what he goes back
to D1 and it's important that you're
willing to go back to a plan you could
have played and realize it maybe this is
what I should have done and all the
moves for the most part would have been
winning but he made this as easy as
possible on himself so he took his time
he kept his composure and then he was
saying I'm willing to change my mind and
go for a plan that may objectively be
best so I think it was great
demonstration of of how to play these
games especially if you're a newer chess
player you can think when you have an
hour on your clock and if you're winning
there's no need to rush
well said and perhaps the last good
example he set is that against any
tenacious Defender at some point they
will challenge you with a plan that at
least looks crazy even if it isn't as as
complicated as first seems and he still
kept his Focus taking with the H Pawn
allowing the wild looking H3 again note
that taking with the queen to keep your
excuse me taken with the queen to keep
your kingside looking pretty could
actually be a huge blunder due to ideas
like Queen E1 check and queen E5 so
really good good example again you have
to calculate in the end because a good
Defender will make you do so and he did
just that with Queen F3 you realize it
was all just smoke and mirrors despite
how scary this kind of looks and yawn in
fact resigned and that is how game eight
came to a close will It ultimately be a
game that we're talking about uh as a
tone Setter for how the World Chess
Championship really came to a close
obviously time will tell there are still
a lot of games ahead including a rest
day tomorrow so we will see what the
Challenger can cook up when he gets
another chance with the white pieces but
before you go anywhere let's remind you
our post show is just beginning we have
so many people who need to tune in and
give us their thoughts cannot wait to
hear what the Von aronian is going to
tell us as he joins us just on the other
side of the post game press conference
we also have young Ludwig hammer and
then the man Ludwig who left twitch
recently for YouTube gaming and so much
to unpack there so as I as I head to a
break I already see the players are
getting set for the post game press
conference so keep it tuned keep it
locked in here chess.com's coverage now
post game coverage of the 2021 feed a
World Chess Championship game eight will
return in just a few
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the cameras in the back and to the
journalists who have not been here for
your questions please use the two
microphones on the sides Be Careful to
always wear your mask at all times and
do not touch the microphones
I'll ask a few questions and then I will
give it to the floor Jan I know that's a
difficult moment and game thank you so
much for joining us and some questions
will certainly be be difficult so they
need to be asked first a question I have
is about the mistake of why did it
happen
well I don't think those questions are
difficult because
yeah basically in you know in another
iteration it would be a draw like in 15
most after Queen E1 check Queen E7 uh
yeah but I would say it was like a
change of uh slightly weird decisions so
starting with King f8 yeah like uh this
was like some somewhat more
um artificial than just Queen E7 yeah
trading away the queens and uh basically
finished clean uh but uh that's uh that
wasn't actually the um such such a big
deal I think it's still very very
natural position like it's almost equal
but yeah perhaps after H4 C4 it became
slightly slightly unpleasant so perhaps
instead of H4 I could just change the
queen like with Queen D6 I intending
rookie 6 so it would also be
um
those are two quality and well uh I mean
indeed B5 uh was just a very bad monitor
but I believe uh at that moment the
position became like slightly unpleasant
but still it was
uh I believe positive draw uh but I mean
of course after B5 it's uh well probably
I didn't defend in the best way but uh
it becomes really unpleasant and I guess
uh Frankly Speaking it's uh it's hard to
defend after such uh such a blunder
what uh what did you overlook you use
did you see the queen A3 check threat
and thought there was something that you
had as a counter or yeah I mean indeed I
saw it but uh I forgot that in The Lion
King Jade Queen E7 bjc4 actually Bishop
is hanging there so but
um once again at this moment it's uh
especially after you take C4 it's not as
uh you know straightforward draw as it
used to be
such a game
must be extremely difficult at the
moment when you when you realize you had
blundered your reaction when you saw it
or what point did you realize it well I
I wasn't quite happy yeah
uh but uh I mean in general uh well the
test Remains the Same yeah I get to I
get to try to win some games so since
anyway I was
um down on uh on scores so now it's
enter the 1v92 wins so let's
uh let's see what will happen
uh final question in this part your
queen to E7 avoidance that you just not
want to play a quick game or are you
trying to keep some fight alive
no I mean okay I just didn't see a big
difference between Queen E7 and King f8
so I thought that anyway it will end
quickly in a draw but uh yeah I mean uh
of course after H5 was you know sort of
um
expecting uh more tense game but yeah
okay Queenie one was a brilliant
practical decision yeah just uh to offer
a draw silently
thanks Magnus uh I guess immediate
feelings after such a win
yeah I'm very happy with the with the
results
um obviously that's um
yeah what can I say it's it's huge
um otherwise I'm
pretty uh pretty uh tired and
I'm looking looking forward to the rest
there
the opening you seemed a bit surprised
you took a long time uh after his age
five to play Queen E1 were you
what were you thinking about at this
point yeah I
I
was
um was a bit confused I I mean I thought
Black's really not supposed to go Bishop
Bishop D6 there
um and uh H5 obviously I couldn't
completely know whether it was
preparation or not although I suspected
that it was not
um well anyway I just sat thinking for
so long that I I couldn't
um
uh yeah I couldn't like
[Music]
um
calculate properly so I decided just to
um to trade queens and then
probably was just was just going to be a
draw uh of course I was I was hoping
slightly that he would go for a king of
Ed since I thought uh I'd have a
risk-free position there
um and um yeah after that the game was
kind of
kind of pleasant for me
um I don't think it's very easy for for
black to
um to force the draw and as long as you
cannot force the draw
um then so it's going to be like a
little bit of pressure that you have to
have to neutralize
um
um yeah then of course um yeah B5
bustled me as well because I thought
that was uh was a blunder
um
and
I was um
uh I think yeah both of us were pretty
pretty tired at that point but um it
always helps to have the initiative in
that case
you're
your reaction in forward when B5
actually came on the board you were say
you were puzzled at some point you must
have realized that this was a big
mistake
no I I I
suspected it wasn't was a mistake like I
I thought it was just was just a blunder
um but I had plenty of time so I thought
I'll double check see what he's
um what he's intending and turned out it
was was nothing
at the end you you seemed especially
careful to me
you won the game the Precision at that
point was just was just abundance of
caution
um yeah
um for instance I could have traded H4
for B3 earlier which probably wins
pretty easily um but I thought
um I do that later I have plenty of time
there's no reason to to force things uh
first things uh quite yet so yeah I
thought the win is not going away let's
um just be really really careful
but a point of being a plus two in a
match of this duration with six games to
go how do you avoid feeling or not
feeling overconfident or relaxing uh
when you're when you have such a
significant lead I think you just
focused on
on the next game always that's um
I mean there are still six games to to
go uh
against a very strong opponent
um so it's it's never easy but um yeah
clearly two games is uh
yeah makes a huge difference to to just
one
I'm sorry final question for you on my
part yeah you're down to how do you
avoid not feeling like this is really a
Herculean challenge
no well uh uh I believe it's about the
level of Chess so I'm
I think uh in the beginning of the match
I got quite some chances and hopefully
if I uh play well I will keep getting
these chances yes so it's
um it's about my own play and I don't
think I should think about this score
but uh yeah indeed it would be better to
have like an equal score instead of this
one but uh we hear what we have
I'll open the floor to the journalists
remember to use the microphones and keep
your mask on I will start here
myclimatechess.com this question is for
the champion uh late in the game Magnus
there was a moment I don't think you
were at the board where Jan put his head
in his hands uh looked visibly more
emotional than in the past what goes
through your mind when you see your
opponent go through those emotions and
do you ever feel sympathy
um yeah I didn't particularly
particularly see that um but um the
world championship is is tough
[Music]
you know it's um it's really brutal uh
emotionally with it with its up and ups
and downs and it's part of what makes it
exciting and also extremely um extremely
tough
Hansel walking from nrk question to
yarnachi
how do you rate your performance today
uh well uh in general I'd like to you
know apologize for today's performance
why
why ah it was um probably far below than
uh
not even let's say my normal level but
in general I think it was below then at
just a GM level were you tired after
three on the third day of playing no I
don't think it's about being tired it's
like
uh some weird sequence of choices but uh
yeah I mean I'm just looking forward for
the next games
yeah Nicholas from afternoon I have a
question for you minus
um you spent many games drawing since
2016 in the world championships now I
won two games uh in three
um what has been the key to that change
yeah I think
um to be honest this um
this second win probably doesn't happen
without without the first
um
so everything is kind of uh kind of
connected
um and um for instance I I think if I'd
won the first game against Corona when I
had a winning position or he had one
um one of the two games where he had a
winning position uh things could have
turned out a lot different there could
have been a lot more decisive games so
um I it's not a it's not a shock that
the second one comes quickly after
the first how do you see your chances to
win the match now they're very good
hi uh saravanan from chess base
uh question to Magnus uh when yarn
played H5 on the ninth move you took a
long thing and uh at that point
commentators on the engines were
suggesting either rookie one or C4
probably
active play against a molec H5 obviously
you must have considered that also what
made you choose Queen E1 instead of a
more involving C4 rather than Queen E1
which will it might lead to Queen E7 and
queen exchange and so on
yeah with so much brain was just fried
um and um I felt that a sharp battle was
not in not in my interests so
um I was trying to calculate
the lines
um if I'd gone for for one of the
principled options but
I I couldn't
um
I couldn't like get any good results
from it so in the end I decided that um
yeah I'll play 21 and if he plays Queen
E7 it's probably going to be
probably going to be a draw
um
um and I would be fine with that
okay does that mean that uh Queenie one
was addition over the board it was not
in your files or your preparation
uh yeah I didn't know the move H5 so uh
I mean I if I'd known the move of H5 I
wouldn't think for 40 minutes and play
um play a move that's um
uh that's so insipid thank you
only from ts24 first a question from
Magnus what move surprised you the most
H5 or B5
I mean that's
that's a weird question uh I I guess
that we're both both surprising uh but
B5
yeah
um before obviously
you know you don't expect your opponent
to to wander okay and uh Jan you are
earning a lot of new fans uh online due
to the way you handle these press
conferences even after a painful game
how do you manage to stay so cool
no but uh I would say it's not the first
game uh I lost in my career though
particularly this one was one of the
worst perhaps uh but uh and uh sadly I
think it's not the last game so I just I
think it's a part of the game and uh
it's a bunch of you know
learning at some point so
once again we have what we have thank
you
Sagar Shah from India my question is to
Yan did magnus's Knight D2 in the
opening surprise you was Bishop D6
preparation
well 92 is obviously not uh
the main line I would say yeah but it's
it could be quite poisonous and I also
I think I played this line with white uh
at least once and of course I studied 92
so perhaps well perhaps Bishop D6 is not
the most precise move but uh well I mean
in general I think their position is
quite balanced and black has a different
a lot of different tries
uh but yeah the H5 idea I think it
exists and uh at least in the 90 free
line it's uh I believe it's quite smart
so I was considering uh
trying to understand what's the
difference but I thought it's anyway it
would be quite playable
uh since
um okay black has its own benefits like
okay Queen H4 Pro King G3 queen of 600
H4
or something like this so I thought it
would be just interesting to see what's
going on in this position after it
becomes slightly unbalanced
and uh when you played uh B5 and Magnus
gave Queen A3 check you are not on the
board for quite some time you are in
your uh in the restroom uh did you
calculate after Queen A7 Bishop takes H3
what was going through your mind because
there still seemed like black could
defend better right well obviously
um I could defend best robots in general
I felt like uh okay uh for quite some
time I was I was regretting of playing
B5
although I think uh after Bishop H3 okay
there is like
capturing on F7 some rookie eight I
believe some rookie check or something
yes so remember G6
sorry rookie A8 there's Rook G6 so I
mean seven
yeah I mean I take with the queen
because if I take with the bishop and
rookie eight there's Rook G6
no but which moments
Bishop H7 if rookie 8 King H7 Bishop
seven there's rookies well again like
Queen E3 okay Queenie free check King
Jade
between takes A7 yeah Queen takes seven
Bishop H3 and we forget check rookie
eight King eight seven takes one F7 our
Bishop F7 rookies here yeah okay it
would be something but I also I was kind
of not sure about Queen takes F7 yeah
this is probably what I have to have to
do yeah but no I mean okay indeed uh I
didn't
um
I didn't play at my best after after
Wonder but it was a little bit hard to
you know to change
uh
that you know the flow of the game
because it was like uh probably in a
very Jewish position of course it's like
plundering upon like this it hurts
thank you
um
Norway a question for young uh I sit
different to bounce back from a lost
game in a match compared to a tournament
well uh once I will bounce back I will
surely tell you
both players did the change of the
Shadows three games before the rest day
effect
the quality of the game today
in previous matches you have two
games and then a rest day is there any
impact
I guess no I think the eight hour game
affected the next the next games
um but I'm I'm in general of for it that
um
you know shaking it up a bit and making
it more difficult for for the players
yeah
I would agree that okay and and our
games is something you don't expect to
happen too often uh but in general uh
yeah I mean uh probably three free games
in a row is slightly more difficult than
two games in a row uh but it all starts
you know
you know affecting after quite some time
yes I think here in the middle of the
match is more or less the same
thank you
my climate chess.com again my question
is for Yan uh you've had a couple
promising positions as black and today
you declined this tacit draw for with
Queen E1 I'm wondering uh this idea of
trying to win as white and draw as black
is that just an Antiquated way of going
into a match is that not an applicable
strategy anymore
well I mean okay I'm just trying to
um
playing
basically every position but uh I would
say that uh I mean king of Faith was
just uh
very silly and practical decision but uh
that's probably before because I thought
you know it will be a draw anyway like
it doesn't matter if I play Queen E7 or
King f8 so it was all surely an
inaccuracy and uh you know a few next
moves also were
uh really I'm called four uh but in
general uh I think yeah it's
basically in every position even if it's
Jewish you can try to bring uh you know
bring in some tension and
see what happens
um Magnus you said by this point in the
match probably both of you are a little
tired
apart from this three games two games
three games thing there is also the late
start of the game at 4 30 in the
afternoon
if the match would could start back all
over again
would you actually try to set it back to
two games followed by rest here and an
early start to the match
no I think it's it's fine as I said
earlier
um it's good to good to Shake it up make
it more difficult for
for the players and makes makes much
more more exciting uh
and um yeah the obviously the the lights
start of of the games mean that
there could be some
some outliers where where your schedule
gets kind of messed up but in general
I'm
um I play better in in the evening so
I'm fine with it
I'm Rakesh from chess.com India question
to both players uh there are there have
been only two instances of challenges
coming back from a two-game deficit UA
in 1935 and Fisher 1972 but of course
those were Timeless matches but here we
have a 14-game limit so how hard or easy
it's going to be for the challenge to
make a comeback here
all right let's
I I would you know it's um
hard to hard to say
um but um
I mean I'm in a pretty pretty good spot
now uh but uh it doesn't doesn't make
any sense to me to
try and you know
compare it with um with other historical
historical matches it's better to be
leading than not to be leading that's
for sure
yeah oh well uh once again I would
repeat that uh it would be much better
to have an equal score uh but as it
seems to me you know cheers wise uh at
least until today's game yeah didn't
experience any any serious issues uh so
that's why I'm quite optimistic but uh
yeah of course it's uh somehow a harder
task uh than I expected
came from an arcade question two minus
um how much have you been working with
your schedule regarding relaxing and
sleeping since the long game on Friday
yeah it's it's been really uh it's been
it's been tough
um and uh I am I think
I really need this this free day to
recharge a bit and um get back in uh win
in a proper uh Rhythm what are you gonna
do tomorrow I don't know I'm just
um happy to to have a rest day and um
I have some yeah have some time off
thank you
my question is to
which was later published in a book so
do you dream about Chess any Novelties
or anything
uh yeah I dream about just from time to
time
um don't remember if it's happened
during the match so far I don't know
I believe I have one more question
um Hans team of the trustable you know
yesterday Magnus I asked you about the
general opening strategy do you think um
your two-point lead will trigger um the
DraStic change in opening approach
uh yeah I feel like that's kind of up to
kind of up to him
um
as I said yesterday as well uh at some
point
you kind of have to have to mix it up
um whether whether that point has has
come I'm I'm not I'm not sure
um but um it's more up to him than to me
so would you say this Kuni one decision
would you say that there were some
psychological
um influence of this based on your
winning game six
slide but um
most of all I was
most of I was just tired and um
I was you know I'm pretty happy to to
swap down to a position that I I
couldn't lose uh
and um
I mean I was it was slightly slightly
hoping that he would not follow up H5
with um with the queen trade but um I
didn't didn't expect the game to be very
long at that point and as you said it's
it's easier to make these kind of
decisions with uh with the lead
with uh
with an equal score I probably would
have felt obliged to do something
different
um even even if it didn't suit my mood
based on that answer would you say that
from psychological perspective you've
been making decisions based on that or
you know in general do you think that's
the thing you've been taking to into
account in this match
I would say
um a little bit but um
not not too much no thank you
we don't have a question for Twitter
today so I'll ask this this last one
then Jan before this match you must have
prepared psychologically in Game Theory
what happens if you're down a couple of
games not that you wanted it but it
could certainly happen you know any
thoughts as you'd like to share as your
mindset and mere preparation to now
handling the situation obviously that
wasn't planned
Magnus I'd ask you would you relax now
uh
but I guess another question then would
be do you try to shut things down and
force him to come after you
we will see one thing
um but um
I mean um
the match clock is in in my favor that's
for um that's for sure
all right well that concludes the press
conference for today tomorrow there will
be no game will be a rest day the next
day will begin at 16 30 on Tuesday thank
you so much everyone and have a great
night
it's Expo 2020 and the world is here as
well if every body in the world
love everybody in the world
what a glorious world
this could be it's the culture it's the
music the artwork if it's the people
[Music]
this good
I was just looking for myself and then
Expo came and it makes me emotional
Liz come on and join us a new
right here at Expo
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's a couple of moves I'd like to
ask you about today what was your
thinking behind the move B5
oh just a blunter so but I mean uh maybe
after each 4c4 it's slightly better
white but I mean instead of H4 I could
just um I don't know rotate with my
green light green F6 queen queen D6 and
then intro V6 so this was obviously an
equal position and
also I think uh in the opening of the
Queenie one check winning seven was the
fastest way to adjust the draw but um
yeah somehow was a strange game yeah and
people were wondering about the move H5
and of course King f8 instead of Queen
E7 would you say you were trying to win
a little bit too much today
not really so H5 is I think quite a
smart move which
in similar positions uh is suggested by
some of the engines I believe but yeah I
mean obviously at some point in time I
started doing some weird things but yeah
I was very unnecessary game and finally
Bobby Fischer came back from a two-game
deficit of course he had a lot more
games remaining in the tank what's it
going to take for you to make a comeback
well first of all uh play uh normally
like not like today but I think in
general uh nothing uh is decided yet so
just get to find my play and
see what goes thanks as always for your
time thank you
thank you
John says that it's not over yet
right obviously his play today was uh
was left left something to be desired
and for those who followed the entire
post-game press conference here thanks
for sticking with us he even apologized
for his play Robert what do you what do
you make of
the things Jan said of that particular
statement and obviously we're seeing a
disheartened John but your thoughts on
what we're what we just witnessed I
thought he was a gracious sport the fact
that he answered all the questions he
did is amazing he just lost his second
game in a World Chess Championship and
he very likely doesn't believe that he
can come back so for all the criticism
that I and everyone else is pointing his
way it is absolutely unbelievable that
he gave such thorough answers to all
these questions he did apologize I I
feel sorry for him in that moment I mean
it's just you shouldn't have to
apologize you had a bad game and yes all
the focus is on you but you know it's
amazing really that he said as much as
he did yeah certainly and Magnus
obviously also asked a number of
questions he was asked which move was
most surprising and he said well you
know you don't really expect your
opponent to make a blunder like that at
this level uh your thoughts on on that
comment there and how Magnus is
we were a bit surprised that because we
didn't think B5 was a blunder during the
game we thought there was some sort of
plan maybe to sacrifice a pawn and get
into an end game our thoughts are not
it's a blunder because Queen A3 and
queen takes A7 is the only two move
combination you think of after B5 in
fact it's it's White's threat uh if
black doesn't play as any other move
like
if black plays opacity move G6 or G6
hangs Rook but any passive move Queen to
A3 comes and uh and picks up a pawn so
we couldn't really understand this as a
blunder uh
I think that this is the most painful
thing probably that Beyond is
experiencing is his chess career
um I do hope that he's able to pull
himself together and pose problems to
Magnus he did say the task is the same
he still has to rack up some wins and he
also mentioned that he had his chances
early on in the match which is correct
and that if he gets more of those
chances and makes the most of them
he can uh try to get back into this
match
that being said realistically his chance
of winning the match now down two games
with six to go where Magnus is looking
very confident and playing as keeping
his cool and Magnus is uh and Jan is
definitely not keeping his cool up to
this point in the last three games we
can definitely see that he is he is on
tilt uh his chances are low but
hopefully the rest day will allow him to
gather himself yeah on his chances
Magnus Carlson who has typically dodged
any questions about Legacy or anything
that would allow him to kind of speak
with confidence about his position he
actually said quite clearly that his
chances of winning the match are are
very good at this point and obviously he
knows that uh as everyone saw Maurice
Ashley reminded everyone that tomorrow
is a rest day so all of you know that
that means it's really SCC day speed
Chess Championship stuff starts bright
and early for those of you on the west
coast we have dingley Ren versus Levon
aronian we'll talk to Lev about his
thoughts going into the match tomorrow
as well as all of his thoughts about
game eight here in about 10 minutes so
don't go anywhere Levon and Ronin will
be with us right after that matchup of
course we will have Hikaru Nakamura and
Anish Geary throwing down uh big big
time matchup not the last matchup of the
quarterfinals because we also have a
Fabiano caruana versus Wesley so
Endeavor to take place later this week
but Hikaru Nakamura and Niche Geary will
certainly have the chess fans tuning in
all right everybody as we said on the
other side of this break we are joined
by Lavon aronian he is our first of many
guests can't wait to hear what Young
Lubbock Hammer thinks of course from
Norway and so much more is still ahead
for you today on chess.com's feed a
World Chess Championship post game show
presented by coinbase
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the post game show continues we will
have one interesting guest after another
and back-to-back fashion we are now
joined once again by Grand Master Lavon
aronian Lev I uh I predicted against
against my will in terms of wanting a
close match I predicted a Magnus win
today but I didn't necessarily predict
it in that fashion I'm just gonna hand
the floor over to you and let you talk
about what you feel were the most
interesting takeaways from I think kind
of a surprising I guess one-sided game
eight
Magnus Carlson game where he was just
trying to play safe uh and uh to put
little pressure if you can and then
suddenly I think uh yeah started playing
in a very strange way well so this
Knight d2 move is the
I think is well known
you you you can play first five but
um what I have analyzed was 92 Bishop to
27 check which is I think the most
precise way to equalize because we
should be frequent before
and then uh both C3 and 22 with two drop
call us yeah C3 you just take the phone
and then the queen is never getting
[ __ ]
so uh in the game
we saw young Play Bishop B6 uh after a
short thought Castle
and here he started thinking for a long
time so once again I didn't really
understand what was all about of course
we knew the book 92 he plays this line
with white himself he plays Castle 963
uh
but uh to play Bishop D6 quickly and
then realize oh wait now Castle is not
that good because it's Queen H5 is very
strange it only talks about the strange
mental situation that the partnership
finds himself in
uh so he went to H5
which I thought is probably the best
move and here Magnus kind of played the
strange move when he won
because if you look at the position you
think okay white can play a rookie one
check uh King get fate
and then do something like I don't know
C3 or even A3 let's see three looks
logical
and then uh if I mean white is nowhere
in danger if you play Queen H4 I go G3
and the ministry I can even play Bishop
F1 and put the pawn on H4 so I'm still
slightly better
but 21 is basically is inviting wife to
play 27 which is you can clearly see
that like sick was easily after 27. so
what I felt the Magnus thought to
himself okay I finally played uh I I
came to make a drop with my 92. my
parent played something uh rare which I
didn't expect all right let me just uh
play this game in control
and Jan at this moment I thought he told
himself
I should avoid the throw this is kind of
a psychological
so I should avoid the throw
and you try to avoid it without actually
real
you're going into a worse position
so this is what the
what happened in the game so um
for one second
um John mentioned that Queen E7 would
likely lead to a draw but how in his
thought process could he think that king
of fate
even if let's say he doesn't realize
it's worse how can he think that he has
any chances to play for anything more
than a draw after Bishop to B4 and
Bishop B4 is the only move White
is uh showing showing his intention with
Queen he wants to play Bishop B4
uh you know I'm a master of screw us I
know how the mind of somebody is ready
to screw things up at work
and this is how I think it goes you kind
of tell yourself a organism is boring
but I want to show that I'm fighting and
therefore I'm not going to go any seven
I'm going through
then you get a worse position and then
you're satellite selling to yourself
continuously why wouldn't I guilty when
if uh 27
and this is the way that you're slowly
digging your grade and this is what
happened in the game so Bishop
27
Bishop the second D6 I mean White's play
is so natural and uh I I do think
position is silly cool but black has to
play precisely
so rookie H rookie one
here I actually didn't understand what's
happening at all I thought when I was in
the game I thought you won rookie one G6
and it looks kind of natural
and then uh okay Queen G5
King G7
[Music]
to be able to make a draw here I see a
way that you can benefit I was thinking
that maybe white can try to stop rookie
8 long term by playing instead of Queen
to G5
Rook maybe to E5
King G7 and maybe Queen g72
airplane so yeah maybe it still poses
black so some problems but of course it
doesn't look like very
very much
yeah I can always play C6
yeah slowly come out of this thing but
this looks Supernatural I mean in
just the way
way that everybody would play
and in the game uh young played this
Rook H6 idea which I felt was highly
Furious
I didn't really understand it
because Rook I don't think you have the
time to put the Rook 36 right and if
you're going to play F6 then The Rook on
H6 makes zero sense and here I felt that
Magnus played excellently I felt the
next move she played were
very very good
and I will explain why as as a master of
screw-ups I'll explain you why
Fabiano absolutely sorry
yeah yeah made these mistakes yeah I
wouldn't make such mistakes because
Fabiana is is a brilliant
guy when it comes to defending slightly
worse position
so here H3 a brilliant move
oh why is it so brilliant
what black wants to do he wants to play
G5 or H4 somehow to come up but now
after G5 Queen G3 is the problem
because if Queen G3 Queen F4 I take and
play H4
is this a draw I don't know but it looks
very important
so if you're not gonna do the five
persons
you you want to play H4 in order to you
know then safely play G5 and H4 is not
by C4 which is very unpleasant
now you probably have to react to take C
makes sense Bishop C4
and what do you do here because if you
sit in calculate King G8 Queen E7
um and find some draw there you know
it's uh
it's tough I during the game but I
wasn't so sure how does black managed to
make it grow here
because we we didn't see any good move
besides King G8 because there's no way
to stop either Queen a if Queen D6 Queen
to B3 we were worried so so we were
looking at King to G8 and here Rook to
D6 Rook takes F7
and King to H7 and we thought maybe
black is
holding on here rookette Ford maybe Rook
F4 is probably
easing Black's task because of G5 but
it's not easy to find
a path to a clear Advantage for white
yeah because wife didn't even try D5 E5
maybe default is a good idea
King to H6 and uh maybe
yeah
this is but after black plays G6 it's
still
like there's no real mating nut after G6
yeah yeah so yeah yeah but it just
visually you kind of start the way I
think uh young blundered 283 check was
that he started looking into this and he
was like okay this is not good for me
then he started thinking about some
other moves like I don't know peace A6
or
and yeah that's he came up to to play
the boundary
but definitely it was not something that
oh his position was fine and he just
spotted no uh he took the wrong plan he
put the Rook on H6 and then Magnus
played this excellent H3 C4 ID yeah we
were quite impressed with H3 uh when it
was played
because it also dealt with the idea if
black plays Queen to D6 instead of H4
yeah we showed a critical line Leb that
went back with Queen G5 and the whole
point being that after Queen G5 if Queen
F6 again now Queen G3 works because on
Queen D6 you finally have rookie five
due to the idea that you can actually
grab the H Pawn in this line because the
Pawn's not on H2
in these variations
ah yes so
this was another another brilliant Point
behind the subtly powerful move H3
yeah well you know
and after the blunder yeah I think the
game was let's come back to that level
first of all this was this was awesome
it's amazing to go over with another
Super Grand Master because we sit next
to one and just hearing you guys talk
about it shines lights on even even more
ideas than we even talked about in the
real game and you know
I have to ask you because I don't I
would need to get another opinion on
this one of the things we're talking
about when the game is running in real
time is is that Yawn is not at the board
very much now I understand right all
players have different styles different
ways that they find their their Rhythm
if you will and a lot of players of
course are able to focus and visualize
not at the board of course we know that
but when he returns to the board he's
playing so quickly and because some of
these moves are are obviously unbiasedly
deserving of criticism like B5 what what
are your what are your thoughts on that
it just it it feels like we're watching
him sort of beat himself for lack of a
better way to put it right and you just
want to tell him hey slow down a little
bit and at the same time obviously this
guy has a lot of coaches around him he
clearly probably has people giving him
this advice but what are your thoughts
on on the storyline of Jan just having a
couple careless moments frankly that you
could Define his entire world
championship uh you know campaign by
whether it was Queen E4 and game six and
then here B5 and if you would please
give me your thoughts you think we're
nuts on that and you don't want to mess
with a player like that or or do you
would you also tell him he needs to slow
down
I think when the things are not going
your way and then you start the like the
feeling the pressure then you go back to
your waist then you go back and you I
mean definitely uh young prior to the
match worked very hard to changing his
style changing changed his attitude and
trying to get rid of this very very few
and Tiny inaccuracies in this style and
character
but
once things start going wrong for you
you kind of tell yourself oh screw screw
this I'm just going to play the way I
can I won tournaments with this style
and things are going to uh just I'm
gonna relax
but uh yeah you're you're letting off
your guards and then you're doing the
same mistakes that you normally do which
this is what happens with me a lot and I
think
since
Jan is also very emotional of giant
his
[Music]
yeah he's he's doing this mistake of uh
not really getting himself together and
just continuing uh what he was planning
for the match
and just letting loose
level one chess question I was curious
about because although B5 is the
is the first huge mistake we were also
wondering about this moment after Queen
takes A7
Bishop takes literally we struggled to
find a clear path to a win for white
although white is certainly better
um we were wondering if
if White had something very clear here
or maybe this was a still a defensive
chance for black
well definitely I felt it was a
defensive chance and I felt Magnus would
probably play Queen F7 and then both
this uh and the game which
yeah rookie eight takes which does look
you know that white should be winning
here maybe with Bishop G8 and the rookie
five you know this this type of thing
but definitely it was his chance
and
by keeping the Bishops
he yeah basically kind of result
yeah and and again it was another move
that maybe already frustrated John again
played quickly kind of came back to the
board and didn't spend very much time at
all before playing Queen to d8 so
um
well this has again been awesome and uh
makes makes a lot of sense to uh to
break down kind of a player who can be
shrieky and and yonda palmushi and maybe
now now that the streak is not going his
way he really needs to find whatever he
can on this rest day and so let me ask
you I mean I know the match is not over
until it's over but what are your
thoughts on the the status of the match
at this point
well of course it's extremely difficult
for a young
from the perspective of the momentum and
the way he's been playing so far
um
I think he needs to come back to
fighting
um somehow choosing this opening and
this attitude of just uh you know not
playing uh sharp chess
I I don't think it quite worked for them
and maybe he should come back to his
neither and maybe this uh now on the
inside of course it's easy to say but
maybe his decision to
change his approach to chess by playing
very solidly with black maybe this was
not a very good idea so if I were him I
would just try to uh take this recipe
and try to play for a win
and everything I think he should come
back tonight or he should come back to
any kind of society get the you know get
some emotions there because this uh kind
of play without much emotions and just
trying to make a joke I don't think it's
working yeah so love actually
um you've played Magnus
so many times for for already decades
now
um and I I once heard someone say this
that the best uh way to approach uh
playing Magnus is actually to go for the
sharpest possible lines and some
openings were mentioned like the king's
Indian
um the night or the grunfeld uh do you
feel like in general it's a stylistic
mistake to be playing
um openings where Magnus has options
like this to to go for
slightly better solid approaches rather
than to play openings where he really
has to take him on and uh
in a head-on fight
yeah well uh I thought that Madness is
is not well prepared for this match
but probably it's I was underestimating
it because
he probably thought that this is the way
to play against yeah just slowly try to
neutralize it black get slightly worse
positions and with white let's just play
save so
look what he did against you and as much
he was going for the sharpest points
because he thought that you are a very
good positional chess player at the
excellent preparation so he was trying
to avoid your Perfection but here we see
a very different story and the as you
said that probably this is uh you know
the way he's approaching this match
and the way Jan has been approaching
this match is
certainly not working well for for yeah
and uh
yeah I mean I have tried playing night
of against Night Nurse and I have tried
playing sharp openings
uh and it does
put him in an uncomfortable position
sometimes
so I think that's the way to try and go
just to get the
treat him and with any hope
so I think that's what they should do at
this moment
and sorry no you go man and what do you
think about the next game uh Jan has a
rest day and he has the white pieces do
you think he should continue trying the
anti-martial something there or do you
think he should go for something
entirely different
I would go for the answer Marshall I
would just work on this uh you know have
a lot of pieces on the board and just uh
yeah kind of try to get the some
attacking chances
because out of the opening he was
getting very promising positions with
white
but I think
he has been way too solid way to uh
conserve it with his play
well good stuff I could just listen to
YouTube 2800 guys talk to us all day can
I just say that I'm a big fan here big
big fan of on big fan Bobby
um anyway guys all right we talked a lot
about the uh the match that you know is
kind of the second most important match
going on right now the most important
one dingley Ren versus Levon aronian
have you heard about that match that's
happening tomorrow Lev and your thoughts
on the Von aronians chances against
England
foreign
I
can confidently tell you it is going to
be well prepared
and
okay that's great
he's very excited to play some Blitz
and uh yeah hopefully we'll uh yeah
we'll make the crowds uh happy with some
of the you know more exciting games
because the world championship match was
very is very exciting but it's kind of
one-sided at the moment hopefully the
match tomorrow will be
very sharp well
um I'm sure you won't disappoint you you
never do and and these interviews are
are a real highlight of of our entire
broadcast for the last week left
seriously so thank you so much for
taking the time to join us and giving us
your thoughts and best of luck tomorrow
man versus dingley Wren and we'll talk
to you later
thank you very much
see you guys around
yet again awesome stuff there I
seriously I could just listen to you
interview your your buddy all day and
you guys talk match strategy and and
break down you know his thoughts on on
team Yanda Palmer she's approach and
feels like we're kind of coming around
to that that even if the Marshall is the
right thing to do to hammer away at a
slight Edge but just you know maybe
don't play Knight takes up six in those
lines
everyone's talking about maybe this this
idea that they had on Switching him away
from his night orphan hindsight was just
was not yawn
yeah it looked like a good approach the
first time he played the petrol we were
all singing his Praises yeah uh he made
an easy draw he looked to be excellently
prepared I don't think that we can
really blame the petrol yeah today
because he actually got a completely
fine position from the opening he was
pretty much one move away from uh from
going to a very large position uh I
think that we can say his psychological
state is not ideal now yeah but it's
it's a very difficult situation how will
he approach the next game that's why I
asked Levon that and I think that he's
right that it's probably best to still
stick to the anti-martial because at
least you have information there right
you have some Target you can't afford to
take more time to see what Magnus wants
to do for example against D4 yeah or
against C4
um you have you have some sort of Target
there Magnus has shown his intentions to
play keep playing his Rook B8 move
it's it's tough uh it's a really tough
situation I I would probably keep going
for the same yeah approach with white
trying to find some ideas but of course
he needs to be super aggressive he needs
to go pretty much all out for the win
with white in the next game I think it
makes sense too especially from the
Practical point you just made which is
if your resources
for Preparation are strapped at this
point anyway you might as well stick
with the Marshall especially if you're
considering opening up the Sicilian tool
bag right because you don't even know
what Magnus is going to do yet we keep
talking about the night orb like it's a
foregone conclusion there are many
anti-sicilians that that Magnus has been
known to play and I've been sitting here
waiting on that storyline to come up
which hasn't yet because I'm curious how
Magnus would choose to approach one C5
if it was on the board well that's the
other thing we don't know if mine is
exactly E4 as well yep uh Magnus is very
flexible with white so that's why it's
tough you know you have your match
strategy but you get hit once twice
suddenly you're thinking you have to
play for win black but then you have to
prepare an opening against White against
E4 but also against D4 it's really tough
yeah I I think that he should try to win
his next game it's super important for
him to win that next game and then he
can assess the situation right then
maybe he can try to be a bit more solid
with black because a one-point deficit
he'll still have some whites left he'll
have some chances he doesn't need to
burn his Bridges two point deficit if he
doesn't win the game
after the day after tomorrow I don't
know I would say his chances are looking
very slim then so that's a really
crucial game for him each player has
three whites and three blacks left at
their disposal should this match Go the
Distance but as Fabiano said it feels
like literally a must win when we return
from the rest day in game nine begins of
course that will be on Tuesday let's
remind everybody real quick if we can
the schedule uh obviously we still have
much more to go here on our post game
show but as we said tomorrow is a rest
day game nine resumes on Tuesday and
then game 10 following that before
another rest day on December 9th so all
right at this point we're going to let
Fabi take a break and be rejoined by
Robert Hess as well as young Ludwig
Hammer Can't wait to hear how Norway is
feeling right now I'm going to bet that
hammer is in a pretty chipper mood on
the other side of this break and of
course it was awesome to hear Levon and
his thoughts about a match with dingley
run tomorrow so plenty more to go here
on chess.com's post game show for game
eight of the 2021 feet a World Chess
Championship
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations play
a game start review and try it today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS at coinbase are sponsoring
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
world championship and boy are we
thankful whether you're an experienced
Trader been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guess who's back back again hammers back
tell a friend only our most special
special of guests is brought to you by
grip six because we would never have any
guests not as special as Hammer not
brought to you by grip six I don't know
how many double negatives I had in there
we'll impact that later use the promo
code Chess at go.chess.com
chess there's a lot of URLs you can get
to it I'm wearing their fancy schmancy
belt today uh enjoying it so go ahead
and get yourself a belt of wallet some
socks whatever you're into check it out
at grip six Hammer I know you're going
to be excited about where the match
currently stands as a Magnus Carlson
uh former second obviously a fan a good
friend
um but just try not to blow up my
eardrum will you buddy take it away
excited me it's just another day at the
office uh I call some grind to take down
the victory I've never been a less
surprised in my life uh this is what he
does and uh actually to be fair today
was just it was weird no today was just
napomniachi self
yeah doing hurting himself uh basically
and uh we were very disappointed in the
Norwegian broadcast when Magnus played
Queen E1
uh thinking for over 40 minutes and then
he just goes into this situation where
he's gonna trade the queens and it's
gonna be an early draw and we're like oh
that's
we thought this was going to be exciting
but I I guess not
avoids the queen trade and completely
unnecessarily enters a worse position
something was off today and it was on
nepomanyachi's end and
um yeah he um I think it was uh best set
during the press conference by Magnus
that he thought this would not have been
a win for him if not for game uh six uh
where Magnus made that uh eight hour uh
breakthrough uh because nepalnyachi
today was nothing like the nepalnyachi
we've been seeing the other games he
made some very very strange inaccuracies
and then he made one gigantic blunder
and
um Jan was saying at the press
conference right that he was embarrassed
and that this was not a Grand Master
Level game and I agree with him I I
think any Grandmaster would be
disappointed if they played the way
neponiachi did today and that is that is
saying something it was just it was a
bad well there must be Jubilation in
Norway right now because you've seen
Magnus Carlsen take a two-game lead but
it almost at least from your tone I get
the sense that you're almost not
thrilled about the way Magnus won I mean
you'll take the victory obviously but am
I reading that right
I I'm my sentiments may not necessarily
always be shared by the Norwegian public
but I will say I was a bit disappointed
today because I I thought Nepal nechi
had played a really good match so far he
got unfortunate uh to lose on on game
six but it seemed like he had made some
adjustments like Lebon just mentioned
when he was on uh nepalnyachi has
clearly been working on his style to
make the uh adjustments needed to play
at the very uh with the very highest
stakes and
um after the loss in game six it seems
like he kind of went back to his old
self which is one of unnecessary
inaccuracies and inexplicable uh
blunders at some points and uh one of
those blunders
showed up today and um
yeah
I mean I I think Magnus
Magnus is the better player I I thought
before the match started that Magnus was
gonna win it uh but
um
I don't know I guess I'm
I guess I'm disappointed that it's
decided just through uh
a blunder that's just if I read you
write it almost to me sounds like you'll
be rooting for yonda Palm machine in
game nine
well you know I'm paid per day doing
commentary Danny so having 14 days of a
world championship would be in my best
interest uh so uh maybe maybe some of my
analysis now is just incredibly
egotistical uh to maximize my payday
you're a smart man thank you for just
for just getting right to the point here
I should have done a different kind of
contract with Fabiano paid him an amount
no matter how long the match goes so
well I'm going to rethink that for the
future we haven't been paying Hess so it
doesn't matter I do have a question for
you uh and we know that Magnus a
two-game lead it's not a foregone
conclusion that he wins the match
especially if Jan is able to strike back
the next one but Matt just asked this
question about his legacy and while the
match is not over right there's still
games to be played what do you think
this means to Magnus because he is
finally winning games in classical chess
so he can ignore all the previous
critics who said you can't do this
anymore he's proving that he can
did someone say Magnus can't win chess
championships more classical chess he it
took tie break for the last two matches
in order for him to retain and defend
his title
I
I
he
he's very close to winning games against
kayaking I I everyone agrees that Magnus
in the match against kayaking was not
his best self uh but the match against
Fabiano was I mean the fact that there
was no decisive game there was shocking
I think in that match both players
really just showed their very best chess
and the fact that it was all draws is
just a freak accident
um Magnus is the best chess player in
the world
um he's proving it every single month in
all the normal tournaments uh the I I
agree with those who say that the world
championship is a extra difficult uh
event for Magnus in that there's just
you know so much expectations and you
can't go into the world championship and
be like Oh even if you finish second in
this tournament everyone knows you're
the best in the world because like when
you have a bad tournament you finish
second when everyone else has a bad
tournament they finished you know
seventh uh but the world championship is
special in that if you do have an off
tournament then that's something
everyone is gonna remember not for a
couple of months but for literally
hundreds of years
um so I think Magnus feels that pressure
in a different way during a world
championship and and so
he
sometimes struggles a little bit to show
his very very best on those occasions
but
no overall Magnus proves over and over
that he's the best and and
yeah I I think this this succession of
draws in the world championship has been
a bit of a fluke
but well I'm talking with Fabiano I
think he would agree obviously we know
that they were both going after each
other and that match turned out way or
where it was but there were certainly
many games that could have been decisive
either way now the the storyline is
behind us and even if it took a historic
uh historic moment in game six in order
to finally get another decisive game
Hammer what are you going to be doing on
the rest day give us some historic news
how you going to be spending that time
uh I'm gonna restore on the rest day uh
weirdly
uh because uh I'm I'm starting to feel
it and I can only imagine then how how
the players are feeling uh as well uh
it's uh the world championship match
it's a big occasion but it also lasts
for a very very long time so I'm gonna
take a day off of Chess and get my head
ready for for the last uh
I thought you were going to say you can
only imagine how we're feeling given
that we have to wake up at the crack of
2 A.M Pacific Time 3 A.M our time and
and really put on a show that requires
us to sit on a comfortable couch for
hours on end so thanks for showing some
compassion for us
um
[Laughter]
hold your tongue I struggle with that
because I'm always inclined to roast him
but I respect that I see what you did
there all right buddy
um hammer you're the man you know it we
know it we love you buddy I'll just
leave it at that enjoy enjoy your rest
day it is well deserved thanks for
continuing to do awesome stuff every
time every time you're on camera uh
there's there's so many special guests
we have but only the Specialists are
brought To Us by grip six and that was
young Ludwig hammer
and uh and Mr Hammer is out of here and
again let me remind you that you can go
to grip6.com chess and use the promo
code chess to get 25 off your next order
all right well we saw a a jubilant
Hammer there but also a hammer that I
you know I believe it I think we're all
kind of feeling the same way regardless
of whether you were rooting for Magnus
or yawn coming into the match everyone
wants it to be close right and you just
you want to see more game sixes maybe we
don't want to be here for you know
almost eight hours but you want to see
games like that right and it's just hard
when you know that someone like Jan is
capable of just so much better than than
he had today yeah but sometimes you do
earn your opponent's blunders yeah and
Magnus won that historic game and he
neutralized easily with black and then
today he play Queen E1 check likely just
to Peter the position out yeah he didn't
know the opening very well and then he
kept the pressure up so well I agree
that it was uncharacteristic of a world
championship stage to see that kind of
blunder in that moment I do think that
Magnus he puts that pressure on
everybody yeah and so sometimes it's
only a matter of time
all that being said yeah that's not the
way you want to win I don't think Magnus
will take the win he'll celebrate it but
you'd rather outplay your opponent than
them just implode yeah it's a great
point I'm glad you said that because
that reminds me of one of the comments
LeBron did make he kind of said
obviously B5 is the blunder but he was
giving full credit to the H3 Brilliance
the C4 keeping the position unbalanced
right keeping your opponent sort of you
know
on the on their guard and ultimately you
put your opponents in positions where
they make blunders whether they do or
not Magnus has been putting his
opponents in positions to make blunders
more than anybody for the last decade
plus and it's why he is the best chess
player on the planet all right everyone
we are not done yet we've got so much
more ahead at the break we are going to
remind you of what our trivia question
was and then of course have the answer
before we return I know the answer can I
say it now because everyone else has
already done the quote tweet I'll do it
at the end well isn't Corbett going to
give an answer oh yeah I gave the answer
I don't always know the answer so I get
excited when I'm like oh I know the
answer to that anyway
um here here comes the question and the
answer again at the break and when we
return we will be joined he has
confirmed the man the myth the legend Mr
Ludwig aggren who as uh he left twitch
he was on YouTube he got banned for a
copyright strike he's back now he's got
a lot going on in his world and we're
gonna we're gonna break down uh break
down what's going on with him in the
world of streaming let him talk about
the World Chess Championship he does
love chess and and has has been
following it and he also has his man
Robert Hess here to sound off on which
should be a lot of fun to see these two
uh discuss things so don't go anywhere
it's more of chess.com's coverage of the
feed a World Chess Championship when we
return
[Music]
hello again from Expo 2020 in Dubai at
the World Chess Championship my name is
Jonathan corblock bringing to you
another trivia question about the World
Chess championships this one about
prodigies prodigies exist in many fields
not only chess but art mathematics and
music for instance Mark time enough
World chess champion candidate was also
a classical pianist which two World
Chess Champions were also gifted
mathematicians
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations play
a game start review and try it today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
in case you didn't see our partners at
coinbase are sponsoring chess.com's
coverage of the 2021 v-day world
championship and boy are we thankful
whether you're an experienced Trader
been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
we are back here as chess.com's post
game show for game eight and the feeder
World Chess Championship rolls on we are
finally joined by the man the myth the
legend as I said it's been became a bit
of a meme we kept saying that you'd be
with us lud and yet here you are in the
flesh and uh well not quite In the Flesh
how you doing man
doing good I don't know are you um got
my name wrong I feel like I've been with
chess.com for a while at Ludwig augrin
that you know you must have been a troll
because honestly I have no idea how that
would be a possible thing you're pretty
well known in this chess streaming
community in the in the streaming
Community
um speaking of which
how's it going how's the big change
going you got banned this week how that
how'd that feel yeah
it was an exciting first week you know I
left the aisles of twitch.television and
YouTube gaming and you know first first
week was smooth until I got banned but
the band it turns out actually not that
big of a deal
and you know I I think things will go
well from here on out were there any
nerves you know you of course have
experience on YouTube but still you've
put twitch behind you so we're nervous
with your initial streams
yeah a little
give you an analogy has I'm like yawn
all right nepo I was like no shot this
guy does it all right this guy's gonna
flop it's a matter of time doesn't
matter if he busts out five draws
eventually the L is Gonna Come to Magnus
and that's what it felt like and Magnus
was this looming body of of like twitch
is the only place you can succeed in in
the end of this analogy almost assuredly
yeah
I don't know the analogy after that but
let's how closely have you been
following it we know that uh or at least
we we think you and Magnus have have
spent some time together at least at
least gone back and forth where are you
are you rooting for Magnus in this match
and have you have you followed it at all
I have to through for Magnus I got a
roof for Magnus he's my guy uh but I
wake up every morning to you too
um and I just think to myself damn I
wish you guys would let Fabiano talk
more like Danny
[Laughter]
this is all the things I would get fired
for saying
um well okay so we need to let Fabiano
talk more I can I can take uh the L on
that one but what about Hess how's his
performance been you've tuned in I mean
sometimes we've had so many years
together I need other people's opinions
on how he's performing your thoughts on
the only world has champion and how the
how the Hess Championship has gone
dude that has Championship does not miss
I watch Hess in in the back of my brain
I slightly think like
could this [ __ ] beat Magnus
straight up
he's busting out lines that nepo don't
think of and I'm like where is this
coming from I was the how's he thinking
of these things I I actually don't
disagree has had a moment today where he
quickly described some plan that I was
like wow you know it has I know I'm
sitting to Fabi but you're pretty good
too let's keep talking good about Hess
because we both know how uncomfortable
it makes him what else do you love about
Robert what else do you love about him
I dude you know my favorite part about
him is he is the
worst streamer
which in turn makes him a great human
I I don't disagree with that at all
either how's he how's he been obviously
you know your guys's relationship has
been almost as public as maybe yours and
cuties you know you guys have a pretty
public pretty public uh Affair going on
with chess you've been working together
you won twitch Rivals together you know
how has it been since Robert Hess came
into your life and you could no longer
spell chess without Hess
yeah
it's been good it's kind of like Dave
and Kim K I'm Kim K and
it's like a weird couple at first you're
like why are these two hanging out GM of
Chess and a guy who's like making
somewhat funny jokes or perhaps cringe
depending on who you are
well I think it works out it's like a
match made in heaven I still hold on to
that W
um can't say my chest skills have
improved at all but that's also kind of
my secret to staying in POG Champs is
not improving at all that way I'm at the
perfect skill level to be invited
everything something I love to hear you
know remember the first time we spoke
about coaching I was like you know I'm
not going to coach you for POG Champs
and try to help you get better at chess
and you have improved so don't sell
yourself short here but when are we
gonna pass that pop Champs level
never never all right think about it if
I'm passing it and I get to like half
level or like you know Box Box level or
Northern line level where you're like 16
to 18 just like a little too good where
you'd wash everybody in POG Champs and
kind of you know ruin the event with
your skill then what do you have like
what's there to look forward to terrible
matches where people know 13 moves deep
into the London perfectly like I don't
deal with that I can just be slightly
bad no and then
they'll get invited to block Champs to
make close good games I feel like I'm
alive I don't know that I can argue
against that honestly and you know so
you won twitch Rivals
do you think you're going to get any
invites again to Twitch Rivals soon
[Laughter]
YouTube
let's promote him at our event obviously
there's a bit of a patrol but let me let
me ask I mean this is um
I I was happy to say not even sure it
means anything this is the first live
interview you've given you you had your
release video you talked and opened up
about the transition obviously your
experience of going back and forth
between YouTube and twitch won't ask you
to uh talk any more about that than you
don't want to but again just give us
your what you're willing to share for 30
60 seconds on why you're excited about
the future of YouTube and um anything
else you want to share about about this
this huge transition for you
got 150 million reasons why oh I love
that it's a lie
uh yeah I cited I'm excited because I
you know I'm kind of I'm there's like a
few people out there but I think I'm the
only one my very specific category like
most critical who's been on POG Champs
Miss gift who uh was on pocket for a day
before dropping and in a few others uh
that's all on YouTube now so I think
it'll just be kind of exciting to
explore the territory super excited
about the extension that dropped and uh
and how that's going it's just supposed
to make the chat experience better so
you know only exciting things coming and
you know I have not reached us yet
well you mentioned uh you mentioned some
people who are on YouTube now and and
obviously you know since you may not be
invited to the next chest twitch Rivals
event I was thinking maybe you and I
what if there was a YouTube POG champs
for only YouTube streamers what'd you
think about that
okay well you got Jimmy beast on who's
literally youtube.com In the Flesh you
know we can we can make it happen like
you can make it work for your old pal a
lot I'm thinking the same thing what I I
kind of like the idea hear me out you
know
Ludwig runs a chess event and we figure
it out like we get a little crate maybe
we do an in-person one over the board
get with it this is happening live for a
reason because I'm just as in on this as
you are so we just got to figure out you
know how we're flipping the bill for
that obviously chess.com and you're
you're you're you're flipping the uh
well you know whatever whatever the
things you're flipping to make that that
content exciting and uh dude we're gonna
do it seriously
so
yeah I would love to do more chess stuff
I feel like watching this event makes me
want to play chess and uh and I I like
uh a reason to play chess rather than
just watching the low number go up and
down drastically usually a good match
against an opponent I I'm like excited
to beat whether it's like a Charlie
who I lost to or in Albert who I lost
you were oh sure I lost to I'll look
forward to those matches let me get this
correct you want to do chess not just
for the ELO game
and you want to improve and you really
are into chess and want to do more chess
yet all those times I'm like hey Ludwig
lesson because I coach you not just to
win POG jams but to get better and then
you disappear so what I'm hearing is
that you want to learn chess what I'm
seeing is
not always that so
what is it man which way
I think everybody who's currently
watched
watching this chess broadcast can
totally understand
the sentiment I want to learn Jess
like do I actually want to do all the
work and then deal with like a game
because I don't really know what I'm
doing and then I'm embarrassed having to
promote to get two Rooks to do a double
Rook Checkmate instead of like a cooler
Checkmate or do I try some custom [ __ ]
in a game aim and then lose because I
did like how many people in chat right
now can I get an amen do you go on the
chest app do you play like a 3-2 game
which is probably too short of a Time
control do you immediately win or lose
and then jump into another game with
Zero review because all you want to do
is play chess you don't actually want to
can I get a name amen amen guilty can't
be alone here I'm just like I'm I'm like
fiending through the games like it's
nothing to me like it's just crackers
it's like it's like a bag of Doritos
music to a coach's ear chips music to
coaches and speaking of bags of Doritos
we won those bags of Doritos which
Rivals so you mentioned how you
mentioned sardose hey you know who beat
sardost you did you guys did you did I'm
not gonna lie as a guy who was
commentating on that match that you guys
took down swordosh sorry
now now you're in my head Lubbock as a
guy who took the corn base as a guy who
watched you take down sardosh I'm not
gonna lie Ludwig I didn't believe you
could do it what
sorry but you did and that's the magic
of Ludwig never practice so No One
Believes Me then maybe wait you did but
I believed in Ludwig so if you didn't
believe in him that means you didn't
believe in me no stop it stop it no I
I'm just kidding I knew you guys could
do it all right I don't want to say that
the sappy is getting a divorce yeah
um anyway well given Hess is uh
confronting you about the coaching it
kind of leads me to my last real big
question for you I mean who is your
favorite person in chess Magnus Carlson
or Robert Hess
I got a main [ __ ] I got a mistress but
and a damn main [ __ ]
all right that's that's all we wanted to
hear and uh
you're the man lud seriously uh
congratulations on the on the switch to
YouTube and best of luck on on the on
the switch as well
um thank you guys appreciate it okay can
I have one for you guys
is there a shot nepo wins this
hurt my back you threw up my back with
that question you threw on my back
because I know I know I'm gonna be
carrying the show for the rest the rest
of this match to try to convince people
that it's possible uh but no one's
watching the post show so I'll just say
I mean it's an uphill okay I'll put it
this way
if he wins next game if he doesn't I
will I will say it's over but if he wins
the next game so I'm gonna wait till
that game nine Robert all right game
nine
Tuesday we'll exactly find out you're
keeping the suspense I mean he's in big
trouble but he does get the rest day he
does get the white pieces and Ludwig he
just needs to change his style
completely because what he's been doing
has not been working it doesn't match
the success that we've seen from him in
the past so I think he needs to just
completely revamp his game and he only
has a couple days to do so otherwise
Magnus Carlsen and maybe even if he does
for Vamp his game Magnus Carlsen very
likely to retain his world championship
title and still fight to be your best
friend in chess yep
dispatch perhaps now we're talking there
you go oh look I forgot I had one more
favor to ask of you could you tell
everyone who was throwing you their
Prime on your channel to throw their
Prime to us right now live maybe to
cutie as well but do you know about the
Secret website
what's the z there's a Secret website
that you can go to and if you subscribed
to me it gives you a free subscription
to a Channel of your choice on uh on
Twitch okay
uh let me see if I can find it somebody
in chat might have this but all they do
and people have been farming my death
which is respectable just linking this
website to viewers and then accruing so
so many subs from it just let me see if
I can find yeah something I would never
do I respect Lubbock too much
anyway he's here uh might as well throw
his old Prime our way no
I can't I can't even find the link oh
the wait is that it oh yeah there it is
someone like the twitch.tv forward slash
Subs forward slash Lottery yeah you go
to this guys if you sub it to me at any
point if you're one of the 27 000 that
somehow got to me from Jess or left me
four chess either way you can go to this
type someone's name in and then hit
redeem and then you just get a sub I'm
not gonna lie I was I was honestly
expecting just a total hilarious troll
you know throw it in my throw it in my
face answer to that so that's actually
awesome anyone can do that but that's
hilar and also hilarious I got you
you haven't gotten a single prop okay
you got one sub thank you cow Moody but
I haven't gotten jack [ __ ] but you know
hey at least I informed the people
you've done your job you've done your
job all right two people two people
apparently sub that's hilarious okay
well thank you so much for the two of
you that did it uh love but seriously
man best of luck with all the new Subs
you'll be getting on YouTube and um
we'll catch up with you later man POG
Champs YouTube only POG Champs it's
coming next year we're doing it
see you buddy thanks guys
well that was awesome as usual and as
expected and I love his question about
whether Jan has a chance he cares about
this he's following it oh yeah for sure
he is and with all the trolling aside
Ludwig loves chess he really tries his
best and uh I think winning twitch
Rivals which we did together was just a
huge highlight so
um you did make me highly uncomfortable
talking about me with me present so
thank you both for that I should
accomplish but it's uh it's good to have
him on the show and he is following the
chess so I'm always happy about it no
and seriously not that we necessarily
need to sing lud's praises but you and I
talk about this offline a lot I mean
Ludwig to me defines all the positive
things that came out of POG Champs last
year I mean the guy is obviously an
incredible personality and an amazing
person but also it shows that this was a
a guy who's a variety streamer who got
into the game you know during during a
time when a lot of people of other games
were but he really loves Jess he
committed himself to it he competed in
all but one and you did see a a massive
progression regardless of what he says
right much thanks to your coaching and
also like his work he competed and it
was he's the guy that defines to me what
I feel is a new generation of chess
players all of his fans and and people
that came to the game because of him and
I have to say he's a great student so I
we riff we joke and a lot of banter but
he's a really good student he asks great
questions and well I regret admitting
this publicly because you know that's
gonna he's a good wind of it but he
really is and he dedicate dedicate
himself to learning especially as a huge
streamer it's difficult because there's
so many people who can see your mistakes
especially with the engine and yet he
kept powering through and the fact that
you know he was able to really lead us
to that twitch Rivals Victory and keep
getting better at chess and keep wanting
to play I mean that's there's nothing
better for me to hear it's nothing
better than I could ask for well said
and all right there are a few things
were said uh in one of our our special
videos set today debut at the end of the
show
I'm going to say that all of many of the
world's best chess players were there in
a in a discussion that um is best left
in in the video and the leak footage
that we're about to bring you so you're
not going to want to go anywhere uh our
uh our our latest and greatest behind
the scenes video from all the things
going down here at chess.com
headquarters during our coverage of the
fide World Chess Championship Match is
coming up after our final break along
with our final thoughts in studio Heroes
Fabiano rejoins us we bring you the
coinbase critical moment and still much
more so don't go anywhere we will be
right back
[Music]
thank you
just one point can make or break a
champion just one point determine the
winner and loser in zanzibar's 1961
general election the Cleveland Browns
came from 25 points behind to beat
Tennessee by just one point in an
unforgettable game on October 5th 2014.
and in 1935 Dutch chess player max over
beat the reigning world chess champion
by just one point the world was
suffering under a cloud of the Great
Depression tensions were high as Germany
began to rearm and Mussolini's Italy
attacked Ethiopia the World Chess
Championship held in multiple cities and
towns across the Netherlands offered a
distraction of the time in fact in one
newspaper the match was positioned as
bigger news than the situation in
Ethiopia
according to the custom at the time the
world chest title holder set the match
conditions
reigning champ Alexander aliakin
proposed the first player to win six
games and score more than 15 points
would be the champion
in those days there was no strict
qualification process to challenge the
title holder Atkins choice for an
opponent was conservative by most
standards OVA was considered by his
peers to be a consistent player solid
but not extraordinary
OVA had won a World amateur Championship
but mostly only played tournaments when
it did not clash with his math teaching
duties
throughout his life OVA refused to call
himself a professional chess player
whether it was overconfidence or simply
underestimating his opponent at Atkins
seemingly safe Choice wasn't a safe bet
after all over won the title by
overcoming a three-point deficit as late
as the ninth game at the end of 30 Games
Elva Beat the Champ by just one point
Eva wrote about the Victory and his
admiration for aliakin calling ayakan's
endgame shining but Al yankin would get
a chance to redeem himself and he did
two years later with a record-setting
win making him the very first player in
chess history to regain the title after
losing it the rematch was under the same
conditions in which Al yankin lost the
title in the first place
won easily 15 and a half to nine and a
half Atkins brilliant attacks coupled
with his endgame superiority helped him
to exact revenge on the math professor
but he wouldn't live to face another
Challenger he died shortly after World
War II before another match could take
place making the 1937 World Chess
Championship the last event where the
champion had control of the title and
could set match conditions
World War II sidelined the championship
for 10 years and after ayakin's death in
1946 for the first time since 1886 no
reigning Champion existed how would the
next World Champion be decided who would
step up and take control over the match
the world would have to wait to find out
coming up see how the game changed when
the dust settled in 1948.
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then selected
we are all back now here to bring you to
the final moments of chess.com's game 8
broadcast for the feeder World Chess
Championship before us on our amazing
House of Staunton board shout out to our
sponsors is the critical moment from the
game so that we can bring you the
coinbase critical moment let's give a
quick shout out to House of Staunton
once again the beautiful chess set you
see before you I think we might be
swapping it out after the next rest day
they sent us two so the next one we're
going to have set up is uh even pritzia
if you don't mind me saying so myself
not sure where it's coming from here but
I'm going to keep talking in the accent
right there okay uh yeah so anyway
deliciosodora right there go to
chess.com Staunton go.chess.com use the
promo code yes.com and get 15 off makes
a great holiday gift
also makes a great way to display
the coinbase critical coin you see I did
that see I combined two sponsors into
one thing the house of stone the
coinbase critical moment very skillful
just real quick sponsors like that they
love it they love it they probably don't
the critical moment of course was Jan's
blunder B5
um
much has been said about this all day
and uh
I think uh one of the final things we
took from the interview with LeBron is
that LeBron seems to be in his own head
a little bit right now and maybe that
led to the blunder more than just a move
here but all the moves before it too it
was a rushed move and there were three
very questionable decisions in this game
B5 was the beginning of the end I think
that Jan will have a hard time sleeping
after this move tonight yep
yeah this uh mistake came in pairs B5
followed by the magical Queen d8 yep
that was not what the doctor ordered in
fact just gave him a quick loss yeah and
so Jan was not really in it today and
likely do as Hammer said to game six and
the trauma that came about after losing
that one yep all right well speaking of
trauma another thing happened recently
in the Chess World that you know led to
some traumatic feelings some traumatic
uh views amongst the other the other top
chess players I I mean well at least
that's what they what they shared with
me all I know is it um it got heated in
our latest session of top chess players
Anonymous and you know Robert you were
we won't talk about let's just let's let
the video explain what happened and then
we'll we'll break down the big feelings
everyone had afterwards
okay welcome welcome again everybody to
top chess players Anonymous and uh we we
have a big day ahead reviewing our
topics from last week young I want to
thank you for sharing your feelings so
openly I know I know you're still a
little grumpy about it but it's okay
Hikaru thank you so much for for hearing
yon so well you've resonated and you
validated his feelings which is which is
sometimes all we can do so thank you
thank you for doing that so big topic
this week
um Maxime are you
ready to join us this week buddy no not
yet that's okay buddy that's okay when
you're ready okay when you're ready
um okay well I know we got a big topic
to get into this week right farouja made
2800. I know that everybody here is
feeling some very big feelings and big
feelings are okay that's why we're here
this is a safe place and it's safe to
share
um I just want to remind Hikaru and
Magnus that depending on how things go
we use our inside voices here our inside
voices for that
um Fabiano I know I know you're just
happy to be here so we really appreciate
you being with us whenever whenever you
show up that means the world to us so
okay well um
Robert
we we kind of talked about this I would
be great if you put away your phone at
these sessions
well I would appreciate it if Georg
stopped pointing a firearm at me because
that's also not allowed in these
sessions
yeah I hear I hear you on that thank you
thank you I I hear you on that York he's
he's got a point this this would be
something I'd like you to work on
starting next week to come to come to
these sessions as I've said with with
empty hands and Open Hearts can we do
that next week
okay thank you yeah I hear you on that
so okay as we get into the big topic we
all know the ground rules no one shares
unless they're holding the Conch um so
you need to have the Conch in your hand
before speaking I I've got the
controversial I will ask who would like
to raise their hand and uh share their
feelings
okay looks like Robert's going first
again
[Music]
I
I don't know that anyone else had the
ability to raise their hand in that
Circle in hindsight but Robert thank you
for
putting away your phone and for raising
your hand I was at a low point there I
was looking pretty disheveled I was in
the therapy session with my higher rated
friends and some of them pointing a gun
at you some of them have a gunpoint on
me wasn't wasn't the best yeah but I
listened to you you know I tried to
become a better person and I want to
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak my mind really appreciate that
and obviously yeah I mean the big topic
all there was a farusia made 2800
um you know obviously a lot of big
feelings in the rumor there and Bobby as
we said just thanks for always showing
up with a smile that's all
unfortunately that's not the most
ridiculous thing that we did
don't tell them about the other videos
okay that is that is my that is not the
most ridiculous thing I have like tears
I'm wiping away
the more there are plenty more
ridiculous things coming your way
because we uh
we're having a good time you know we're
having a lot of fun and obviously the
world championship still has
um many days ahead we hope that they are
exciting days but either way we have a
lot of excitement coming your way
um
there's the schedule before your very
eyes so that uh so that you don't miss a
single day of the action more videos
like that will continue to premiere on
these shows and then you can find them
on our Eclipse channel so let's remind
everybody again that you can subscribe
to our many YouTube channels because
we've got so much content going on our
best of moments today Fabiano had some
super educational stuff so did Robert
Hess and I already saw many of those
great clips shared their
um
I was watching the one you were giving
Robert about the positional goal of the
end game
um our team worked hard I mean seriously
some really good stuff over there uh so
subscribe to the clips Channel which is
where that video of top chess players
Anonymous and the others coming that
again fobby don't leak don't leak the
other stuff we did
well there's only one man who's leaking
stuff privately that's on his cure
that's on East Curie that's right he's
taking pictures of our DMS it's because
he's just jealous he was here he looked
at that picture he was like where's my
fat head in the room so we printed him
one out one but we'll uh we'll see mate
Anish you know if you if you behave
maybe we'll make you a permanent pick
you know fixture in these shows if you
behave okay we'll see how you perform on
Twitter today all right everyone uh
thanks so much for being here thank you
for uh for tuning in to what has been
eight wonderful days so far of the 2021
feta World Chess Championship we hope
you enjoy your rest day uh and uh real
quick shout out that on Tuesday our
guests will include once again Lavon
aronian again I hope Hammer's still
watching this so I can say our most
amazing guest Livonia rhodian you all
love big hammer and then we have uh the
man Rayne Wilson friend of mine and uh
big big chess fan and uh can't wait to
hear rain's thoughts on what's been
going down also a friend of magnus's so
I'm sure he's been following the World
Chess Championship closely uh so tune in
on Tuesday to hear what Rayne Wilson
best known as the actor Dwight in the TV
hit series The Office uh will be here on
Tuesday so with that we will uh wish
everybody a wonderful day if that's what
you're about to have if you're going to
sleep please have a good night dream
dream and and Dream well and sleep tight
and otherwise this is goodbye Dubai
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations
play a game start review and try it
today
thank you
[Music]
thank you